Aha, keine 20 Fehlerbehebungen später.
Fängt schon eine Sendung an. Und zwar, es handelt sich dabei um die Freakshow Nummer 290.
Freakshow international bekannt.
Grüße gehen raus an, wie hieß er? Fabian, den wir gerade noch auf der Straße getroffen haben.
Genau, der uns einfach so im Rudel erwischt hat und gleich meinte,
ob wir die Freakshow sind.
Weil wir sehen ja so aus.
Wir sehen ja so aus wie Fritsch.
Wir klingen wahrscheinlich so.
Ja, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, woran er uns eigentlich identifiziert hat.
Hat er euch nicht irgendwie vor mir sogar noch angesprochen?
Also er schlurpt ja auf jeden Fall vorher mit einem großen Lastenrad an uns
vorbei. Aber da tat er noch so, als würde er uns nicht kennen.
Er ist mir nämlich aufgefallen, vorher aufgrund dieses riesigen Rades, was er hatte.
Okay, wir haben das leider in dem Moment nicht geklärt, aber du kriegst jetzt
hier einen Spezialgruß.
Und der Die restlichen Grüße gehen raus an euch, die ihr diese Sendung lange
vermissen musstet, weil wir nicht in der Lage waren, einen Termin zu finden.
Ralf ist nämlich immer noch nicht bereit, Familie und Karriere hinten anzustellen.
Und es ist ja auf dem Opferalter der Freakshow der Öffentlichkeit feilen zu bieten.
Ich verstehe nicht warum, aber es ist so.
Und da ist es dann ein bisschen schwierig. Wir hatten, muss man sagen,
es war jetzt auch schwierig, dadurch, dass die Zeitzone so war,
dass es für mich sehr schwierig war,
diesen Spättermin zu realisieren, weil das sozusagen bedeutet hätte,
was hätte das eigentlich bedeutet, um zwei Uhr nachts anzufangen und naja.
Da wird man doch gerade erst warm.
Ich war ganz froh, dass ich mal in so einen normalen Aufsteh-Frühstücken-Termin-Modus
gekommen bin. Aber wie auch immer, ist ja egal.
Auf jeden Fall bist du da, Ralf.
Ich bin da.
Hallo. Alles, was wichtig ist, wie auch Roddy. Roddy ist auch da.
Ich bin auch da. Und ich würde, wo wir schon dabei waren, auch gerne noch jemanden grüßen.
Und zwar hat mir jemand, ich habe leider den Namen vergessen,
von meiner Amazon Wishlist etwas zugeschickt.
Ein Christian aus CH, zufällig. Ich habe nämlich auch was gesagt.
Kann sein. Und zwar nämlich von Spax.
Die extra Zelt-Teller-Kopfschrauben, die man bei Spax erwerben kann.
Es gibt spezielle Tellerkopfschrauben für Zeltbau?
Ja, von Spax. In einem Paket, da sind noch so Plastik-Unterlegscheiben drunter,
damit man da irgendwie mehr Halt hat.
Aber ist eine Tellerkopfschraube noch irgendwas anderes speziell von Spax?
Ich glaube nur der Preis.
Die Verpackung ist auch ganz nett, weil das ist so ein Plastikrohr,
was man so auseinander und zusammenschieben kann, wie so Kunststudenten sowas
immer dabei haben oder Architekten.
Die nennt man sowas überhaupt, so eine Verpackung. Da gibt es doch bestimmt
irgendeinen speziellen Namen für, den man irgendwie im Baumarkt eingeben kann.
Ich weiß es auch nicht, aber ich habe sowas, glaube ich, in meinem Werkzeug,
in meinem Bohrmaschinen-Set.
Aber du weißt, was ich meine, so auseinanderschraubbare Röhre.
Genau.
Genau, sowas war da drin.
Da habe ich so meine Meißel- und Langbohrer drin.
Also an dieser Stelle vielen Dank.
Ja, aber jetzt wissen wir immer noch nicht, wie es heißt. Gibt es bestimmt Schraub...
Röhretubedose.
Schraubtubenröhren. Dosen-Tube.
All diese Dinge haben spezielle Namen. Das finde ich immer so bemerkenswert.
Es muss ja auch alles irgendwie mal bestellt werden.
Weißt du, wie diese Dinger heißen? Diese Plastik-Dingsis, die verhindern,
dass eine Schnur irgendwie durch eine Öse geht, wenn man so drauf drückt und
dann kann man da so rein und rausziehen?
Aber ich...
Kordelstopper. Also falls du mal
sowas bestellen willst, der Suchbegriff Kordelstopper, da bekommst du das.
Aber ich habe ja gelernt, dass ja in unseren modernen Zeiten tatsächlich diese
LLMs sind ja nur perfekt für das Ergänzen.
Das heißt, wenn man alles andere schon weiß, dann fragt man einfach,
wie heißt äh, ähm, wie heißt, ich, Moment, anders, ich,
Aua, ich suche nach dem Namen für ein Verpackungselement,
das aus zwei Plastikröhren besteht.
Die sich ineinander verschrauben lassen.
Darin kann man zum Beispiel sehr gut lange schrauben oder Bohrer unterbringen
oder posteren. Meint ihr, das reicht?
Versuch's.
Hit it.
Das, was du beschreibst, ist häufig unter dem Begriff Teleskophülse,
Teleskopverpackung oder Schraubrohrverpackung bekannt.
Weitere mögliche Bezeichnungen sind Kunststoffteleskopröhre,
Schraubhülse, Schraubrohrverpackungsröhre mit Schraubverschluss.
Schraubrohr. Das ist mein Favorit, glaube ich.
Wenn du danach im Internet suchen müsstest, kannst du zum Beispiel folgende
Begriffe ausprobieren. Teleskopverpackung Kunststoff.
Das klingt für mich ein bisschen geraten.
Nein, die AI würde das nie tun.
Aber?
Also unter Google kriegt man bei Teles... Na, okay.
Okay. Also Teleskopverpackung bei Google bringt Pappkartons,
die sich so ausziehen lassen in der Länge. Auch interessant.
Alibaba, 100 Stücke, runde Form, Kunststoff, Injektion, Teleskop,
Verpackung, Rohr-Teleskop, Kunststoff, Paketbox für CNC-Endfräser.
Aber das ist in etwa sowas.
Also unter Schraubröhre ist eher so ein Reagenz, Plastikreagenzglas,
was man oben zuschrauben kann.
Hm.
Also ich weiß nicht.
Aber ich habe auf jeden Fall deine Spax-Zeltschrauben gefunden.
Ah ja, okay.
Spax-Camping ist eine eigene, mittlerweile machen sie noch eine eigene Untergruppe draus.
Ja, es wird alles.
Täterkopfschraube mit Plastik, schnuppsi drunter.
Genau.
Ja, okay.
Da sind sogar, also es sind zwei verschiedene große Schrauben drin gewesen und
auch die Bits, die man braucht, weil das sind Torx-Schrauben und die entsprechenden
Torx-Bits waren auch mit dabei.
Das ist natürlich sehr gut. Und sind es 40er oder 50er?
Ich glaube je eins.
Nein, ich meine die Größe der Torx. Ist es T40 oder T50?
Wie gesagt, je eins. Weil es sind unterschiedlich große Schrauben,
deswegen sind unterschiedlich große Bits dabei und ich glaube es ist ein 40er und ein 50er.
Also auf der Webseite hier bei dem Packen steht es ein T30 und T40.
Na gut. Na gut.
Ich bin ja auf T50 gegangen, weil ich wollte es ja so richtig hart haben.
Aber ich musste dann schnell erkennen, wenn auch bisher noch nicht zu meinem
Nachteil, aber nahezu alle, wenn nicht wirklich sogar alle Sets,
Bitsets, die ich so typischerweise in Werkzeugkoffer so antreffe,
da ist dann bei T40 Schluss.
Man kann ja auch Einzelbits kaufen.
Ja, das heißt aber, wenn ich meinen verliere, dann muss ich zum Baumarkt fahren
und kann nicht einfach irgendjemand fragen.
Ansonsten, ich glaube, einmal pro Jahr muss man das sagen. Leute,
wenn da draußen noch irgendjemand ist, der noch Kreuzschrauben verwendet.
Kreuzschlitzschrauben.
Wegschmeißen und nach Talks googeln und das ist die eine Maßnahme,
die jedes Heimwerkern auf ein völlig neues Level bringt. Die eine Maßnahme,
die man wirklich machen muss.
Alles wegschmeißen, und neu. Talks.
Also ich bin inzwischen auch ein Fan von Torx.
Von was denn sonst?
Zumindest mit dem Akkubohrschrauber ist Torx schon besser.
Aber ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass es das auf einen neuen Level hebt,
sondern das ist schon praktisch.
Naja, aber Kreuzschlitz ist schon bekloppt.
Und hier im Chat schreibt jemand, der hätte noch Schlitzschrauben.
Das ist natürlich like an animal.
Ja, Schlitzschrauben kannst du ja mit einem Akkubohrschrauber eigentlich gar
nicht sinnvoll verwenden.
Also Leute, da fange ich überhaupt gar nicht ran zu diskutieren. Kauft Torx.
Wie lange gibt es den? Standard auch schon 20 Jahre oder sowas.
Sind so richtig Mainstream, mindestens seit 15. Also da reden wir jetzt nicht.
Ja, es ist schlecht zu argumentieren, dass man Torx jetzt nicht haben will. Das sehe ich ein.
Torx ist eine Marke von Argument Intellectual Properties in Michigan,
die in den 1970er Jahren als Wortmarke und in den 1990er Jahren als Wortbildmarke
von Textron in Deutschland registriert wurde. Okay.
Ja. Naja.
Torx von Spax.
Aber Torx ist ja auch nicht gleich Torx. Es gibt Torx, es gibt Torx Plus,
Torx TR und Torx Plus Security.
Ja, und ob mit genau Loch in der Mitte oder nicht. Das sind nämlich die TR und die Security.
Naja, also wer wirklich die noch nicht hat, anschauen, ausprobieren und ihr wisst warum.
Ja, das ist einfach so. Das ist schon wirklich eine interessante technologische
Entwicklung, so klein sie von außen aussehen mag. Naja gut, wie schön,
dass wir abschweifen, das können wir nämlich besonders gut.
Womit wollen wir denn diese wunderbare Sendung beginnen? Vielleicht mit einem kurzen Reise-Update.
Sagt doch mal jeweils euer Lieblingsgericht von eurer ganzen Reise.
Ihr wart jetzt beide weit weg.
Was ist das eine Gericht, wo ihr denkt, warum zum Teufel gibt es das hier nicht um die Ecke?
Die Leute würden reich werden, wenn sie das hier anbieten würden.
Ich weiß, okay. Du zuerst, Roddy.
Ja, meine Antwort habt ihr ja schon gehört. Meine Antwort ist Chicken Lollipops.
Was sind Chicken Lollipops?
Chicken Lollipops sind so quasi Hühnerkeulen, wo das Gelenkende so ein bisschen entfernt wird.
Dann kommt da Alufolie rum. Also der Alufolie kommt zum Schluss rum.
Der Bereich, wo eigentlich das Fleisch ist, da kommt nochmal so eine Panade, ähnliche Dings drauf.
So ein Backteig ähnlich?
Ja, so ein Backteig ähnlich, genau. Und dann wird es halt zubereitet,
sodass es schön juicy ist.
Und dann kommt aufs andere Ende Alufolie und dann kann man die so an der Folie
nehmen und so wie so ein Lollipop halt so da so runterknabbern.
Wie viele davon holt man sich in einem Durchgang?
Na, so ein halbes Dutzend sind das meistens so bis acht Stück,
zehn Stück. Das hängt sehr stark davon ab, wie das Restaurant das halt handhabt.
Aber so halbes Dutzend bis zehn Stück, würde ich mal sagen.
Das habe ich auch schon bemängelt, dass es die in Berlin nicht gibt.
Also ich wüsste zumindest nicht wo.
Wer den Trend nach Europa holt, könnte reich werden, finde ich.
Siehste, genau solche Infos müssen wir hier verbreiten. Und Tim,
du, was sagst du? Die eine Sache.
Also ich will jetzt gar nicht so groß mit dem tollen Essen, was ich hatte auf
der Reise rumprahlen, weil ich habe gut gegessen, ich habe auch mal nicht so gut gegessen.
Es gab jetzt aber auch nicht so viele Momente, wo ich sagen würde,
so jetzt aber alles anders als vorher und so. Und vor allem,
was mich wirklich genervt hat, ist,
Ich habe ja schon in Berlin immer Probleme, in Restaurants wirklich scharfes
Essen zu bekommen, selbst wenn man fünfmal sagt, man möchte es,
ja, man wird wirklich scharf und so, wie ihr das auch essen würdet und so und
dann ist es immer noch nicht scharf, weil die tuscheln dann immer in der Küche und sagen so.
Der sieht nicht so aus, der hat schon weiße Haare, der kippt uns um,
macht das nicht, Jungen.
Das gibt nur Ärger mit der Versicherung.
Deswegen kriegst du einfach hier nie was Scharfes, aber es ist mir auch ehrlich
gesagt, jetzt in Asien, Und mit einer Ausnahme, das war, also was wirklich scharf
war, das ist auch etwas, wo ich gehört habe, das ist hier mittlerweile ein Trend.
Hotpot. Das ist jetzt hip.
Hotpot.
Das machen gerade überall Hotpot-Restaurants auf, wurde mir gesagt.
Ich habe das allerdings erst auf der Reise kennengelernt.
Den Trend habe ich auch wahrgenommen, aber noch nicht teilgenommen.
Also ich war auch noch nicht bei einem Hotpot dabei.
Ja, ich schon.
Was zeichnet ein Hotpot aus?
Na, Hotpot ist halt einfach, das ist so eine chinesische Nummer.
Ich hatte das, Grüße an Stefan, aus Indonesien, Bali, da habe ich das ausprobiert
und das sind im Wesentlichen so spezialisierte Restaurants.
Da hast du so ein großes Geblubber vor dir und du schmeißt da irgendwie alles mögliche rein.
Also Hotpot ist halt einfach super scharfes Essen.
Der Name ist Programm Das war ganz okay was ich am besten Kredenz bekommen hatte
wo ich wirklich gesagt habe oh wow, was ist das denn?
Das ist Laksa Laksa ist so in Singapur und Malaysia vor allem ich glaube in
Singapur gilt es sogar als Nationalgericht das ist einfach so eine super.
Angeblich Kokosmilch, Chili, keine Ahnung, was da alles drin war, war halt so ein Teller.
Und das ist ja generell, also ich muss sagen, in einer Hinsicht hat Asien in
gewisser Hinsicht so eine Schwäche.
Und zwar, man isst da immer alles aus ganz vielen, ist mehr so Tapas-mäßig.
Also du bestellst immer irgendwas und der ganze Teller, der ganze Tisch ist
voll mit tausend Schüsselchen dieses und jenes und so weiter.
Und wenn du jetzt so als Europäer in so ein Restaurant reingehst und du suchst
dir eine Vorspeise aus und dann das Hauptgericht, das funktioniert dann nicht.
Du kriegst immer alles gleichzeitig. Im Zweifelsfall kriegst du immer das Hauptgericht
zuerst und später dann irgendwie noch die Suppe oder so, weißt du?
Keine Ahnung, was irgendwie nicht funktioniert in unserer kulturellen Vorschau.
Es war selbst auf Hinweis nicht möglich in irgendeiner Form da so ein Zeitmanagement
in die Auslieferung hineinzubekommen.
Ich hab's dann irgendwann aufgegeben. Man nimmt's einfach so,
wie's kommt oder bestellt einfach generell alles so parallel.
Genau, also Lachsa war super, das war richtig lecker.
Das erinnert mich an den Begriff Lachsativ, hat damit aber nichts zu tun, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist, von daher kann ich dir das nicht sagen.
Das ist, wenn man Verdauungsprobleme hat, dann kann man ein Lachsativ nehmen und dann geht's wieder.
Ja, ich hatte zumindest keine Verdauungsprobleme danach.
So, und was war noch? Ah ja, genau, dann war ich noch in meiner letzten Etappe
war ich in Vietnam, in Hoi An.
Hoi An ist so eine ganz hübsche, historische, vietnamesische Stadt,
wo ganz viel so Kolonialarchitektur noch seinen Einfluss gefunden hat und auch erhalten hat.
Von daher ist es wirklich nett da. Also ich fand es wirklich,
wirklich, wirklich sehr angenehm dort.
Und in der Gegend ist man Khao Lau.
Kao Lau, also C-A-O-L-A-U und das ist einfach so eine lecker schmeckende Suppe
mit so ein bisschen Schweinfleisch und Gedöns und Nudeln und so.
Kann man jetzt nicht beschreiben, wie das schmeckt. Schmeckt halt einfach gut.
Da gibt es auch noch tausend andere Sachen, die gut schmecken.
Aber das ist da so ein bisschen das städtische Nationalgericht.
Wie ist es denn da mit der Schärfe?
Wie gesagt, enttäuschend. Also es war einfach alles nicht scharf genug.
Okay. Aber dann nächstes Mal Indien, kann ich nur sagen.
Da fliegt es richtig.
Sagen wir mal so, die nehmen einen nicht ernst, wenn man sagt, not spicy.
Also andersrum.
Also man hat das Gefühl, die Inder kennen den Unterschied nicht zwischen Gewürzen und Chili.
Für die ist Chili auch ein Gewürz. Spicy heißt halt, dass man das gewürzt hat.
Genau und schwarzer Pfeffer und grüner Chili und roter Chili gehört halt einfach
zu den Gewürzen und es gehört zum Essen dazu und es ist eigentlich alles scharf.
Also es geht schon beim Frühstück los mit den Dosas, da ist mindestens eine
scharfe Soße dabei und das endet irgendwann später abends, keine Ahnung, beim Snacken oder so.
Ich fand es nach drei Wochen extrem anstrengend, dass alles irgendwie scharf war.
Also selbst die Pizza war irgendwie auf der Schärfeskala nicht da,
wo er in Italiener sich verorten würde.
Ja, also im Prinzip esse ich gerne scharf, aber ab einem bestimmten Punkt hätte
man auch gerne mal wieder was, was einfach nicht wehtut.
Sag ich mal so.
Na gut, soviel zum Essen. Also ich habe da nicht leiden müssen,
aber es ist mir auch da gelungen, mal was zu bekommen, was nicht so mein Ding ist.
Ich glaube, dass ich generell so mit dem chinesischen Essen so ein bisschen
mehr Schwierigkeiten habe.
Sehr sehr,
ungewöhnliche Mischung von Sachen.
Also ich kann das jetzt nicht genauer beschreiben, aber weiß ich nicht.
Ich hatte dann manchmal so als Trotzreaktion, jetzt gehe ich zum Inder.
Wobei gute Inder habe ich jetzt da auch nicht gefunden außerhalb von Indien. Naja.
Man kriegt in Indien auch chinesisches Essen, aber es ist trotzdem indisch scharf.
Also es ist einfach alles scharf.
Du meinst jetzt aber asiatisches Essen, nicht chinesisches.
Nein, nein, ich meine schon explizit chinesisches Essen. Also mit China ist
das ja so eine Sache in dieser Region.
Das ist ja da so ein bisschen, was für uns so USA ist, ist für Asien so China.
Da gibt es ganz viele von und das drückt sich überall rein und jetzt war ich
ja insgesamt, ich war in Singapur, ich war in Malaysia, ich war kurz auf Bali,
ich war in Thailand, ich war in Taiwan und dann war ich noch in Vietnam.
Und Taiwan ist ja auch China und das andere China sozusagen.
Wenn die Landungsboote kommen.
Und Malaysia, Penang, der Bereich, wo ich war, ist auch ganz stark chinesisch
geprägt und Singapur ja auch.
Also das sind sozusagen Regionen. Also Singapur gilt überhaupt so als der chinesisch freundlichste,
also das China-freundlichste Gebiet außerhalb Chinas ist Singapur.
Und dementsprechend ist dann halt auch mal das Essen und die Kultur immer so ein bisschen anders.
Taiwan wiederum war ganz wirklich sehr interessant.
Das ist so ein bisschen das Deutschland Asiens, habe ich so den Eindruck. Also das ist so sehr,
geordnet. Also da geht es sehr geordnet zu.
Ich mache das ja immer alles am Verkehr fest. Und mir wurde von jedem Land vorher
erzählt, oh, da, da ist aber voll krasser Verkehr und so, da musst du voll aufpassen.
Das habe ich auch von Taiwan erzählt bekommen. Kann ich überhaupt nicht bestätigen.
Das ist da wie in Deutschland. Ganz viele Ampeln, alle halten bei Rot und so
weiter. Total enttäuschend.
Also das war mir alles zu aufgeräumt da.
Alle nett, gar keine Frage, aber sehr geordnet.
Architektonisch ein bisschen enttäuschend. Ich fand, da war nicht so viel zu
holen. Da ist nicht so viel.
Die haben irgendwie keine so richtige Hausbaukultur.
Es sieht alles ein bisschen scheppig aus.
Die Tabanesen.
Ja, ja. Es ist alles so gefließt. Weiß ich nicht. Also mir hat die Optik nicht so gepasst.
Und vor allem aus der Historie heraus, dass sie damals sehr viel Übergriffiges
erleiden mussten in ihrer frühen Geschichte,
hat sich da so eine Kultur der Vergitterung etabliert.
Also du schaust dich halt um und Fenster, auch im zehnten Stock,
sind irgendwie vergittert.
Wo man sich fragt,
habt ihr irgendwie eine hohe Suizidrate oder was ist das Problem?
Ja, wenn die Drohnen kommen.
Aber das scheint sich eher so kulturell manifestiert zu haben.
Also es gab tatsächlich sozusagen als, wir wollen hier, dass die Schergen des
bösen Governments nicht uns einfach mal ins Haus reinfallen.
Deswegen ist alles vergittert und dann ist das irgendwie so kulturell so geblieben.
Moderne Gebäude nicht mehr.
Das kenne ich von Jamaika auch. Also da haben Maueröffnungen gerne mal Gitter, aber selten Glas.
Also es gibt auch keine Fenster, die du zumachen kannst bist ja auch froh da
ist aber auch die Sicherheitslage noch entsprechend,
Da ist die Sicherheitslage relativ...
Genau, und das ist ja in Taiwan überhaupt nicht der Fall. Also Taiwan ist ja total,
also wenn ich Leute auf Kriminalität angesprochen habe, da hast du nur leere
Gesichtsausdrücke gesehen.
Das findet da kaum statt.
Ich habe halt gefragt, warum?
Und da gab es im Wesentlichen so zwei Antworten. Das eine ist so, ja, machen wir nicht.
Also die sind sich da...
Warum auch?
Ja, das ist ja auch, sagen wir mal, eine vergleichsweise gute austarierte Gesellschaft.
Also überhaupt da, wo ich war, gibt es auch andere Regionen, gar keine Frage.
Aber so, ich weiß nicht, als sie nach Berlin kamen, ging das dann wieder schnell
so mit der Obdachlosigkeit los. Das ist ein Phänomen, das ich dort nicht wahrgenommen habe in Taiwan.
Und der zweite Grund, warum es keine Kriminalität gibt, weil überall Kameras
sind und alles wird irgendwie auch super überwacht.
Ich habe eine Story erzählt bekommen, ja, irgendjemand hat ihm was von seinem
Roller geklaut und dann haben sie
wirklich den Typen nicht nur per Kamera Überwachungsnachvollziehungsblatt,
das Wort ist kaputt,
gefunden, sondern die haben dann die Polizei den Täter dann auch noch genötigt,
sich persönlich zu entschuldigen.
Also es ist irgendwie alles fremde Länder, andere Sitten und ich bin ganz weit
davon entfernt ein vollständiges.
Kulturstruktogramm Taiwans erstellt zu haben in meiner Anwesenheit,
aber ich bin gut rumgekommen und ja, aber der Verkehr war enttäuschend,
ich hätte es gern so wie in Vietnam, das war die beste Mischung.
Ich kann dazu nur sagen, Bombay-Verkehr, der beste Vergleich ist eine Sanduhr.
Fließt irgendwie, also es verkeilt sich nicht komplett, aber es fließt,
aber es fließt sehr langsam und Hupen gehört zum guten Ton dazu.
Da gibt es sogar LKWs, da steht dann sowas drauf wie OK Sound Horn,
was so viel heißt wie Fahrer träumt halt, wenn man vorbei will,
soll man halt hupen, dann ist er aufmerksam und lässt einen durch.
Das ist, es gibt wohl Bundesländer in Indien, wo solche Beschriftungen inzwischen
verboten sind, weil wir versuchen das ständige Gehupe irgendwie in den Griff zu kriegen,
aber also ich habe viel, also man kennt ja diese bunt bemalten indischen LKWs,
die sind da durchaus noch Standard.
Und das ist auch durchaus Standard, dass die, naja, wenn da eine zweispurige
Straße, also zwei Spuren in jede Richtung Straße ist, dass die dann auch nicht
in den Spuren fahren, sondern halt irgendwo.
Und wenn man dann vorbei will, dann muss man halt hupen und dann fährt er irgendwie
nach innen oder nach außen, weiß man nicht genau.
Und dann kann man ihn auf der anderen Seite überholen.
Ja, aber was auf jeden Fall überall ganz gut funktioniert hat, war Internet.
Das SIM-Kartenspiel, das funktioniert da wunderbar.
Du kommst irgendwo an und noch bevor du am Zoll vorbeigegangen bist,
hast du schon die ersten SIM-Kartenverkäufer vor deiner Nase.
Also noch am Gepäckband kriegst du sozusagen gleich deine SIM-Karte aufgedrückt,
wo du dann krasse 10 Euro zahlen musst für Unlimited Internet auf deiner SIM-Karte,
die du dann direkt reingesteckt und enabled bekommst und fertig.
Aber physisch reale Karten.
Keine eSIMs. Es gab auch E-SIM-Lösungen, die ich aber nicht näher angeschaut habe,
weil ich habe ja einen Slot frei,
weil ich habe meine normale SIM-Karte ist E-SIM und dann habe ich mir für die
Reise bei Aerolo, das hatte ich ja schon mal angesprochen, das sind so eine Apps.
Es gibt auch noch andere, die habe ich aber jetzt nicht so ausprobiert.
Andere Leute benutzen andere Sachen.
Aber Aerolo hat für mich so ganz gut funktioniert und ich habe jetzt preislich
nicht so einen großen Unterschied gesehen.
Also es ist nicht billig, aber es ist super convenient.
Du kaufst halt vorher, also ich habe halt bevor ich losgefahren bin,
einmal Aerolo so eine SIM-Karte runtergeladen für Asia.
Und da waren dann irgendwie alle Destinationen, die ich grob im Sinn hatte und
die es dann letztlich auch geworden sind, waren da alle mit abgedeckt.
Hatte dann irgendwie meine 50 GB drauf und so hatte ich halt immer so dieses Default.
Also ich lande irgendwo, Airplane-Modus aus, eingeloggt, Internet,
man kann Taxi bestellen, bevor man irgendwie auch nur Geld gewechselt hat und ich habe dann.
Auch damit weitgehend gearbeitet.
Man hat halt überall WLAN. Also das erste Café, wo ich keinen WLAN hatte,
auf dieser ganzen Reise war das Café, wo ich heute in Berlin war. Das erste.
Also alle anderen, da steht das
halt schon an der Kasse, das WLAN-Passwort groß oder auf dem Menü drauf.
Also nicht nur, dass du eins bekommst auf Zuruf, sondern es ist einfach selbstverständlich,
es gibt eine Kasse, es gibt einen Ort, wo du bestellen kannst,
es gibt ein Klo und es gibt ein WLAN-Passwort.
Das ist einfach Standard. Überall, egal, wo du bist.
RALO hatte ich in der Ukraine. Das hat da ganz gut funktioniert.
In Indien, da wollten die unglaublich viel Geld verglichen damit,
was man für eine Karte von vor Ort.
Ja, vor Ort ist natürlich immer viel, viel, viel billiger.
Und das Geilste ist, Und ich habe dort in so einem Shop so eine Karte erstanden
und da muss man eigentlich den Pass vorzeigen.
Und jetzt hatte ich den Pass, der war aber im Hotel, also habe ich den Personalausweis
vorgezeigt und dann hat der Typ so ein bisschen so,
hat mir dann doch eine Karte verkauft und dann habe ich die reingetan,
dann habe ich von dem entsprechenden Anbieter die App installiert und man kann dann mit so einer,
ja, dann schicken sie dir eine SMS und dann kannst du dich da anmelden und dann
hast du plötzlich dein Konto, was zu der Karte gehört, in dieser App drin und ich sage mal so,
Ekaterina Lyubimova die sich dann offiziell für RTL schöner Name,
ja ne auf gut Deutsch, der hat da irgendwie scheinbar den Pass oder Personalausweis
von irgendeiner Russin wieder verwendet,
um auf den Namen dann die Karte zu machen ist auch Mr, also das sieht man jetzt
in dem Screenshot nicht, aber es war auch Mr.
Ekaterina also das war schon sehr geil.
Okay, nobody cares.
Ja, hat aber nichts gekostet. Also ich glaube, es waren 5 Euro für 30 Tage,
jeden Tag 2 Gigabyte oder so.
Ja. Aber was ich jetzt bei Eralo zu schätzen gelernt habe, ich habe mir ein
E-SIM gekauft, ich habe gesagt, ja, einmal Asia, irgendwie alle Länder,
wo ich hin wollte, waren dabei und es hat auch funktioniert und,
es war so frictionless, es war einfach so easy travel, als wäre das alles EU.
Obwohl du überall andere Währungen und andere Sünden hast. Ist schon sehr,
nett. Allerdings, auch die Unlimited-Karten hatten ein Limit,
wie sich dann später herausgestellt hat.
Also zumindest die, die ich in Vietnam gekauft hatte.
Also die ist zwar Unlimited in dem Sinne, dass sie sagen, dass du da nicht so
eine Begrenzung hast, also nicht so wie jetzt in Deutschland mit 10 Gigabyte und dann ist Schluss.
Ja, aber sie nennt es ja trotzdem Flatrate.
Sie nennt es Unlimited. War aber nicht Unlimited. Wie ich später herausgestellt
habe, gibt es ein Tageslimit.
Ich weiß aber nicht genau, wo das lag.
Kann ich jetzt nur raten. Deswegen mach ich es jetzt nicht.
Aber das war so, es gab ein Tageslimit und am nächsten Tag ging es dann wieder.
Davon hatten sie mir aber entweder nichts gesagt oder ich hab das Kleingedruckte nicht gelesen.
Muss aber sagen, das wäre vielleicht ja auch mal was für Deutschland,
wenn sie einem schon nicht wirklich Unlimited geben wollen, dann warum nicht ein Tageslimit?
Also ein sinnvolles Tageslimit, ja.
Dann ist es auch nicht Unlimited, aber es ist nicht so blöd Unlimited wie in
einem Monat und dann, keine Ahnung,
100 Gigabyte und dann hast du drei verbraucht und kannst aber die 97 nicht mit
den nächsten Monaten nehmen und es ist alles irgendwie doof.
Und das muss ich hier ändern.
Wie gesagt, ich hatte auch dieses 2 GB pro Tag,
Und bin da aber nie reingelaufen in diese zwei Gigabyte. Aber gut.
Mein Anbieter, bei dem ich ja bin, Frank, wir erinnern uns mit diesem Wasserfallmodell,
wo man für jeden, den man weiter anwirbt, zwei oder drei Gigabyte drauf bekommt.
Die haben jetzt nochmal so ein lustiges Konzept vor, ich glaube bis Ostern läuft
das, glaube ich, wenn da draußen jemand auch bei denen ist, wo man 50 Gigabyte
Sicherheitspuffer sich geschenkt bekommt.
Den claimst du also einmal in der App und dann hast du so einen 50 Gigabyte
Polster und das kannst du einsetzen, wann immer du willst und wird aber übertragen.
Das finde ich nochmal so eine ganz nette Safety Net Geschichte.
Wobei ich jetzt dank Wasserfallmodell bin ich da jetzt schon bei 54 Gigabyte
und von denen kriege ich halt so pro Monat so vier oder fünf weg.
Also das ist schon, irgendwo ist es mit diesem Unlimited dann auch so ein bisschen virtuell.
Also Wasserfallmodell ist bei
mir was anderes und das hat einen ganz komischen Namen, Klang aber egal.
Schneeballsystem ist glaube ich der Wasserfall.
Ist im Development.
Das klassische Wie heißt diese Scam-Geschichte? Ist das so ein Schneeballsystem?
Schneeballsystem oder Pyramid Scheme Pyramid Scheme.
Also der oben reibt sich die Hände und alle anderen unten drunter müssen leiden Ja.
Dann noch vielleicht ein paar Eindrücke zum iPhone im Ausland als Lebensretter.
Also ich habe mich jetzt schon sehr oft an Orten bewegt, wo kein Englisch war.
Restaurants, wo einfach die Speisekarte, die war dann einfach auf Chinesisch und das war so.
Und da saß ich dann davor und musste rauskriegen, was ist denn das?
Und da muss ich sagen, da sind so die Tools schon richtig geil.
Also vor allem erstmal Google Lens, muss man ja sagen.
Das funktioniert ganz großartig in der normalen Google-App. Du fotografierst
halt so eine Speisekarte und kriegst also in Place,
Die Übersetzung und das haut ganz gut hin. Zumindest so gut,
dass man da mit arbeiten kann.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt kam übrigens diese iOS 18.4 Beta raus und dann hatte ich auf
meinem Telefon auch Visual Intelligence.
Das habe ich dann auch mal ausprobiert. Also Visual Intelligence ist jetzt hier,
ich habe ja das neueste iPhone, dann klickst du hier auf diesen neuen Kamera-Button.
Lange drauf, glaube ich, war das, ne, mit der Visual Intelligence. Genau.
Und dann hältst du das halt auf irgendwas drauf und dann, lass ich mal kurz hier ausprobieren.
Genau, dann hast du nämlich hier auch so einen Fotografier-Button.
Halt doch mal auf mich drauf und dann kommt da muss abnehmen oder,
mehr Sport.
Keine Ahnung, also ich hab halt, er hat halt hier so Fragen suchen und dann,
wenn er Text erkennt, auch übersetzen und das funktioniert dann halt so ähnlich,
aber nicht so gut wie Google Lens.
Das lag daran, dass sie den Text nicht so gut platziert bekommen und das dann
irgendwie neu formatieren.
Bei einer Speisekarte ist das dann ein bisschen bekloppt, wenn der Text nicht
genau an der Stelle ist, wo du ihn fotografiert hast.
Von daher da ist noch einiges dran zu machen.
Aber ich fand es erstaunlich, wie man also ohne irgendwelche Language Skills
in Chinesisch einfach so in einem Restaurant schon mal sieht,
so okay, das, das, das, das.
Dann hast du natürlich nochmal oft das Problem, dass die Bezeichnungen dir dann
unter Umständen auch nicht viel sagen, was es sich dabei handelt.
Und dann ist natürlich die nächste Eskalationsstufe, ist halt einfach Chat-GPT
zu nehmen und einfach die Speisekarte zu fotografieren und zu sagen, so,
Schlag mir mal was vor.
Okay.
Erklär mir mal, was das ist. Was sind hier die Spezialitäten?
Was sind hier die lokalen Sachen? Und so weiter.
Und so habe ich mich also durch koreanische Speisekarten durchgearbeitet und
durch chinesische Speisekarten und vietnamesische Speisekarten.
Das war wirklich erstaunlich gut, was man da so machen kann.
Ja, also iPhone, also nicht nur iPhone natürlich, also jetzt Smartphone als,
universeller Bubblefish where,
da sind wir jetzt also das ist einfach,
ja es geht alles noch ein bisschen schicker, schöner und so weiter,
aber es ist schon erstaunlich wie die sich einfach durch so andere Kulturlandschaften
durchfräsen da und Und dir einfach sagen, was Phase ist, sodass du dann eine
qualifizierte Entscheidung treffen kannst.
Ja, das Problem hat man natürlich in Indien nicht ganz so, weil da gibt es ja
so viele Sprachen auf dem Subkontinent und das Einzige, was sie gemeinsam haben, ist Englisch.
Wenn man es denn versteht, geht es halt.
Also ich hatte so das Gefühl, dass je älter die Leute sind, desto besser ist
das Englisch zu verstehen.
Weil man merkt, die jüngste Generation hat schon keine Englischlehrer mehr,
die irgendwie Englisch in England gelernt haben.
Und das ist so ein bisschen schwierig. Da muss man sich echt schwer reinhören.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen kommt man eigentlich überall durch damit.
Wo das Smartphone natürlich auch noch richtig wichtig ist, sind Karten.
Und natürlich stellte sich für mich auch wieder die Frage, okay,
wie sieht es aus, Google Maps versus Apple Maps.
Ich hatte besonders hohen Kartenbedarf in Taiwan, weil ich da sehr viel alleine
unterwegs war und sehr viel mit dem Moped unterwegs war.
Und da hat sich auch nochmal so eine generelle Problematik gezeigt.
Also erst mal, Apple Maps war nicht benutzbar.
In Indien auch so.
Das ist ja schon in Deutschland ein Problem.
Hier geht es gerade noch so, aber es ist immer wieder das Ding,
du hast einfach in Apple Maps nicht diese Ortstiefe von Organisationen und Orten.
Ja, obwohl Google Maps inzwischen auch langsam nachlässt, habe ich so das Gefühl.
Ja, aber die Leute tragen da halt, also wenn sie es irgendwo eintragen,
dann tragen sie es halt erst da ein.
Das stimmt.
Und auch in Deutschland, ich bin hier schon auf so viele Restaurantbesitzer
gestoßen, die einfach noch nicht mal auf die Idee gekommen sind,
sich auch mal bei Apple Maps mal zu aktualisieren.
Und wenn wird es halt teilweise nicht angezeigt, das hatten wir ja auch schon
mal in der Sendung. okay, ihr erinnert euch, selbst in der maximalen Zoom-Stufe
ist ein Drittel der Buden. Hier wird nicht angezeigt.
Wenn du sie danach suchst, kriegst du aber die Pins. Also in der Datenbank sind sie, aber warum?
Ja, aber ich rede jetzt weniger von so einem visuellen Problem.
Das mag natürlich auch nochmal bestehen und mal so, mal so sein.
Da weiß man ja auch immer nicht genau, wie diese Orte verzeichnet sind.
Aber, ja. Aber was für mich eigentlich noch viel wichtiger war, war Navigation.
Und bei der Navigation gibt es da so eine Schwierigkeit, die mich teilweise
hier auch schon geärgert hat, aber die in Taiwan ein echtes Problem ist.
Und zwar du hast halt in der Regel die Möglichkeit, Navigation zu machen für zu Fuß gehen,
Für Auto. Und wenn du Glück hast, gibt es Fahrrad.
Und öffentlichen Nahverkehr.
Fahrrad musst du aber auch Glück haben.
Und öffentlichen Nahverkehr, aber Fahrrad ist schon so nicht immer da.
Aber was halt in Deutschland gar nicht da ist, ist Motorrad.
Wo man sich halt fragt, wo ist der Unterschied? Und tatsächlich in Deutschland
ist der Unterschied nicht so nennenswert.
Das ist aber in Taiwan ganz anders.
Und da ist es auch so, da gibt es nochmal eine weitere Kategorie,
nämlich du musst unterscheiden zwischen Motorrad, das ist tatsächlich meistens wie Auto, und Scooter.
Weil diese Scooter, also diese normalen 80er, wie man hier sagen würde,
Moped halt, Vespa-Style, die sind da ja überall.
Und die ganze Infrastruktur Taiwans und das gilt nicht nur für Taiwan,
aber in Taiwan ist es mir jetzt nochmal besonders aufgefallen,
weil Taiwan auch verhältnismäßig gut strukturiert ist, verkehrstechnisch wie
gesagt, so ein bisschen wie Deutschland,
Straßen es hat alles so ein bisschen seine Ordnung, eine andere aber hat es,
und es gibt aber dort sehr viele Straßen die sind teilweise nicht für Scooter
und es gibt Straßen, die sind nur für Scooter,
Es gibt sozusagen zum Beispiel bei Brücken, es hat mich Tage gekostet,
bis ich gecheckt habe, wie ich über bestimmte Brücken rüberkam.
Ich musste immer von New Taipei nach Taipei fahren und New Taipei ist quasi
alles, was um Taipei herum ist, so vor allem im westlichen Teil.
Und da sind dann aber noch mal so mehrere größere Flussüberquerungen erforderlich.
Es gibt einen sehr breiten Fluss und entsprechend lange Brücken.
Und diese Brücken sind teilweise Stadtstraßen, teilweise Autostraßen, teilweise Autobahnen.
Und manche davon, nicht alle, aber fast alle,
haben nochmal eine separate Spur für Scooter, die aber auch nicht unbedingt
an derselben Stelle beginnen oder enden wie die andere Straße,
sondern die nochmal ganz eigene Zuführungen und Wegführungen haben. Also es ist total wild.
Macht aber voll Spaß. Also sowas vermisse ich ja in Deutschland.
Es gibt überhaupt gar keine Zweirad, also nicht nur keine Fahrradinfrastruktur,
aber es gibt auch keine Motor-Zweirad-Infrastruktur.
In keiner, habe ich noch nie gesehen, dass irgendwas, es gibt noch nicht mal
Parkplätze für Motorräder. Ja, und das ist da ganz anders in Taiwan.
Da hast du überall Parkplätze dafür und spezielle Verkehrsregeln.
So, jetzt ist es so, Google Maps hat tatsächlich in Taiwan eine spezielle Navigation nur für Scooter.
Weil du musst ganz andere Wege fahren. Du kannst nicht überall fahren,
wo Autos fahren und umgekehrt.
Nur, es taucht halt automatisch auf. Mit anderen Worten, nicht immer.
Also bei mir taucht es halt nicht auf.
Ich konnte machen, was ich wollte. Ich habe auf Englisch umgestellt.
Ich habe mein Land auf Taiwan gestellt.
Ich habe x-mal rebooted, Cache gelöscht, keine Ahnung, ausgelockt,
eingeloggt, alle möglichen Tipps im Internet. Kennst du das,
was man da mal alles so empfohlen bekommt?
Alles ausprobieren, kein Erfolg. Das ist mir dann irgendwann gelungen,
im Webbrowser zumindest diesen Scooter noch zu bekommen,
sodass ich zumindest grob schon mal recherchieren konnte, wenn dann auch eben
nicht auf dem Telefon und musste mich dann so ein bisschen durchschlagen mit,
ja okay, keine Autostraßen, keine Mautstraßen, dann passt das schon irgendwie,
aber das hat dann auch nur so begrenzt funktioniert. Naja.
Und ja, das ist ein echtes Problem.
Und das ist auch ein generelles Problem, was die Navigation betrifft,
auch hier für die Autonavigation, weil Apple Maps und Google Maps auch in Europa
immer davon ausgehen, dass wenn du sagst Auto,
dann ist das ein Auto, was beliebig schnell fahren kann.
Und was kein Problem mit Gewicht hat oder Höhe.
Aber es gibt halt sehr viele Einschränkungen. Tunnel, Brücken,
Unterfahrten dürfen halt nur unterfahren werden, wenn dein Fahrzeug 2 Meter,
3 Meter, 4 Meter, was auch immer ist.
Was ist, wenn du jetzt ein besonders hohes Fahrzeug hast? Was ist,
wenn dein Fahrzeug nicht schneller als 80 oder 100 Stundenkilometer fahren darf?
Das sind diese ganzen Zeiteinschätzungen. mit so, ja nee, fahr Autobahn, das ist voll schnell.
Weil da kannst du Unlimited fahren oder keine Ahnung. Man weiß ja auch nicht,
was der annimmt, wenn man auf der Autobahn fährt.
Ja, in Deutschland, was fährt man in der Autobahn? 500, ist ja erlaubt.
Also früher konnte man, als es noch so richtig TomTom-Apps und sowas gab,
konntest du ja einstellen, wie viel du wirklich im Durchschnitt auf Landstraße
und auf Autobahn fährst.
Da hätte man das dann rein parametrisieren können. Aber sowas gibt es ja alles nicht mehr.
Du kannst in der TomTom App, ich glaube das mit der Geschwindigkeit nicht mehr,
aber du kannst tatsächlich auch auf LKW Navigation umstellen oder auf Motorrad Navigation.
Hast du denn mal Open Street Map ausprobiert da unten, hinten unten?
Ja, aber jetzt nicht für die Autonavigation oder Scootnavigation.
Das hätte ich vielleicht mal probieren sollen.
Ich habe das immer nur genommen, wenn ich halt auf Trampelpfade und so etwas angewiesen war.
Aber ist grundsätzlich da unten schon auch gut erschlossen OpenStreet?
Ja, ich finde OpenStreetMap funktioniert eigentlich überall.
Also ich habe jetzt zumindest noch keinen Ort angetroffen, wo ich sagen würde, oh hier fehlt ja alles.
Da muss mal jemand trecken kommen, ja.
Also sagen wir mal so, in Jamaika war es ein bisschen sporadisch an vielen Stellen.
In Italien, die Geschichte erzähle ich auch immer wieder gerne,
Italien hat 1912 hat die Armee mal eine große Mapping-Campaign gemacht über
das ganze Land. und hat Katasterkarten erstellt.
Und selbst moderne Autoatlasse werden immer noch nach diesen Karten gebaut.
Das heißt, da fehlen Straßen, die schon gar nicht mehr in so gutem Zustand sind,
wenn du dich mitten auf dem Land befindest.
Und wenn du nicht weißt, dass da eine Straße ist, findest du sie halt auch nicht
im Shell-Sonstwas-Atlas drin.
Da ist mitunter OpenStreetMap besser, Besonders, weil man halt fehlende Straßen
selber nachmappen kann, was ich dann auch getan habe.
Gut, vielleicht ist es inzwischen durch die ganzen Kartendienste besser geworden,
aber so vor 10, 15 Jahren war das so,
war OpenStreetMap noch mit die beste Alternative gegen klassische Karte kaufe ich an der Tankstelle.
Also es gibt spezielle Navi-Apps natürlich auch für LKW, die haben ja nochmal
ganz andere Auflagen, wo du mit welchem Gefahrgut langfahren darfst und von
wann bis wann und Stellplätze und Mautgebühren und so weiter.
Da kommt ja nochmal ein ganzer Rattenschwanz, Fahrbahnbreite, Höhe etc.
Kommt alles mit rein. Aber wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel mit einem Wohnmobil oder
Wohnwagen unterwegs ist, dann hat man ja auch viele dieser Einschränkungen.
Oder man will vielleicht auch langsam fahren aus Energie und so weiter.
Mit Elektro will ich jetzt gar nicht erst anfangen.
Das war eh ein bisschen enttäuschend, muss ich sagen. Ich dachte ja so Asien,
weil man hört immer so viel aus China, das ist jetzt alles elektrisch.
Ja, kann man nicht wirklich behaupten. Also es gibt in Taiwan tatsächlich zwei
Scooterfirmen, die da weit vorne sind.
Das eine kennt man auch aus Berlin, das sind diese Gogoros, die hier unter dem
Namen Coop mal eine Weile unterwegs waren.
Das sind halt relativ moderne Elektroscooter, die diese Wechselakkusystematik
richtig perfektioniert haben. Du hast ja so zwei.
Milchkannartige Akkus unterm Sitz, die du leicht rausziehen kannst und die haben
dann über ganz Taiwan verteilt überall Ladestationen.
Und zwar nicht, wo du deine Akkus laden kannst, sondern wo du einfach so eine Tauschstation hast.
Die stehen entweder so an der Straße rum oder in irgendwelchen Läden sind die mit drin.
Und das ist ganz pfiffig in vielerlei Hinsicht. Du machst da halt so ein Subscription-Service
und dann, je nachdem wie viel du fährst und so.
Klar, wenn dir die Akkus nicht gehören, dann musst du sie natürlich mieten.
Genau, das ist natürlich auch ein Problem für sich.
Das ist bei NIO ja genauso, wenn du da die, bei den Autos, wenn du da dieses
Wechselmodell haben willst, wo du an der Tauschstation den Akku tauschst,
dann mietest du den auch.
Macht ja auch irgendwie Sinn, muss man halt nur überlegen, inwiefern man sich
da halt technologisch binden will.
Und es ist natürlich kein Standard. Das heißt, es gibt halt neben Gogoro gibt
es noch eine zweite Firma, die heißt Kimco, das ist auch so eine taiwanesische
Scooterhersteller, die auch elektrisch haben, die auch Wechselakkus haben,
auch ihre eigenen Stationen haben, aber natürlich inkompatible Systeme haben untereinander.
Ja, super, Gogoro will natürlich sein System durchbringen, hat auch in Indien
verschiedene Kooperationen, wo sie mit anderen Herstellern auch schon mit demselben
Akkumodell versuchen, sozusagen da die Weltherrschaft zu übernehmen.
Vielleicht gelingt Ihnen das auch.
Meine Erwartung war nur so, dass es ein Taiwan noch ein bisschen präsenter ist.
Du siehst sie überall. Also es ist nicht so, dass es dir jetzt gar nicht auffällt.
Aber wenn halt irgendwo so ein Rudel, zwei Räder an dir vorbei raus,
dann ist halt einfach 95 Prozent, ist halt Verbrenner.
Ja, das war in Indien, das ist ja ganz merkwürdig.
Also so diese normalen Scooter, da muss der Fahrer einen Helm tragen und der Beifahrer aber nicht.
Warum auch immer. Ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, ist aber so.
So ist das Gesetz oder was?
Ja. Und man sieht es auch sehr viel, der Fahrer trägt dann den Helm und die
Frau meistens hinten drauf hat halt keinen.
So, keine Ahnung und dann gibt es halt diese Elektroroller und da musst du halt
keinen Helm tragen die sind aber nicht viel langsamer besonders im Bombay-Straßenverkehr
sind die eher noch schneller weil die halt die ordentliche Beschleunigung haben,
aber dann fahren die ohne Helm und sind auch nicht zu hören weil die ja kein Geräusch machen,
also fand ich ein bisschen komisch ja.
Also es wird dringend Zeit, glaube ich, dass Akkus erfunden werden,
die in zwei Rädern zur Verwendung kommen können, die sehr schnell laden.
Also da ist es fast noch ein größeres Thema, glaube ich, als bei Autos.
Da würde ich dir wahrscheinlich widersprechen. Bei Autos ist es auch ein sehr, sehr großes Thema.
Und ich glaube, wenn die Akkus, die sehr schnell zu laden sind,
da sind, dann werden sie auch überall verwendet.
Ja, ja, gar keine Frage, nur bei Autos hast du jetzt schon okaye Lösungen.
Ja.
Bei Zweiradern, bei Scootern hast du noch außer diesem Tauschmodell.
Aber auf Ladebasis hast du keine okaye Lösung.
Weil ich fahre jetzt mit einem normalen Zweirad Viertakter an die Tankstelle,
der hält da kurz 10 Sekunden seinen Rüssel da rein und dann fahre ich wieder weiter.
Ja, so argumentieren die Leute natürlich auch bei Autos.
Ja, bei Autos ist es nicht zehn Sekunden, sondern hier ist es wirklich literally zehn Sekunden.
Also ich rede von wirklich zehn Sekunden von Geldscheinen, inklusive Geldscheinen
in die Hand drücken und so weiter.
Also es ist so überhaupt nicht spürbar, dieser Moment, dass du da einfach nicht
sagen kannst, ja und die Alternative ist eine Stunde laden.
Also es steht einfach in gar keinem...
Eine Stunde ist natürlich auch exzessiv.
Ja, aber das ist die Realität bei diesen kleinen Zweirad-Scootern.
Und dazu kommt ja noch, dass die noch nicht mal die Ladegeräte eingebaut haben.
Sondern du hast ja in der Regel in dieser Kategorie immer noch externe Ladegeräte.
Das ist ja das andere Problem. Also du hast noch nicht mal irgendwie auch nur
die Chance, eine normale Ladesäule zu verwenden.
Du hast natürlich, also zumindest wenn du so ein Ding in Deutschland,
in einer großen Stadt verwendest, hast du natürlich den Vorteil,
dass du nimmst den Akku mit rein, zu Hause, lädst ihn zu Hause, morgens ist er voll,
fährst zur Arbeit, dann nimmst du den Akku wieder raus, stellst ihn auf den
Schreibtisch, steckst ihn ein und wenn du wieder zurückfahren willst,
ist er auch wieder voll, weil dann ist es halt auch egal.
Ja, aber die 10 Kilo Akku dann im fünften Stock, wo keinen Fahrstuhl ist,
hochzuschleppen, hat halt auch keiner so richtig Bock drauf.
Ja gut, das ist jetzt natürlich auch eine Berliner Spezialität.
Ja, nicht nur.
Ja gut, nicht nur.
Den dritten Stock, den findest du auch noch in Hamburg.
Aber 10 Kilo sollte so ein Akku doch nicht wiegen, oder?
Ja, das ist das Problem.
Und da muss dran gearbeitet werden.
Und ja, nee, aber ich glaube, dass dieses Akkus schneller laden ich da,
da spechten sie alle drauf und ich bin da guter Dinge,
dass, dass die Entwicklung so weitergeht, wie sie derzeit läuft und dann,
wenn du bei 20 Minuten bist, ist die Diskussion schon viel einfacher zu führen.
Dazu kommt natürlich auch noch, dass Energie oft sehr subventioniert ist in den Ländern.
Energie im Sinne von Schreibstoff oder Strom?
Nö, alles. Strom kostet nicht so viel, Solar lohnt sich nicht so richtig.
Naja, bei uns ist der Strom ja eher das Gegenteil von subventioniert.
Der Privatmann subventioniert ja die Industrie mit dem Strom.
Und vor allen Dingen auch den Netzbetreiber und die Unfähigkeit,
das Netz mal in Teile zu zerlegen, die sinnvoll abrechnen können.
Ja gut, aber in Deutschland gibt es keine Zweirad-Motorroller-Kultur.
Also hier fahren welche, aber es ist ja nicht… Nee.
Aber wir haben ja auch nicht das Wetter dafür.
Wir haben nicht das Wetter wie da, aber unser Wetter ist ausreichend.
Also wir könnten mehr haben, aber wir haben das alle nicht auf dem Zeiger.
Und außerdem dürfen sie nur 45 Stundenkilometer fahren, was total bekloppt ist.
Was total bekloppt ist.
Da hat die Autoindustrie halt einfach wirklich mal den Schraubenschlüssel ins Rad geworfen.
Und viel zu viel Führerschein, Scheißdreck und was du da alles für bezahlen
musst, nur um so ein Ding. Ich meine, in Vietnam fährt einfach jeder,
jeder und jeder fährt Roller.
Es ist einfach, ich meine, so einen Roller zu fahren, ich weiß gar nicht,
warum man da überhaupt einen Führerschein für braucht.
Es ist einfach, das lernst du in fünf Minuten.
In Goa standen die Straßen voll mit Leihrollern.
Alles ist dreckig und staubig und stinkt, aber die Roller, die Leihroller,
die noch nicht verliehen sind, die blinken und glänzen, als wären sie gerade
erst vor einer Viertelstunde vom Händler abgeholt worden.
Weil die sind da ständig dabei und putzen die Leihroller, damit du dann bei
denen dir deinen Roller leihst.
Da fällt mir noch was ein, denn heuer an gab es tatsächlich einen Rollerverleih.
Die hatten Elektroroller, die aber auch nur 45 fuhren. Habe ich ausprobiert.
Für sie getestet.
Für sie getestet. Das heißt, die waren jetzt nicht schnell oder so, aber die waren okay.
Also für jetzt Touristen gucken durch die Stadt und schauen sich mal alles irgendwie
an und sind leise und so weiter und unproblematisch und wartungsarm. Völlig ausreichend.
Und der Clou war, äh,
geladen hast du die, indem du die wieder zu diesem Laden, wo du sie gefahren
hast und die in den Vollen nimmst.
Also die laden für dich sozusagen die Roller, haben da genug rumstehen und wenn
du irgendwie so ans Ende deines Akkus kommst, fährst du da kurz vorbei,
setzt dich auf den anderen und fährst mit dem weiter.
Aber für die Teile brauchtest du noch nicht mal einen Führerschein.
Also es war sozusagen offiziell erlaubt, damit rumzufahren ohne Führerschein, weil von zu hoch. Naja.
Also was ich in Bombay sehr krass fand, aber das war in den anderen Städten auch so,
ist, dass extrem viele so Liefertypen mit diesen Rollern unterwegs sind und
jeder Inder erzählt dir wie,
was zum Supermarkt? Nee, da gehe ich nicht mehr.
Die liefern sowieso alles innerhalb von 10 Minuten wenn es etwas länger dauert
dann sind es 10 Minuten und dann war das halt auch so ja hier wollt ihr noch
einen Tee, ja noch ein paar Kekse Moment, düdüdüd auf der App rumgetippt,
nach 5 Minuten bimmelt es, steht der Typ mit den Keksen vor der Tür irgendwie,
oder wie heißt es so schön,
Manual Labor doesn't cost anything also es war wirklich so.
Haben wir ja hier auch.
Naja.
Okay, gut. Ich denke, damit können wir unsere Reiseberichte erstmal abschließen
und verlegen uns vielleicht ein bisschen mehr aufs Datenreisen.
Das sind ja auch Experten für.
Genau, ihr habt die Welt bereist. Ich habe sie gerettet.
Du hast sie gerettet?
Ach du warst es.
Sehr schön. Es fühlt sich gerade gar nicht so an.
Nee, es wirkt wohl langsam.
Ich nehme an einem verzweifelten Versuch teil, sie zu retten.
Ich habe was gemacht, was ich glaube ich noch nie in meinem Leben gemacht habe.
Ich bin Teil einer Kampagne geworden.
Echt?
Teil einer Jugendbewegung.
Ich habe die Plakate gar nicht gesehen mit deinem Konterfeil.
Ja, man muss lange warten, bis ich durchkomme. Wovon rede ich?
Ich rede von der Kampagne Safe Social, also rettet das Soziale und gemeint ist
natürlich das Digitale Soziale.
Und das ist eine Kampagne, die kurz vor unserer letzten Sendung losgetreten worden ist,
aber da war sie quasi noch nicht publiziert und von daher wollte ich da auch
noch nicht dann hier schon irgendwas spoilern unter der allgemeinen PR vorgreifen.
Gestartet hat das Ganze der Björn Staschen wo weiß ich gar nicht genau,
weiß ob ich ihn richtig ausgesprochen habe,
Journalist aus Hamburg, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, der hat so ein etwas
bekannteres Buch geschrieben in der Social Media Falle und der hat Leute zusammen getrommelt,
die auch, wie ich, der Meinung sind, dass das mit dem Fediverse und Mastodon
mal alles ein bisschen vorangehen sollte und die Leute doch endlich mal von
X weg und Und nicht von einem verrückten Milliardär zum nächsten nur irgendwie zu hoppen.
Und diese Kampagne hat in der Tat bis Stand heute, ich glaube,
253.000 Unterschriften gekriegt. Das ist also schon gar nicht mal so wenig.
Auch für so ein Thema, ich glaube, das ist irgendwie von einer der größten Digitalkampagnen,
die bisher in Deutschland irgendwie gelaufen sind. Ihr könnt auch immer noch
unterschreiben, das könnt ihr gerne tun.
Normalerweise bin ich nicht mal sehr vorsichtig, was sowas angeht,
weil so von irgendwie immer gefühlt 20 Forderungen findet man irgendwie so 12
gut und 5 so okayisch und mit 3 hat man eine richtige Bauchschmerze und dann
macht man es mal lieber nicht.
Und bei denen war es aber so, dass ich sagen würde, so da steht jetzt nichts
drin, was ich nicht unterschreiben würde und so die ersten 5 Punkte hätte ich
wortwörtlich genauso geschrieben.
Also beispielsweise der erste Punkt ist eine Sache, mit der ich auch seit dem
Herbst durch die Länder ziehe, diese Plus-Eins-Idee, wie ich das immer nenne.
Alle, die mit öffentlichem Geld finanziert sind, egal ob es jetzt Medienanstalten
sind oder Behörden oder Universitäten oder auch Bibliotheken,
was auch immer ihr für Social-Media-Kanäle bespielt, ist uns völlig egal.
Ihr müsst mindestens einen freien, offenen Kanal bespielen, zusätzlich.
Plus eins. So, das ist
Finde ich, sollte sich für Analogie zu Public Money, Public Code,
genauso sollte das auch mit Public Relations laufen.
Da bin ich total von überzeugt und so auch bei den anderen Punkten,
Alternativen strukturell stärken und so weiter.
Von daher habe ich gesagt, doch, da mache ich jetzt ausnahmsweise mal mit.
Und von daher, wenn man da jetzt lange genug wartet, erschaut auch irgendwann ein Bildchen von mir.
Und, ah, da bin ich ja, genau.
An wen richtet sich denn dieser Aufruf?
Letzte Woche waren die da mit im Bundestag. Und haben das jetzt dort den verschiedenen
Digitalvertretern der Parteien überreicht und jetzt die sich gerade firmierende
Bundesregierung wird in der Tat auch damit agitiert,
das doch mal noch in die Koalitionsverhandlungen reinzunehmen.
Und es hat so eine gewisse Traktion, nimmt das gerade auf.
Ernsthaft? Bei der CDU?
Ja nun.
Und der SPD?
Naja, also auch die gute alte Mutter SPD.
Saskia Esken hat uns empfangen. Immerhin.
Das ist ja eine.
Die innerhalb der SPD, wir erinnern uns, Vorratsdatenspeicherung und sowas,
die hat ja schon ziemlich korrekte Ansichten.
Was das Digitale angeht.
Die haben zwei, drei gute Leute, das stimmt schon. Aber ansonsten beschäftigt
sich die SPD ja nur mit der SPD.
Ich will da alles gar nicht laut widersprechen und auch wenn nichts mehr rumkommt,
ich fand, das war insgesamt eine der doch etwas sinnvolleren Aktionen und da wollte ich nochmal...
Darauf hinweisen.
Darf man denn dann auch Blue Sky nehmen?
Ah, unklar. Du darfst alles nehmen, solange du halt irgendwo auch dein Backup hast.
Man guckt jetzt gerade die USA an, das garantiert dir doch jetzt wirklich kein
Mensch, dass es irgendwie Blue Sky noch in zwei Monaten gibt.
Also ich zähle jetzt schon die Tage, wann sie Signal abschalten.
Weil Trump sagt so, also kennt ihr das, dass der auch wirklich gar nicht kapiert hat, was Signal ist?
Zitat von ihm, ja da sei irgendwie ein Signal wohl schlecht,
das sei wohl schlecht übertragen worden, so dumme Sache, aber da kann jetzt keiner was für.
Also er hat wirklich überhaupt, er ist nicht mehr in der Lage zu verstehen,
was überhaupt dieser Messenger-Dienst ist oder was der tut.
Der versteht nichts.
Aber dann, das ist doch die logische Konsequenz, nächste Woche wird es verboten,
wenn ihm das noch weiter auf den Kegel geht.
Die Finanzierung haben sie ja eh schon eine Woche vorher gekillt.
Also, eieieiei.
Ich warte ja immer noch auf den Film, wo jemand irgendwie die ganze Situation
so darstellt, wie das läuft alles nur im Kopf eines bekloppten Alten,
der im Altenheim ist, ab.
Und dann kommt immer jemand, wir müssen das und das machen.
Lass uns nicht über Trump oder Singlegate reden. Bleiben wir mal kurz bei dem
Thema. Aber ich meinte das eigentlich ganz ernst. Also ich meine,
ich verstehe ja diese Kritik.
Also es gibt ja, ich fange mal anders an.
Also, ich komme noch mal rein.
Rettung, genau, Rettung von Social Media bin ich ja voll dafür so,
womit und wie ist meiner Meinung nach eine offene Diskussion und wenn ich mir
halt so den Ansatz von Blue Sky anschaue und den Ansatz vom Fidiverse, dann hat beides was,
ich finde, das ist auch beides,
viele der Kriterien erfüllt die auch ich mir persönlich von solchen Diensten wünsche.
Und teilweise tut es halt Blue Sky mehr als der Fediverse-Ansatz.
Teilweise vielleicht auch sind sie so gleich auf.
Oder je nachdem, was persönlich so wichtig ist.
Spannend wird das jetzt, weil ja Tapbots, die Ivory, also aus Tweetbot und,
Und was für mich der einzige Grund war, dass Twitter benutzbar blieb,
haben sie ja Ivory gebaut und deswegen ist Mastodon für mich benutzbar geworden.
Und jetzt haben sie ja angekündigt, dass sie auch einen Blue Sky Client draus machen.
Verräter!
Der Phönix heißt, ich kann dir sagen, bei mir ist dann das Rennen wieder offen,
weil es gibt teilweise Communities, die sind einfach bei Blue Sky deutlich präsenter
als bei Masso, gar keine Frage. und,
ich finde auch, dass bei Blue Sky einiges wirklich ziemlich cool gelöst ist.
Ich meine diese Jay Graber, ich weiß nicht, ob du der mal gelauscht hast,
die ist schon eine sehr kluge Frau, der man nicht vorwerfen kann,
dass sie über dieses Problem nicht lange nachgedacht hat und ich finde so ihre,
Feststellung bezüglich darauf,
dass sie Blue Sky weil für Billionaire-Proof hält, da ist was dran.
Da würde ich sagen, I tend to disagree, aber das müsste man dann mal ein bisschen.
Ich meine, wenn der Typ, der Twitter an einen Billionaire verkauft hat,
eine neue Plattform aufmacht.
Welcher Typ?
Wie hieß er, Jack irgendwas?
Der steckt da nicht mit drin, das ist so ein Mythos.
Nicht mehr, aber eher.
Nein, der steckte da auch noch nie mit drin, der hat mal die ursprüngliche Idee
gehabt, Der hat diese Jay Graeber engagiert, dieses Projekt zu leiten.
Das hat sie dann auch getan.
Das hat sie aber unabhängig von ihm getan. Ja, ist so.
Ja, es ist natürlich trotzdem ein Single Point of Failure irgendwie.
Was ist ein Single Point of Failure?
Ein Blue Sky.
Wo, an welcher Stelle?
Bei den Relays. Es gibt nach wie vor exakt ein einziges Relay,
über das alles vermittelt wird. Es ist halt nicht Dezentralpunkt.
Das Protokoll könnte dezentral sein. Es ist nicht dezentral implementiert.
Und damit hast du einen Single Point of Failure.
Dafür hast du deine Daten, kannst du selber in deinem eigenen Server speichern,
was du wiederum beim Fediverse nicht kannst.
Das ist das, was ich meine. Also es gibt da technische Eigenschaften und ich
finde, dass die beiden Systeme sich gegenseitig ein bisschen mehr befruchten
als bekämpfen sollten. Darauf wollte ich eigentlich hinaus.
Ja, ich will ja auch jetzt nicht Blue Sky irgendwie an den Karren pissen,
nur so richtig wohl ist mir bei der Sache nicht.
Ich finde es aber cool, dass ich im Prinzip einen Server aufsetzen kann,
wo ich meine ganzen Daten und meine Tweets speichern kann und wenn ich halt nicht Blue Sky als,
App oder als Verteilersystem benutzen möchte, dann kann ich halt was anderes
machen und es bleibt halt alles da.
Während wenn ich einmal einen Mast oder einen Server wechsle,
ist halt mein ganzer Content weg.
Ja gut.
Oder wenn der nicht ordentlich administriert wird, dann werden auch die Bilder
nicht richtig gesurft und es ist irgendwie alles immer so furchtbar langsam.
Ja, im Prinzip richtig. Das Ding mit dem, ich kann im Prinzip meinen eigenen
Server machen, ist halt genau so lange interessant, bis ich es dann versuche.
Bei eigenen Server hosten willst du halt dann letzten Endes doch nicht machen.
Egal, was es ist. Weil es sei denn, du bist so jemand, der steht da drauf.
Wenn es das so zum Fertig zum Klicken gibt, irgendwann so, dass du dir für zwei
Dollar im Monat irgendwie mit deiner eigenen Domain irgendwo hostest,
dann ist das ja kein Thema.
Das geht dann aber und du bespielst halt alles, was AdProtokoll steht.
Die Argumentation könntest du natürlich für deinen eigenen Feddy-Server auch aufmachen.
Ja, aber dann muss dieser Faddy-Server halt auch deinen ganzen Content,
ja okay, das muss er auch sonst, aber du musst ja dann auch sozusagen auch noch
den Content aller anderen User, die du da hast, oder du hast halt eine komplette
Mastodons-Site nur für einen einzigen User, was halt auch der totale Overkill ist.
Naja, es ist auch eine Ein-Klick-Lösung.
Wir drehen jetzt im Kreis.
Wir haben ja auch schon ein paar Mal, ich bin da ja auch gar nicht dogmatisch
unterwegs, aber ich finde dieses Plus-Eins-Konzept finde ich einfach ziemlich zwingend.
Also bespielt alle Blue Sky und meinetwegen auch X, wenn ihr meint,
dass ihr dort noch irgendwen erreicht und noch bekehren könnt, I so don't care.
Aber es muss eben auch mit öffentlichem Geld ein öffentlicher Kanal bespielt werden.
Das finde ich, das gehört sich einfach so. So, das sollte gute Sitte sein.
So, und dann habe ich noch ein anderes Update zur letzten Sendung.
Die war ja kurz vor der Wahl.
Und da hatte ich ja hier Fedipol vorgestellt.
Diesen Fediverse-Tracker, den
ich gebaut habe oder bauen lassen von Claude Sonnet. Wir kommen noch dazu.
Wo man gucken konnte, wie eigentlich die verschiedenen politischen Parteien
im Fediverse, hauptsächlich Mastodon, unterwegs sind.
Hieß der schon so, letztes Mal?
Fidipol?
Ja.
Ich glaube schon.
Ich glaube, du hattest ihn noch nicht.
Oder hat er noch keinen Namen gehabt?
Er war vor allen Dingen auch noch nicht ausgerollt irgendwo öffentlich verfügbar.
Echt nicht?
Ich glaube nicht.
Das hast du in der Sendung doch erst gemacht.
Na, auf jeden Fall. Damals hatte ich ja noch so eine Wiki-Seite gescrapt mit
den Informationen der verschiedenen Daten.
Und das habe ich dann nochmal umgestellt auf Wikidata, weil ich dachte so,
jetzt machen wir es professionell und jetzt mal die ganzen Parteien.
Und das ist ja vielleicht dann doch ein Rabbit Hole.
Ich habe schon immer ein bisschen was gemacht mit Wikidata, aber dort jetzt
eine vernünftige Query zu bauen, womit ich also.
Und einigermaßen verlässlich alle deutschen relevanten Politikerinnen erwische,
die auch ein Fidiverse-Account haben. Das war mal nicht trivial.
Und ich habe, wie es sich gehört, das Ganze mal ordentlich dokumentiert.
Link dazu findet ihr in der Shownotes, kann man auch oben in meinem Dienst mit
dem Tabs hier und herstellen.
Und da sieht man genau, welche Entities innerhalb der Wikidata ich da jetzt
abfrage und auch wie die ganze Query zusammengebaut ist.
Und das ist schon ganz schön umständlich, weil man muss beispielsweise die ganzen
Institutionen durchgehen.
Also ist Member of Bundestag oder EU-Parlament, Landtag, Ratsherr,
Bürgermeister, Stadtrat, Bezirksverordnete, Kreisrat.
Also dieser ganze Schlons, dann natürlich die ganzen Parteien,
die man alle irgendwie drin haben muss, weil ist deutsche Partei,
reicht als Query nicht so, da ist dann die Datenbasis dann noch immer nicht präzise genug.
Und dann hatte ich das Ganze publiziert und dann gab es wieder so einen schönen
Large Language Model Moment.
Es funktionierte, fand ich ganz gut und ich hatte das meiste auch so durchgetrackt
und einer hat mich dann auf Mastodon angeschrieben, guck dir nochmal deine Sparkle-Abfrage an.
Irgendwie so eine, da ist glaube ich irgendwo ein Zahlendreher drin bei einer Entität.
Das ist irgendwie nicht Bürgermeister, sondern irgendwie eine Schlingpflanze
oder sowas, die du als Entität abfragst und die wird mit ziemlicher Sicherheit,
keinen Mastodon-Account haben.
Ist aber bei den Grünen.
Ist bei den Grünen, ja. Die Grünen haben nebenbei bemerkt ja das wirklich schöne
Projekt Netzbegrünung gestartet, wo sie dann ja im Schwung wirklich zu Mastodon
rüber sind. So ein cooler Name.
Gut, wie auch immer. Ich habe also geguckt, ja stimmt hier, die Identity ist
wirklich komisch und habe das dann halt wieder Claude Sonnet vorgeworfen nach
dem Motto hier, bitte kontrolliere das mal.
Da haben wir glaube ich einen Fehler drin, das ist überhaupt kein Stadrat,
sondern eine Schlingepflanze.
Die RLM dann so, hm, okay, ich gucke mir nochmal hier die Sparkle-Abfrage an.
Oh ja, da hast du recht, das stimmt gar nicht. Ich check mal eben die anderen Entitäten.
Oh, ich bin da was ganz Großem auf der Spur. Die sind ja fast alle falsch.
Du, da müssen wir mal bei Wikidata ran und mal die Entitäten alle korrigieren.
Moment, ich schicke dir mal eine Liste.
Da war mir ein Moment, wo ich so dachte, ja okay, mach mal.
Wer hatte denn jetzt recht?
Weil ich hatte vorher die Liste da nämlich schon händisch eigentlich schon selber
geprüft und der Rest stimmte halt alles.
Und dann fing also ein nicht enden wollender Strom an der Anuzinierung statt,
welche Wikidata-Queries, alle Identities, alle falsch sind. Weil da hat er halt
praktisch kein Trainingsmaterial offensichtlich drauf.
Und offensichtlich sind die noch nicht so auf Wikidata optimiert,
dass sie da also wirklich exakt die Sachen zuzugreifen dürfen.
Und er hat sich dann also auch, jetzt habe ich mal so noch falsch,
da bin ich völlig reingesteigert in seine Antwort.
So, da müssen wir jetzt mal wirklich Bescheid geben. Das geht doch so nicht,
dass hier Wikidata alles falsch hat. So, da musst du jetzt einschreiten, Ralf.
Ja, okay, gut, beruhige dich. Ich glaube, es ist anders. Guck mal hier.
Ja, auch sowas passiert. Also wir kommen da hinterher noch zu dieser LLM-Entwicklung,
das hat auch schon alles so seine Fallstricke.
Gut, wenn noch Menschen drüber gucken.
Ja, da bräuchte es mal einen MCP-Server.
Aber der Dienst ist jetzt schön, der gefällt mir jetzt, wo man ja so gucken
kann, wie aktiv sind ja die ganzen Parteien, die Grünen in der Tat,
mit 202 Accounts da weit vorne.
Kannst du auch um mal zurück zur Übersicht, dann kriegt man da ja die die ganze
Oberfläche, wo man auch wirklich sehen kann, wann die Grünen alle reingegangen sind.
Das ist dann eben hier genau die zwei Wellen von...
Ja, aber was kann man denn da jetzt sozusagen für uns, also ich meine,
was ist denn jetzt, abgesehen von schöner Zahlenstatistik, die Essenz?
Also kann man da jetzt irgendwas daraus ableiten?
Kann man da irgendwelche Aussagen machen? Kann man sagen, hier die Grünen posten
ganz viel auf dem Fettiverse, aber deswegen kommen sie auch nicht mehr in die Regierung.
Während die anderen ihre Zeit besser zu nutzen wissen.
Ja, aber Linke, zweitstärkste hier im Fidiverse, die sind ja jetzt erfolgreichste
Partei geworden in der Bundestagswahl. Von daher hier in Berlin.
Also du kannst glaube ich schon hier so ein Links-Rechts-Schema ablesen.
Also die tendenziell eher linken Parteien wie eben Grüne, Linke und SPD.
Drücken wir mal so vier Augen zu. die bilden hier glaube ich wenn ich mir jetzt
so die Balken angucke drei Viertel der Accounts ab,
Wo hingegen dann so CDU sind 23, Hansel.
Okay, sagen wir es einfach wie es ist.
FDP-Sieden.
Das Fediverse ist linksgrün versifft.
Linksgrün versifft, ja.
Naja, die rechten Parteien haben eigene Fernsehsender, die brauchen das nicht.
Ja, ich auch.
Ja, also das kann man schon sehen. Und das zweite ist, dass es halt auch viele
Karteileichen gibt. Also das habe ich in meiner Statistik hier auch drin.
Sind das ganz erstmal Bots oder sind das keine Bots? Weil teilweise gab es auch so ganze Movements,
wo also offensichtlich irgendwie ein ganzes Parlament reinbuxiert wurde,
aber niemand von denen hat irgendwie dort jemals selber was gepostet,
sondern es sind ja nur so Cross-Postings, teilweise auch von Blue Sky interessanterweise.
Und ich habe halt auch noch einen Filter drin, so ist da überhaupt in den letzten
60 Tagen irgendwas mal an Aktivität passiert und da bleibt dann schon gar nicht
mehr so rasend viel übrig, muss man sagen.
Das ist schon ein bisschen betrüblich.
Die posten wahrscheinlich auch alle die Wahrheit, das interessiert ja keinen Menschen.
Ja, aber so als Proof of Concept, mal gucken, vielleicht brauche ich das irgendwann
nochmal generischer, dass man da nicht nur quasi Politik abfragen kann,
sondern wie sind die Hochschulen vertreten, wie sind die Ministerien vertreten oder sowas.
Vielleicht brauche ich da irgendwann mal so ein generisches Framework.
Ja, die Partei ist vielleicht gar nicht mal das Spannendste.
Das war natürlich jetzt vielleicht so zur Bundestagswahl ein ganz guter Kick-Off,
Aber tatsächlich fände ich, sagen wir mal, Wissenschaft,
Forschung wäre mal ganz interessant, weil das ist ja nun eigentlich auch ein
Bereich, wo man sagen würde, das passt auch zu euch.
Also ob das jetzt zu Parteien passt, da kann man jetzt trefflich drüber diskutieren.
Also vielleicht für ihre interne Kommunikation, aber nicht so sehr jetzt für die Außenwirkung.
Das ist, glaube ich, bei Wissenschaft dann schon wieder anders.
Genau.
Alright, sehr schön.
Womit machen wir weiter?
Wir gehen jetzt langsam auf das AI-Thema zu. Hart. Müssen wir auch, weil.
Geh ich mal schnell vorher aufs Klo.
Ich habe Wo ist die Mute-Taste, wenn man sie braucht?
Du kannst doch nicht arbeiten. Ich habe auch Schwierigkeiten so zu arbeiten.
Ich bin ja nun etwas länger unterwegs gewesen und bin ja heute erst zurückgekommen und habe,
jetzt muss ich ja mal den Kanal hier aufdrehen.
Damit man auf dem Klo was hört.
Ja, damit man auch auf dem Klo was hört. Ich hoffe, das funktioniert.
Hörst du uns jetzt auf dem Klo?
Super, okay. Das beruhigt jetzt alle.
Ja, ich merke gerade, ich habe gerade so eine kleine Müdigkeitsphase,
weil ich jetzt doch 24 Stunden auf dem Rückweg war und heute morgen angekommen
bin und dann hat alles nochmal 6-7 Stunden länger gedauert als ursprünglich geplant und,
der Slot fürs Nicker-Chäden zwischendurch, der war dann leider auch weg, deswegen.
Aber ich konzentriere mich jetzt einfach nochmal und beiße mich hier durch.
So, worüber wollen wir nämlich reden? Wir wollen über Vibe-Coding reden.
Das ist jetzt das, worüber wir hier schon ein paar Mal gesprochen haben, hat jetzt einen Namen.
Vibe Coding?
Vibe Coding, genau.
Und das machen sich ja schon diverse Leute darüber lustig.
Selbstverständlich. Alle Leute machen sich über neue Begriffe lustig.
Nein, nicht über den Begriff, sondern über das, was da passiert.
Ach so, über das Vibe Coding? Ja, natürlich machen sich Leute darüber lustig.
Die Leute, die es halt noch nicht gemacht haben, machen sich darüber lustig.
Und die anderen, die machen.
Das ist ja immer so das Ding mit diesen Dingen, die neu sind.
Und alle machen sich drüber lustig.
Ja, was bezeichnet Vibe Coding? Vibe Coding ist im Prinzip das,
worüber wir jetzt hier schon zwei, drei Mal ausführlich gesprochen haben,
nämlich Programmieren mit LLM-Unterstützung.
Und da hatten wir nämlich auch diesen schönen Titel, die Programmiersprache heißt Deutsch.
Und tatsächlich der Typ, der hier diesen Begriff mit dem Vibe Coding eingeführt
hat, hat das auch mit so einem Tweet gemacht, wo er meinte, the most popular
programming language is English.
Und das trifft halt sozusagen genau diesen Punkt. Und eigentlich in der ganzen
Berichterstattung, was ich jetzt darüber gelesen habe und Interviews und so
weiter, wie dieser Begriff zu verstehen ist, das ist eigentlich genau das,
was wir hier auch gesagt haben.
Kurz gesagt, man kann jetzt mit AI-Tools auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise Software schreiben.
Und es geht schnell und man kommt schnell zu diesen 80 Prozent,
wo wir mal alle hinwollen. Und die Frage ist, wofür ist das gut?
Und natürlich die erfahrenen Programmierer, die irgendwie alles super können
und kennen und alle Pitfalls des Programmierens schon mal gesehen haben,
sagen und wissen natürlich auch, dass das so seine Grenzen haben wird.
Nur auf der anderen Seite ist es eben auch so, man kommt sehr weit und oft schon
weit genug und kann auf einmal Dinge machen und Prototypen und schon mal zu
einer ordentlichen Lösung bringen,
ohne einen Aufwand treiben zu müssen, der sonst vielleicht die Sache nie wert gewesen wäre.
Und ich finde den Begriff ganz schön, weil man nämlich eigentlich ja,
ja, was ist drin in diesem Namen?
Ein Vibe erzeugt, man muss so ein Gefühl an den Tag legen.
Genau, es transportiert so einen gewissen Spirit, so einen Drive,
Energie, Geschwindigkeit, im Flow sein.
Alles sowas. Bis der Flow dann halt abbricht. Also ich finde es erstmal toll,
dass wir jetzt einen Begriff dafür haben.
Ja.
Weil ich mache das irgendwie seit zwei Jahren und schön, dass man jetzt mal
weiß, was es eigentlich ist.
Ich habe jetzt an der ZRB auch mal ein Experiment gemacht.
Also weil wir coden ja auch alle ansonsten irgendwie so ein bisschen und können
das irgendwie dann alles damit noch anders umgehen.
Ich habe jetzt mal wirklich komplette Laien da vorgesetzt bei mir in der Bibliothek.
Und Leuten gesagt, so Achtung, ihr habt doch bestimmt bei euch jetzt irgendwie
in eurem Bibliotheksgeschäft irgendwelche kleinen Probleme, die ihr gerne mal gelöst haben möchtet.
Also irgendwie eine einfache Datentransformation oder ich habe hier irgendwie
eine Excel-Datei und damit will ich irgendwie ganz was anderes machen,
habe aber keine Lust auf Excel und will eine Datenvisualisierung haben oder wie auch immer.
Und habe dann also vier Gruppen gebildet und die hatten zweieinhalb Stunden Zeit, sich mit Cloud,
Sonnet 3.5 und Cursor und ein bisschen vorgegebener Infrastruktur,
die ich quasi vorher reingepromptet hatte, so es läuft ein lokaler Python-Webserver
und Programmiersprache ist HTML, JavaScript und mehr gibt es hier nicht.
Und es können Vanilla-Frameworks nachgeladen werden, aber jetzt kein fancy Kram
hier, kein Node installieren und sowas.
Und da war ich schon sehr nervös, ob und wie das wohl funktioniert und ob die
mich hinterher am nächsten Baum aufknüpfen, weil sie irgendwie nach zwei Minuten
in der Sackgasse landen und es funktioniert nichts. Und das lief total cool.
Also klar, das waren jetzt keine produktiven Sachen, die da rausgekommen sind,
aber alle vier Gruppen mit sehr unterschiedlichen Voraussetzungen,
in einer war eine Informatikerin drin, in einer waren nur Laien drin,
trotzdem sind alle in diesen zweieinhalb Stunden ähnlich weit gekommen.
Sie hatten eine Nutzeroberfläche, sie haben ihre Daten eingelesen bekommen,
sie haben Datentransformationen gemacht.
Und ansatzweise hatten sie auch schon sowas wie Export, Visualisierung, wie auch immer.
Und dass das wirklich auch mit Leuten, die null Hintergrund haben und null Erfahrung
haben, das finde ich schon interessant.
Und was ich dafür, ich habe am Anfang so einen kleinen Pitch gemacht und dafür
habe ich mal eine Grafik gebaut, Vibe Coding, a Classic User Journey.
Das ist so ein Grundmuster, wo ich merke, ich habe jetzt glaube ich sieben oder
acht Projekte in der Art irgendwie am Start und die laufen immer nach dem selben
Grundmuster eigentlich ab. So wie kommt man in das Projekt rein und wie verläuft es dann.
Man hat am Anfang so eine Setup-Phase, wo man sich erstmal so seine Boilerplate-Templates
zusammensucht und was für eine Technologie will ich jetzt irgendwie haben und
klappt das alles mit den Schnittstellen oder meckern die APIs von irgendwelchen
Servern rum, wo man was gegen machen muss.
Das ist so ein bisschen anstrengend, aber irgendwann ist man da durch.
Da habe ich mal gesagt, das dauert ungefähr eine Stunde.
Und dann kommt diese totale schöne Hype-Phase, ich habe das hier mal Prototyping
genannt, zwei Stunden, ja, wo du so Feature auf Feature, Christmas Tree Approach
mäßig, genau, Tim hat schon gleich die Referenz.
Der Gartner Hype-Cycle.
Der Gartner Hype-Cycle ist hier quasi nachgemalt, ja.
Alles funktioniert out of the box, ja, die Maschine versteht dich und du denkst
dir, oh mein Gott, die Zukunft, endlich ist sie da. So und dann nach ungefähr
zwei Stunden bricht das Ganze immer in sich zusammen und man landet in so einem tiefen Tal der Tränen.
Die Komplexität nimmt zu, du bist plötzlich irgendwie so bei 800.000 Zeilen Code,
das LLM kriegt die Sachen nicht mehr so richtig zusammen, du sagst mach mal
ein Refactoring, das funktioniert so zu zwei Dritteln, dann fallen Sachen hinten
runter und du merkst einfach, okay, du hast jetzt irgendwie hier ein Konstrukt,
wo mehr dran hängen, Christmas Tree funktioniert nicht.
Ja, Refactoring auch nur so halbwegs, wie komme ich jetzt hier wieder raus?
Und das kann teilweise lang und schmerzvoll sein. Ich habe jetzt immer so fünf
Stunden angesetzt, bis man sich da so Stückchen für Stückchen wieder rausgearbeitet hat.
Und dann kommt so eine lange, kontinuierliche Konsolidierungsphase,
wo man dann vernünftig ist und nicht mehr von einem Feature zum nächsten springt,
sondern sich selber auch ein bisschen diszipliniert und dann wird man aber dann
doch sehr produktiv und endet dann am Ende dann doch wieder auf einem sehr positiven Outcome,
den man so in der Zeit vorher nicht geschafft hätte.
Aber die Kurve war bei, ich glaube, sieben Projekte habe ich jetzt gemacht und
bei mindestens fünf, eher bei sechs davon ist es genau so gelaufen.
Ich würde, also ja, ich stimme dir total zu, es deckt sich mit meinen Erfahrungen.
Ich würde sogar noch einen Schritt weiter gehen und sagen, dass diese Kurve
auch nicht nur sozusagen die Erfahrung in jedem einzelnen Projekt nachzeichnet,
sondern eigentlich eben auch die eigene Ausbildung als Vibe-Coder.
Weil man kann schon dann auch selbst irgendwann in dieser Konsolidierungsphase landen,
wo man dann eben diese ganzen Probleme nicht unbedingt immer wieder hat,
indem man einfach bestimmte Vorgänge nicht mehr so macht.
Also einfach Erfahrung durch Anwendung und durch Lernen.
Also man muss sozusagen seine eigenen Skills so ein bisschen konsolidieren.
Und ja, das ist eine ganz interessante Feststellung.
Ich habe also sehr viel Vibe-Coding betrieben in den letzten zweieinhalb Monaten,
muss ich sagen und ich bereue nichts.
Um das mal gleich vorne anzustellen zumal meine.
Ziele auch immer noch komplett kompatibel damit sind.
Nämlich erstmal war das Ziel, meine eigene Inkompetenz abzubauen,
die ich einfach, also ich habe das ja schon mal erzählt, aber ich habe früher
viel programmiert und quasi mehr oder weniger als Programmierer in diese Welt
gestartet, also in diese Computerwelt gestartet.
Das war am Anfang das Einzige, was mich eigentlich interessiert hat.
Ich wollte halt irgendwie verstehen, wie die Maschinen funktionieren,
habe viel Assembler gemacht, viel C gemacht,
aber dann halt irgendwann keine Lust mehr gehabt auf diese Welt,
die so unausgereift war. AC war einfach scheiße.
Bessere Sprachen waren irgendwie nicht so richtig am Start.
Und ich habe so eigentlich auch noch in so einer Welt ohne IDEs gelebt.
Also diese ganzen Advanced-Entwicklungswerkzeuge, integrierte Editoren mit Debugern
und allem möglichen Pipapo,
die einem das Auffinden von Funktionen leicht machen und Cross-Referenzen und
was das alles dann irgendwann so konnte.
Das war so erstmal nicht Teil meiner Ausbildung und das existierte damals einfach
alles noch gar nicht. Man musste irgendwie alles im Kopf haben,
man musste mal alles so richtig gut können.
Da muss man tatsächlich an der Stelle mal Microsoft loben, die damals zu Windows
NT Zeiten schon das Visual Studio war damals wirklich schon sehr gut,
was diese Sachen anbelangt hat.
Sowohl das Debuggen als auch das Finden
von Funktionen und so weiter und Code-Vervollständigung und so ein Kram.
Das ist eher schlechter geworden.
Naja, aber jetzt ist es halt einfach so, das heißt, ich habe da so einen Abriss gehabt und irgendwie,
ich habe nicht diese ganzen Erfahrungen mit den Tools und klar geht irgendwie,
kannte ich irgendwie alles im Prinzip, im Prinzip weiß ich, wie es funktioniert
und so weiter, nur wenn du das nicht regelmäßig machst,
dann hast du da keine Kenntnisse.
Da kannst du einen Podcast drüber machen, kannst dich irgendwie reinlesen,
kannst mal ein Buch lesen, kannst mal Manual studieren, aber nichts schlägt
eben die regelmäßige Auseinandersetzung.
Und in gewisser Hinsicht ist eben auch für das moderne Programmieren heutzutage
auch eine permanente Beschäftigung mit dem Thema wichtig, weil sich da erstmal
sehr viel verändert, verbessert, aber es ist vor allem auch viel geworden.
Also man muss viele unterschiedliche Programmiersprachen heute kennen,
um so halbwegs einen Überblick zu haben.
Also allein im Web muss irgendwie Grundverständnis haben von irgendeiner Backend-Sprache,
JavaScript muss es schon mal gesehen haben, muss im Prinzip den ganzen HTML,
CSS, Mumpets und alles, was mehr oder weniger drauf aufbaut,
zumindest mal so internalisiert haben.
Du musst dich mit Editoren auskennen, mit Compilern, mit Debugern, mit Analyse-Tools.
Du musst Gitgut kennen, musst diese kollaborative Arbeit kennen.
Du musst eine relativ erkleckliche Ahnung von Frameworks haben, die da draußen sind.
Du musst irgendwie die Betriebssysteme kennen. Du musst dann diese ganzen Development-Tools
und Continuous Integration und
irgendwie Docker und man muss nicht alles kennen, aber es gibt so viel,
was heutzutage eigentlich bei mehr oder weniger allen professionellen Projekten
in irgendeiner Form eine Rolle spielt, dass wenn du da eine größere Wissenslücke
hast, dann nimmst du daran nicht teil.
Also dann bist du intern und ich fühlte mich halt immer wieder auf diesen Praktikantenzustand zurück.
Dabei wollte ich einfach nur schöne Sachen für mich selber programmieren.
Aber ich habe das immer wieder gemerkt, um es wirklich richtig gut zu machen,
wie du es möchtest, in einer Sprache, die geil ist.
Es ist ein langer Weg. Und dann wäre die jetzt nicht unmöglich gewesen,
aber es ist viel Arbeit und es braucht längere Konzentrationsphase.
Und ich habe das ja gemerkt, als ich vor zwei Jahren gesagt habe,
okay, alles klar, jetzt mache ich mal drei Monate wirklich mal auch nichts anderes
und habe wirklich nur Elixier und irgendwie alle damit verbundenen Frameworks
und Tools und Werkzeuge und Editoren und so weiter, alles, was ich jetzt brauchte,
unmittelbar in mich reingefräst.
Und das hat auch ganz gut funktioniert, aber dann war dann irgendwann diese
Konzentrationsphase auch erstmal wieder beendet und dann kam wieder das Leben
dazwischen und dann geht auch wieder viel verloren.
So, und jetzt kommt halt irgendwie diese AI-Geschichte und die macht alles das
einfach, was da vorher schwierig war.
Dieses Ganze, womit fange ich eigentlich an? Was brauche ich?
Ein Setup, Boilerplate-Code, irgendwie, mal ein Prototyp, geht das überhaupt,
so wie ich mir das vorstelle, so einfach mal irgendwas ausprobieren.
Du hängst dann normalerweise stundenlang in irgendwelchen Syntax-Errors fest,
wo du irgendwie nicht weißt, wo oben und unten ist, aber es ist nur irgendein
Komma oder Punkt, der irgendwo an der falschen Stelle steht und die Fehlermeldungen
sagen dir nix und das Internet erzählt dir irgendeinen Quatsch darüber und weißt
nicht, wo vorne und hinten ist und die ganze Motivation ist irgendwie weg.
Und jetzt kann man halt ganz anders an die Sache rangehen und das funktioniert halt.
Und man kann sich sehr schnell jetzt auch in so Welten reinarbeiten,
die vorher einfach Bücher mit sieben Siegeln waren.
Und ich habe jetzt, habe ich ja schon erzählt, dass ich an verschiedenen Sachen gearbeitet habe.
Unter anderem kam mir auf der Reise die Idee, einen Slackbot zu programmieren.
Und gut, Slack-Bot, was heißt das?
Also man schreibt halt ein Programm, das klingt sich irgendwie in Slack mit
rein und taucht da halt irgendwie so wie so ein normaler Teilnehmer auf.
So denkt man sich das ja erstmal.
Slack-Bot, da gibt es irgendeine API und die benutzt man dann.
Genau, so ein Chat-Bot und dann denkt man halt so, ja okay, da habe ich halt
irgendwie angefangen und dann so, okay, was kann das Ding machen?
Ja, dann macht das so Kommandos und dann redet man mit dem und so halt so ein Chat-Bot.
So habe ich dann irgendwie auch angefangen, das funktionierte auch alles.
Und ja, dann habe ich dann angefangen, mir aber mal dieses Slack-Universum mal
ein bisschen genauer anzuschauen,
was da eigentlich alles so geht und ich muss feststellen, ich war etwas überrascht,
wie umfangreich das mittlerweile alles geworden ist.
Also auch Slack ist mittlerweile eine riesige Plattform geworden und hat zum
Beispiel seine komplett eigene UI-Sprache.
Also wenn du da halt irgendwie was darstellen willst in so einem Slack-Chat,
dann gibt es dafür das sogenannte Block-Kit, was halt so in JSON formulierte
Datenstrukturen sind, die so bestimmte Block-Types,
formatierter Text, Bilder,
Text mit Bildern daneben, es gibt so verschiedene
Gruppierungen bis hin zu User-Interface-Elementen, Texteingabe,
Checkboxen, Buttons all diese ganzen Sachen du machst das nicht in HTML,
sondern du machst das halt in Blogs und dann habe ich halt gecheckt,
dass man auch in Slack halt so eine App kann halt eine,
Homepage haben, also du kannst sozusagen so ein Bot programmieren und wenn du
den dann direkt anklickst, dann kriegst du so eine.
Ja drei Tabs heißt das irgendwie, der eine Tab ist einfach nur eine Information
der andere ist halt direkte Nachrichten Kommunikation mit dem Bot,
Die halt nicht in einem Kanal stattfinden muss, sondern quasi so Direct Messages.
Aber das hat dann nochmal so seine eigene Präsenz.
Und dann gibt es noch den sogenannten Home View. Und der Homeview ist halt etwas,
wo du dein eigenes User-Interface bauen kannst.
Mit Buttons, mit Dialogen, mit Modalen, wo du irgendwie Sachen angeben kannst und so weiter.
Und das funktioniert ganz leidlich, wenn man erstmal rausgefunden hat,
wie man mit dem Ding halt sprechen muss.
Aber ich konnte dann halt da eine Datenbank anklinken und konnte halt da richtig
irgendwie so typische CRUD-Interfaces bauen,
so als wäre das so eine Webseite, aber halt alles innerhalb von Slack,
so richtig mit User-Interface,
und allen möglichen Klimpeln.
Ja, das funktioniert in der Tat ganz gut.
Und da habe ich dann irgendwie ewig dran rumgefeilt, bis das alles irgendwie
ganz ordentlich funktioniert hat und feile da auch immer noch dran rum.
Und das geht halt einfach so. Und habe dann ein Notificationsystem eingebaut
und dann ja für in Slack und ja vielleicht dann vielleicht auch außerhalb von Slack.
Ja, dann habe ich das mal für Blue Sky implementiert. Das war dann irgendwie
in einem Tag fertig. Dann habe ich das für Masterland gemacht,
das war in einem halben Tag fertig.
Und auch so nicht nur mit hier der Code dafür, hier der Code dafür,
sondern das ist halt alles so schön mit Protokollen generisch,
dass sich irgendwie jedes Modul sich da reinplugt und automatisch ein weiterer
Notification Service ist.
Permanent ist mal so am Refactoren und am Neumachen und ja und,
der Progress ist einfach so absurd schnell es gibt da gar keine Worte dafür
es ist einfach lässt sich in Zahlen gar nicht ausdrücken das ist wirklich krass.
Ja und das mit diesem Slackbot, das war nämlich ganz interessant Das hat mich
nämlich dann auf eine alte Idee wiedergebracht und da wollte ich mal mit euch
jetzt mal drüber diskutieren,
weil da ist jetzt so viel Code entstanden, den ich ganz gut wiederverwenden
kann und dachte mir, vielleicht bauen wir ja mal so einen Slackbot hier für
den Live-Chat in der Freakshow.
Und der macht was?
Da sehe ich im Wesentlichen zwei Anwendungen.
Anwendung 1 ist so ein bisschen das naheliegende, Shownotes einsammeln.
Also etwas strukturierter, als man das derzeit tut.
Derzeit schmeißen halt alle irgendwelche URLs rein, aber sie schmeißen halt
die URLs aus allen möglichen Gründen da rein.
Man könnte es so ein bisschen machen wie die Kollegen bei Audiodump,
die nur für die Shownotes nochmal einen eigenen Kanal aufmachen.
Ja, kann man machen, könnte man aber auch anders machen.
Hin und her schalten und viele Sachen im Auge behalten.
Genau, Kontextwechsel, anderer Aufwand und es wäre eigentlich besser,
wenn man halt irgendwie den Bot direkt anspricht, dem einfach eine URL vorwerft
und automatisch noch vielleicht eine Beschreibung dazu und das wird dann wirklich
in so eine Datenbank übernommen und mit diesem Home-Tab könnte man sozusagen
jederzeit in so eine Übersicht kommen,
wo dann auch schon alle Shownotes nach Zeit sortiert drin sind,
wo man die dann auch direkt dort bearbeiten kann.
Sozusagen mit Beschreibungen oder mit Bewertungen oder ja, nein oder keine Ahnung.
Oder vielleicht in der Reihenfolge oder Zuordnung sortieren, keine Ahnung.
Also das ist jetzt nur alles jetzt mal ins Grobe gedacht, weil man muss natürlich
bei sowas immer aufpassen, dass man das auch nicht total overingeniert und dann
benutzt es wieder am Ende keiner.
Und als ich darüber nachgedacht habe, dachte ich mir so, Okay,
vielleicht ist das dann doch ein bisschen zu viel Klimbim, um etwas,
wo es eigentlich im Wesentlichen nur darum geht, dass die URL nicht verloren
geht und dass man sie von den anderen unterscheiden kann.
Also wenn man halt einfach sagt, was ich, addbot.
URL, dann ist das sozusagen schon mal eine explizite Information,
dass man gerne möchte, dass das in die Shownotes kommt versus,
ich werfe das jetzt mal hier in den Chat, um mit dem Chat, hier guck mal mein
Bild, guck mal meinen Link,
so ist es dann sozusagen eine offizielle Kontribution.
Hätte übrigens auch noch den Vorteil, dass man in dem Moment natürlich auch
den Kontributor mitspeichern kann.
Also es gäbe sozusagen die Möglichkeit,
in so einer Datensammlung halt auch Credits quasi zu verteilen.
Und die zweite Anwendung, die ich sehe, wäre ein Voting-System für Titel.
Ja, also wo man genauso so Titel
erstmal sammeln kann und dann so am Ende der Sendung macht man so ein,
preference-based System, wo halt dann Favoriten gebildet werden können.
Dann können wir uns daran orientieren, müssen aber nicht.
Nein, nein, das müssen wir natürlich nicht, aber es wäre sozusagen mal eine
interessante Anwendung, es wäre vor allem eine interessante Anwendung des Präferenzwahl,
des Präferenzwahlsystems. Ja.
Dann kommt title make title face gleich ganz nach oben.
Ja gut, aber wenn man nicht vorher sagt, dass man sich dem Votum unterwirft,
dann ist man sicher.
Meinst du?
Nee, aber ich halte das für ein gutes Wahlsystem. Sozusagen etwas,
wo man, also man würde sozusagen in seinem Home-Tab würde man quasi immer die
ganze Liste der Titel sehen.
Und dann am Schluss sagen, welche davon kämen für mich in Frage.
Und innerhalb dieser vergibt man eine Reihenfolge.
Ja, der C-Light im Chat, hallo C-Light, gibt nochmal einen Gedanken rein,
der mich ja auch echt hier schon seit Jahren jetzt umtreibt.
Wir haben halt doch, auch wenn wir ein Audio-Podcast sind, relativ häufig irgendwas an Bildmaterial.
Also gerade eben zum Beispiel hier mein Vibe-Coding-Graf. Das ist schon schön,
wenn man den sich jetzt zur Sendung auch einfach mal angucken kann und nicht nur erklärt bekommt.
Und hat Slack irgendeine Option, dass man auch ohne Anmeldung irgendeine Public-Seite
kreieren könnte, auf der einfach alle ausgezeichneten Bilder,
die während der Sendung eben an so einen Bot geschickt worden sind,
einfach nur in einem Gallery-View verfügbar wären?
Ja, ich kann, man kann, also innerhalb von Slack nicht, aber man kann einfach
noch einen Webserver dazu bauen.
Ja, also das fände ich schon, weil also ich weiß, du hättest das ganz gerne
irgendwie als Teil von einem wahnsinnig elaborierten Shownotes-Format und so
und ich sage immer, packst du doch in Ultraschall, dann sagst du,
ich will aber nicht so viele Kapitänmarken haben.
Ja, kann ich alles nachvollziehen, aber wir kommen da gefühlt irgendwie seit
zwei Jahren keinen Meter weiter und es wäre aber einfach mal geil,
die ganzen Bilder vernünftig irgendwie zu haben. Lass uns doch sowas bauen.
Wo zu haben?
Wenn du den Podcast hörst, hast du einen Link in den Shownotes zur Galerie und
da klickst du drauf und dann kriegst du eine vernünftig mobil nutzbare Galerie,
wo chronologisch sortiert vielleicht noch die Kapitelmarken sogar als Trenner
dazwischen irgendwie hast.
Also geht es jetzt um Kapitelbilder oder wo?
Nee, Bilder generell.
Ein Album?
Ein Album.
Und welche Bilder?
Die Slides.
Ja, welche Bilder sollen das sein?
Dann geh doch einfach mal unseren Chat hier durch, wie viele sinnvolle Bilder
zur Sendung wir schon hier drin haben. Bestimmt 15 bis jetzt.
Und da kommen noch ein paar dazu.
So, und die wären es total wert. Irgendwo.
Na, 15 sind es nicht, weil da sind halt viele Sachen dabei, wo ein Bild zu einem Link angezeigt wird.
Genau, aber hier zum Beispiel habe ich gepostet die Architektur vom Blue Sky,
wo man sieht, es gibt nur diese zentralen Relays und die sind eben nicht dezentral
so. Dieses Bild hätte ich gerne in den Shownotes. Kriegen wir derzeit nicht rein.
So, wir haben hier mein schönes Porträt von SafeSocial. Das muss vielleicht
nicht rein, aber es schaltet auch nicht.
Warte mal, warte mal, warte mal, warte mal, warte mal. Hält sich ja keiner davon
ab, einfach im WordPress daraus eine Galerie zu machen und hochzuladen.
Das ist ja relativ einfach.
Ja, aber wir sind doch jetzt hier nicht irgendwie in einer Steinzeit.
Wenn du jetzt schon gerade sagst, du willst solche Bots bauen,
wo du Shownotes automatisiert dann eben irgendwie weiterprozessierst,
dann lass uns das doch gleich für die Bilder machen. Das tut doch jetzt dann gar nicht weh.
Naja, also...
Weil ich will mich ja nicht nach der Sendung noch hinsetzen und dann noch einen
WordPress-Editor starten.
Der Feature-Request ist valide, würde ich sagen. Wie man ihn dann tatsächlich
gestaltet, ist wahrscheinlich eine andere Diskussion.
Also Shownotes und Bilder sind für mich erstmal...
Zwei Seiten einer Medaille.
Und ich glaube...
Zu diesen ganzen asiatischen Gerichten haben wir überall zu jedem Einzelnen
ein schönes Bild rausgesucht und gepostet.
Das wird alles vergangen in der Zeit wie Tränen im Regen. Die Arbeit...
Die Bildbegleitung, weiß ich nicht, wie man es nennt. Wahrscheinlich ist es
nicht das gleiche, Bilder und Shownotes, aber das ist, weiß ich nicht.
Hast du bei deinem Podcast damals sowas gemacht? Nein.
Da gab es einfach das noch nicht.
Okay, okay.
Mein letzter Podcast ist glaube ich zehn Jahre her.
Genau, und da hast du nicht mit Bildern gearbeitet. Ich habe das schon mal ein bisschen probiert.
Das Problem ist, Bilder sind, also ich sage nicht, das ist unmöglich,
ich sage nur, die mentale Last in der Postproduktion mit Bildern ist sehr hoch.
Darum sage ich ja, lass uns das deine mentale Last in der Post völlig rausnehmen,
indem wir einfach nur sagen, du kannst jetzt zu jedem Bild noch ein Kommando
sagen, schick das an den Bilderbot,
und der baut daraus eine statische HTML-Seite, unterteilt hinterher noch in
der Luxusvariante durch die
Kapitelmarken und das reicht. Mehr braucht man nicht. Voll automatisiert.
Du hast keine Sekunde Arbeit in der Post.
Also nochmal eine separate HTML-Seite. Das ist viel mehr Aufwand,
als das einfach nur noch mit WordPress reinzunehmen.
Die eigentliche Problematik, Also ein Album von guten Bildern da reinbringen
und den Bot so zu machen, dass Leute sagen, dieses Bild soll dann in diesem
Album landen und das dann irgendwie so zu separieren,
dass ich das schnell in WordPress übernehmen kann, da bin ich sofort dabei.
Ja, das ist sozusagen, das ist okay.
Kapitelbilder sind...
Eine extreme Last.
Ja, von denen rede ich jetzt aber gar nicht.
Okay, gut.
Wenn du es in WordPress haben willst und sagst, okay, du nimmst die WordPress
API und das da reinzuspeichern.
Keine Kapitelbilder, sondern halt einfach eine Bildbegleitung für Dinge,
die man halt als Bild im Chat hat.
Ja, ich nenne das Album. Ist eine ganz alte Potluff-Shownotes-Idee.
Übrigens habe ich schon seit Ewigkeiten in meinem White Paper drin.
Du hast halt bei Bildern oft immer noch das das Credit-Problem,
du musst dann bei jedem Bild immer noch sagen, von wem ist das,
dann hast du Copyright, Lizenz, Scheißdreck,
den ganzen Kram, das kommt da alles mit so und irgendjemand muss das prozessieren,
irgendjemand muss das bearbeiten.
Und ich kann dir mal sagen, wenn dieser Podcast fertig geschnitten ist,
ich die Shownotes, die Links am Start habe,
wenn ich auch noch eine halbwegs brauchbare Beschreibung gemacht habe und dann
auch noch das blöde Kapitel, das Sendungsbild generiert habe mit diesen bekloppten
AI-Editoren, die mir mittlerweile wirklich auf Keks gehen.
Auch vielen Hörern. Aber trotzdem ist es, wenn es gelingt, ein gutes Bild zu
generieren für die Sendung, finde ich das immer richtig geil.
Aber manchmal gibt es so Themen, wo mir einfach ums Verrecken nichts einfällt
oder es mir ums Verrecken nicht gelingt.
Vielleicht jetzt mit dem neuen
Bildgenerator von OpenAI, sollen wir vielleicht noch kurz drüber reden.
Ausprobiert habe ich ihn noch nicht. Vielleicht wird es jetzt einfacher,
Ich bin schon kurz am Verzweifeln und ich kann auch mal verstehen,
wenn Leute so, oh Gott, noch mehr AI-Slop, Visuella, verschone mich.
Kann ich auch verstehen, ist nicht immer alles gelungen, aber es ist ja auch ein Prozess.
Aber,
Das ist schon alles sehr viel Arbeit in der Postproduktion.
Manchmal geht es schnell, manchmal macht es einen wahnsinnig,
manchmal verzögert das irgendwie das Release um den Tag, weil man einfach nicht
zu Potte kommt mit diesem ganzen Bilderscheiß.
Kapitelbilder erzeugt richtig Stress in mir, der Gedanke, das dann immer noch
liefern zu müssen für alle Kapitel.
Ich weiß, es muss nicht für alle Kapitel sein, aber die ganzen Tools,
die wir derzeit haben, um das zu machen.
Aber von Kapitelbildern redet ja keiner.
Und wir reden von dem Bot. Und der Chat ist jetzt schon zwei Umdrehungen weiter.
Also das, was ich durchgehen lasse als Argument, ist die Sache mit dem Copyright.
Aber dann lasst auch hier so einen Modus nehmen, das wird hier auch schon vorgeschlagen.
Wir verlinken halt nur die Bilder.
Das heißt also, man macht nicht das Bild rein, sondern halt den Link zu dem
Bild, weil die wenigsten Bilder sind ja wirklich genehmigt von uns entstanden.
Müssen die aber irgendwo liegen, wo du sie verlinken kannst.
Ja, das sind sie ja, aber ansonsten hätten wir sie in der Sendung ja nicht auch irgendwo aus dem Weg.
Nee, oft kommen die Bilder auch einfach mit Paste und so weiter und Screenshots.
Also das Bild, was ich gepostet habe, kam aus meiner Fotos-Library.
Ja, aber dann gehört sie auch dir. Ja, dann kannst du ja differenzieren zwischen
Bildern, die du sofort 10-0 stellst.
Ja, aber ein Album muss man dann auch selber hosten. Also das muss dann schon
in der eigenen Datenbank liegen.
Links, die verrotten alle innerhalb kürzester Zeit. Gerade Bilder links verrotten sofort.
Das ist, dann hast du nur noch stale Links, das ist scheiße.
Dazu muss ich, da muss ich dir recht geben. Ich habe irgendwann einen Podcast
nachgehört, wo es sehr viel um Bilder ging, die eingeschickt wurden und die
Hälfte der Links war nicht mehr zu einem Bild.
Also das ist so, ja.
Also die Hörer sind hier ganz anderer Meinung, das können wir schon mal sagen.
Die wollen schon eine Hörerinnen-Gewerkschaft bilden.
Fangen wir an.
Früher hieß es noch Ultras, jetzt heißt es schon Gewerkschaft.
Das siehst du mal.
Wo wir hingekommen sind.
Eins lasse ich mir ja nicht anhängen, dass ich nicht hier...
Stetig und immer mir darüber Gedanken mache, wie das Produkt noch besser werden kann.
Da auch sehr viel meiner ganzen ProMir-Experimente in den letzten Monaten geht in diese Richtung.
Also ich habe zum Beispiel so ein Shownotes-Tool gebaut, was irgendwie Links
frisst und irgendwie ordentlich versucht, auf dem Internet,
herauszufinden, was sich hinter diesen Links verbirgt, um schon uns ordentlich darzustellen.
Also einen ordentlichen Titel, eine Zusammenfassung zu haben und Link. Was?
Gedanken reichen nicht. Wir brauchen Ergebnisse, Tim. Schreibt hier der Chat.
Wir sind alle Terroristen.
Nein, wir versuchen es nicht mit Gemütlichkeit.
Versuch dir mal in dieses Thema Link rausfinden, was der Titel ist.
Hast du das denn mal mit einer LLM probiert?
Jaja, ich hab da ein sehr großes Programm zugeschrieben Ich hab das Thema komplett
durchgearbeitet von A bis Z Und du kannst dir nicht vorstellen, wie schlimm es ist Doch.
Also da würde mir jetzt schon so eine Prompt-Kaskade einfallen,
die ich dann mal so probieren würde.
Ja, okay. Eine Prompt-Kaskade, okay.
Also erstmal halt die Seite selber ansteuern, gucken, was es dort halt an sowohl
Metainformationen als auch Informationen selber gibt.
Eine Google-Suche anschieben, gucken, was die Trefferliste hergeben.
Gibt es einen Wikipedia-Eintrag, gibt es einen Wikidata-Eintrag dazu.
Zum Link?
Ja, klar.
Ein Wikidata-Eintrag zu einem Link?
Naja, der Link ist ja selber, führt ja wohin. So, und da passiert dann ja was.
Ja, der Link ist halt in der Regel irgendeine News-Webseite.
Naja, oder eine Firmenseite oder was auch immer. Und dazu hast du dann vielleicht
durchaus einen Wikidata-Eintrag.
Ein Wikidata-Eintrag? Achso, du meinst, dass der Link als solcher irgendwo in
Wikidata für irgendwas steht?
Den Link vergesse ich jetzt gar nicht. Du willst ja nicht den Link posten.
Also ich hatte jetzt so...
Shownotes. Es ging mir um Shownotes. Ziel ist, ich habe einen Link und ich möchte
gerne einen Titel und vielleicht noch eine Beschreibung dazu haben und Klammer
auf, vielleicht auch noch ein Bild, aber das lassen wir jetzt mal raus.
Ja, aber das sollte doch Sonnet hinbekommen. Also hast du das wirklich schon...
Es geht nicht um Sonnet. Ich habe das Tool fertig. Ich kann dir nur sagen,
was für Probleme einem das Internet macht, an diese Informationen zu kommen.
Da kannst du programmieren, was du willst. Du musst ja, das Internet muss es
ja rausrücken und du glaubst gar nicht, wie viele Webseiten sich mit Händen
und Füßen dagegen wehren,
dass du herausfindest, was der Titel und der Inhalt dieser Webseite ist,
weil Copyright oder weil DDoS-Schutz.
Da kommt dann Cloudflare dazwischen und zweifelt erstmal an,
dass du ein Mensch bist. So, ich bin auch ein Mensch.
Zu Recht.
Zu Recht, ich bin ein ehrwürdiger Bot, der hier versucht, einfach nur den Titel rauszubringen.
Ja, dann kommen irgendwelche, dann kommt hier, wer war das? Nicht YouTube, sondern...
Äh, verdammt, habe ich gerade vergessen, welche Webseite war das?
Das war auch irgendwas von Google. Google, Google, Google, nicht YouTube, sondern...
Genau, so Halifax hier im Chat, genau so hätte ich das auch erstmal probiert.
CurlSide an LLM macht Titel, genau.
Ja, also du kriegst von so viel, mach das mal bei Golem, ja,
dann kommst du erstmal in deine Consent-Page, Redirects rein,
du wirst sowieso erstmal, hast du diese ganzen Bitly-URL-Shortner,
du wirst durch so eine Kaskade von Redirects durchgeladen,
ja, dann kommt dir Cloudflare dazwischen, dann Consent-Page mit,
ja, Werbung zustimmen, sonst gar nichts und so weiter.
Es gibt keine API, wo du einfach mal nur sagst, ich gebe mir einfach nur deinen
Scheiß-Titel. Wer will ich ja gar nicht haben.
Das Internet ist nicht so schön, wie du denkst.
Es gibt Webseiten, die werfen dir JavaScript vor, den du erstmal exekutieren
musst, um auf den eigentlichen Link zu kommen.
Und dann gibt es einfach viele, die machen einfach zu und sagen,
mich gibt es gar nicht. Hier gibt es nur Paywall und überhaupt und geh weg.
Das ist das Ding. Was ich gemacht habe, ist, Ich habe mir eine umfangreiche
Redirect Engine gebaut,
die also wirklich jedem Redirect folgt und unterscheidet, ob es sich dabei um
temporäre oder permanente Redirects handelt.
Gehe das so lange, so lange durch, bis ich bei dem finalen Ergebnis bin.
Dann nehme ich diese Webseite.
Dann schaue ich, ob ich in diese Webseite reinschauen kann, gucke durch das
HTML durch, durch die HTTP-Header und gucke, ob dort eine Referenz auf einen Canonical-Link ist,
damit ich solche Unterseiten von Unterseiten von Unterseiten irgendwie trennen
kann von die eigentliche URL. Dann nehme ich halt die.
Wenn irgendwelche Consent-Pages dazwischen kommen oder Cloudflare oder hast
du nicht gesehen oder hier gibt es nur JavaScript,
dann nehme ich den Umweg und gehe auf Archive.org und gucke in der Wayback-Maschine
nach, ob es dort noch einen Snapshot gibt von dieser Webseite und hole mir da
diese Informationen raus.
Hast du mal probiert, Google als Proxy zu nehmen?
Also die URL in Google reinschmeißen? Ich habe es gerade mal mit dem vorletzten
golem.de Artikel gemacht, sieben Stunden alt, löst mir Google schon korrekt auf.
Das ist eine sehr gute Idee, das kann ich auf jeden Fall nochmal einbauen,
erhöht aber die Komplexität noch weiter.
Naja nun.
Naja, ich meine, da musste ich ja jetzt erstmal überall durchmarschieren,
das musst du halt irgendwie auch erstmal hinbekommen, soweit bin ich schon mal gekommen.
Gibt es aber trotzdem noch Webseiten, die halt einfach sagen, ja nö, irgendwie 401.
Gibt es so Link-Preview irgendwie als Bibliothek von irgendwem, als Open-Source?
Bibliotheken helfen dir nicht weiter, wenn dir die Webseiten nicht antworten.
Nein, aber das Problem ist, jedes Chatprogramm hat ja das Willian Preview-Anzeigen
zu einem Link, den du in das Chatprogramm bürgst.
Ja, das funktioniert deshalb, weil die halt entweder einen Service nehmen,
der sozusagen bezahlt ist,
der wiederum von diesen ganzen Webseiten freigeschaltet ist,
dass die mit ihrem Bot da drauf dürfen, aber ich halt nicht von meiner blöden Domain aus.
Und ich könnte halt natürlich mir so einen Dienst nehmen und mir das davon liefern lassen.
Aber dann muss ich dafür halt Geld zahlen oder irgendwie abgeben.
Oder du machst einen Hidden Channel im Slack auf, der den Link reinpostet.
Dann guckst du nach, was da für eine Preview rauskommt.
So nämlich, Roddy. So nämlich. Das ist gut.
Ja, es ist nicht so ganz das, was ich so als Open-Source-Lösung publizieren wollen würde.
Nein, das ist Das ist jetzt natürlich kein Open-Source-Vorschlag,
aber es wäre vielleicht auch möglich.
Das Ding ist, dass, ich weiß nicht genau, Apple hat, glaube ich,
auch einen Service für sowas?
Ja, wir müssen das im Detail auch nicht durchsetzen.
Ich wollte nur sagen, es ist ein Aufwand.
Also allein mein Ziel, ordentliche Shownotes aus Links, die ich gesammelt habe, zu machen.
Im Sinne von, ich habe einen Titel dafür,
ich habe den Namen der Webseite, ich habe den Link, der wirklich der korrekte,
kanonische Link ist, befreit von allen Werbeparametern und sonst irgendwie Search,
dritte Seite und so weiter.
Weiter, ja, plus noch eine Zusammenfassung.
Ich habe am Ende, wenn ich, nehme ich das, äh,
wenn ich keine, wenn da keine Open Graph Information mit einer Summary drin
ist, dann schmeiße ich das nochmal irgendwie mit ChatGPT in dessen API,
lass mir eine Summary davon machen lassen, das geht mit PDFs und so weiter.
Wenn ein Link auf ein PDF ist, kann ich mittlerweile auch eine Beschreibung dafür bekommen.
So, ist alles drin in diesem Tool, ja, habe ich alles irgendwie mit Claude und
Sonne zusammen geballert. Aber es ist halt,
Es macht dich wahnsinnig, wie sehr sich dieses Internet dagegen wehrt,
einfach benutzt zu werden.
Ja, vor allen Dingen willst du natürlich nicht für jeden dritten Link,
den du irgendwann zugeschmissen bekommst, an deinem Tool feilen,
weil du mal wieder eine Website erwischt hast, bei der nichts geht.
Genau.
Also das ist schon klar, dass man da eigentlich diese Aufgabe an irgendjemanden
abwälzen will, der weiß, was er tut oder zumindest Power reinsteckt.
Ich habe sogar URL-spezifische Händler drin.
Also wenn ich auf Wikipedia linke, dann benutze ich natürlich die Wikipedia-API.
Wenn ich einen YouTube-Link habe, dann benutze ich die YouTube-API.
Die haben zumindest eine, wo ich sagen kann, hier, sag mir, was das ist.
Und dann weiß ich halt auch, ist das ein Video, ist das eine Playlist,
ist das eine Autorenseite und so weiter.
Also das habe ich alles klassifiziert und habe sozusagen für diese einzelnen
Untergruppen von populären Webseiten, wo man sowieso am meisten hinlegt noch spezielle Sachen Du.
Musst halt auch alles pflegen, weil da gibt es auch immer Änderungen und dann brechen Ja.
Wobei so eine API ist einfacher zu pflegen als dieser ganze andere Co Eine gute.
API ist ein Versprechen, dass die sich nicht so schnell ändert.
Hast du das schon auf GitHub irgendwo den Kram, den würde ich mir in der Tat
gerne mal angucken Ja, mach doch mal Ja.
Ist noch nicht fertig Achso.
Weil dafür gibt es natürlich, also das ist ja erstmal alles,
so das hört sich ja hier gerade sehr grundkritisch an, so nach dem Motto,
mach doch einfach was lecker und dann läuft das. Wahrscheinlich wäre das der
wirklich einfachste Weg.
Aber grundsätzlich finde ich das natürlich großartig, was du da tust.
Also von daher, das könnte in vielen Kontexten total nützlich sein.
Ja, auch ganz fernab von irgendwie Podcasts.
Das muss ordentlich sein.
Mach's mal fertig.
Fertig?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das fertig kriege, aber ich arbeite für mich ist das Research.
Für mich ist das sozusagen derzeit einfach auch das Ding und ist auch alles
so ein bisschen Teil einer etwas
größeren Idee eines potenziellen Potlars-Riefreides, dass man einfach da,
neuen Code bekommt, um irgendwie mit den Sachen zu machen, aber es ist halt
ein weites Feld und man muss das exploren.
Aber ich wollte ja jetzt eigentlich nur über diesen Bot reden.
Ihr kommt jetzt gleich wieder mit euren Bildern. Ihr macht mich wahnsinnig.
Was haltet ihr denn von dieser Titelidee?
Ja, das ist ja sehr niedrigschwellig. Also sehr unterkomplex würde ich jetzt sagen, oder?
Ja, mit dem Auswerten am Schluss und das ja.
Naja, nicht unterkomplex, aber das klingt jetzt nicht nach einem Research Project so wie das andere.
Ja, also man muss dann auch schon nochmal so die Möglichkeit zu Dubletten rausfiltern,
weil Leute den gleichen Vorschlag reinschreiben, bloß mit unterschiedlichem
Wording und so, dann willst du die dann irgendwie auch zusammenführen noch und
dann brauchst du halt wieder, wer macht das, darf dann jeder drauf rum machen
oder brauchst du Moderatoren,
genau, dann musst du noch eine rechte Verwaltung mit einbauen,
alles gar nicht so einfach.
So, gibt es denn noch andere Ideen
was man in so einem Bot, in so einem Freakshow-Chatbot reinbauen muss,
außer Links sammeln und Titel sammeln jetzt möchte ich gerne wissen,
ob der Chat der man alles kommentieren muss noch gute Ideen haben,
hat ich schreibe.
Mal auch wieder Bilder.
Wo denn genau.
Wir machen einfach ein YouTube-Format dann haben wir das Problem darüber erledigt.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall für Ideen zu haben könnt ihr ja zur Not auch noch in
die Kommentare reinschreiben von Transpenden.
Button schreibt Morleid.
Spontan-Spenden-Button. Dafür brauche ich keinen Bot.
Dafür gibt es Apple Pay.
Okay, Screencast vom Chat mit der Sendung synchronisiert auf YouTube ist auch
jetzt nicht das Richtige für Slack-Bot, oder? Sehe ich das falsch.
Wenn man es auf YouTube haben will, dann kann man es gleich auf YouTube streamen,
dann ist der Chat da mit dabei. Aber dann habt ihr halt nur einen YouTube-Chat.
Das wollt ihr nicht.
Hast du eigentlich schon jetzt für deine ganzen Sachen ein Framework,
wo du selber quasi einen LLM eben ansteuern kannst von wo auch immer.
Um also beispielsweise jetzt auch so ein Bot mit in Anführungszeichen Intelligenz
schon auszustaffieren und zu sagen so die...
Also außer, dass ich jetzt runtergeladene Datei aus den Shownotes nochmal mit,
4O Mini zusammenfassen lasse, habe ich jetzt nichts gemacht.
Okay. Also da habe ich jetzt halt im Kontext meine beiden letzten Projekte ein
bisschen mehr mitgemacht.
Ich habe ja diese Open Router Framework, hatte ich ja schon ein paar Mal erzählt,
wo du Geld drauf schmeißt und dann alle Modelle zur Auswahl hast.
Und die haben halt eine API, wo du dann also problemlos halt von draußen sagen
kannst, so dieses Modell will ich haben, da ist mein Prompt, da ist der Content.
Dann kriegst du die Sachen zurück und kannst dann mit dem Code machen,
was auch immer. Das ist schon sehr, sehr geil, weil das echt nochmal wieder
einen völlig neuen Level von was können deine Tools so alles,
ohne dass du dir den Arm brechen musst, verarbeiten kannst.
Kannst du dir ja vielleicht dann auch nochmal angucken, ob das nicht so das
eine oder andere Problem noch löst.
Man kommt irgendwann in ein Geldproblem, es kostet halt, es ist nicht umsonst,
solange wir es nicht lokal betreiben.
Hier kommt noch sowas wie Q&A,
Hörerschaft, Thema wünschen, über das wir reden müssen, hat ja so ein bisschen was von Q&A.
Ich meine, man könnte natürlich sowas machen, wie die Leute können Fragen stellen
und dann müssen sie abvoten und eine Frage wird dann beantwortet oder irgendwie sowas.
Wie heißt denn das Tool, was das normalerweise macht?
Egal, nicht so wichtig.
Kommt drauf an. Also ich meine, YouTuber machen das mit Kommentaren und dann mit Kommentarvoting.
Aber das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee, mit Fragen sozusagen an die Sendung.
Ja, ja, an uns.
Die dann während der Sendung oder auch zwischendurch entstehen können.
Weiß ich nicht. Soweit habe ich noch nicht darüber nachgedacht.
Aber im Prinzip ist es so, wenn man jede Frage beantworten will,
wird man nicht fertig und sind vielleicht auch nicht alle spannend.
Nee klar, für uns wäre es ja dann eher so, man nimmt halt die,
die wirklich am populärsten sind.
Genau, dafür braucht man aber ein Upvoting und dann kann man immer sagen, wir sammeln Fragen,
dann kann halt gewotet werden, vielleicht bis zur nächsten Sendung und dann
werden die populärsten Fragen beantwortet oder am Ende der Sendung. oder irgendwie sowas.
Keine Ahnung, ob das sinnvoll ist.
Ich hatte mir tatsächlich noch hier Ankündigungen der Live-Sendung noch notiert.
Also, dass wenn man eh im Slack ist sozusagen, dass man sagen kann, sag mir Bescheid,
wenn die Live-Sendung angekündigt werden soll oder so, aber ich glaube,
ich kümmere mich erstmal um die Sache mit den Shownotes und mit dem Titel.
Und den Bildern.
Und den Bildern. Geh weg. Euren Scheiß.
Bilder.
Bilder gesagt.
Na gut. Lass uns dann vielleicht gleich nochmal nachholen, welche schönen Updates
es bei unserem Lieblings Vibecoder-Tool gegeben hat.
Oh ja.
Cursor. Ich weiß, es gibt auch Z, es gibt auch andere und so weiter.
Wir benutzen Cursor, deswegen ich kann mich ehrlich gesagt jetzt nur zu Cursor
äußern und ich kann mich eigentlich auch nur zu Claude Sonnet von Anthropik äußern,
weil das ist einfach zumindest für meine Zwecke und ich höre das aber auch von vielen anderen Leuten,
das beste Modell oder zumindest ein sehr gutes Modell für Coding.
So, weil es halt einfach sehr gut ist.
Co-Pilot ist jetzt auch drin.
Was?
In Co-Pilot ist es auch drin.
Load ist in Co-Pilot drin.
Ist in Co-Pilot drin. Ich habe die Meinung gehört, Sonnet 3.5 ist scheiße,
braucht man gar nicht erst zu versuchen, aber 3.7 wäre geil.
Da sage ich gleich was zu.
Ich habe es selber noch nicht probiert, kann dazu nichts sagen.
Du kannst mal den Link aufrufen, den ich gerade in den Chat geworfen habe.
LLM Rankings. Das ist genau von diesem Framework, was ich gerade eben sagte, dieses Open Router.
Und das ist mal im Zeitverlauf, jeweils eine Woche, welche LLM-Modelle für welche
Use Cases gerade, wie häufig über diese API angefragt und ausgeliefert werden.
Und da kann man schön sehen, wie die Modelle populärer werden oder wieder in
ihrer Strahlkraft verlieren.
Und oben kannst du umschalten über diese Bubbles in was für verschiedenen Kategorien.
Ja, also willst du jetzt irgendwie Science haben oder Legal oder Fiance oder
eben Programming, das ist das, was jetzt hier gerade ausgewählt ist.
Und da sieht man, dass also 3.7 Claude Sonnet, das normale Modell,
hier die Welt echt im Sturm genommen hat.
Also von einer Woche auf die nächste, gehen wir aus dem Hover raus gerade.
Ja, also seit es da ist quasi, hat es komplett die 3.5er vorher kannibalisiert,
spielt keine Rolle mehr und wurde vollständig durch die 3.7 verdrängt.
Ja gut, weil es sich im Wesentlichen eigentlich genauso verhält und halt die
bessere Version ist, die benutzen jetzt alle.
Aber wenn ich das hier richtig interpretiere, nimmt ja Claude Sonnet in dieser
Liste irgendwas zwischen 80 und 90 Prozent ein.
Ja und genau, das ist quasi das zweite, was man daraus ziehen kann und den zweiten Link,
den ich jetzt nochmal in die Shownotes werfe zur ähnlichen Fragestellung,
also warum ist das so, warum ist das so populär,
das ist jetzt hier die Web-LMN-Arena-AI.
Okay, was du wieder für Sachen ausbuddelst.
WebDevArena Leaderboard.
Fight.
Real-Time AI Coding Competition.
Where models go head-to-head in Web-Development Challenges. So,
und das ist auch ganz lustig, da gibt es auch immer so kleine Web-Programmieraufgaben
und immer zwei Modelle werden aufeinander gehetzt und User voten,
ohne zu wissen, welches Modell wohinter steckt.
Was ist die bessere Lösung.
Was ist die bessere Lösung. Und da ist also auch Claude 3.7 unangefochten auf
dem ersten Platz mit 4800 Votes versus zweiter Platz ist 1600 erst,
also mehr als ein Faktor 2 Abstand hier an der Stelle.
Zwei ist dann Gemini, drei ist Cloud 3.5 immer noch, vier ist Deep Seek R1,
sechs ist Early Grog 3, hier die X-Geschichte von Musk.
So und er ist auf Platz Nummer 5 hier, kommt überhaupt, also punktgleich glaube
ich, so soll das hier ungefähr heißen, O3 Mini in der High-Variante.
Das heißt also OpenAI ist hier, was jetzt diese Webprogrammiergeschichten sagt,
mittlerweile schon echt hinten dran.
Die sehen da kaum noch so richtig Land derzeit.
Auch interessant. Wie gesagt, Fokus nur Webprogrammierung hier,
sicherlich nicht allgemeingültig.
Ja, also ich kann das also es deckt sich einfach mit meiner Erfahrung auch wenn
ich jetzt nicht solche Vergleiche gemacht habe, ich habe jetzt mit Gemini noch
überhaupt nicht gearbeitet das ist auch so,
der Gewöhnungseffekt ist enorm also wenn man erstmal gelernt
hat mit so einem Model richtig zu reden dann ist
das ein Erfahrungswert in sich wie mit einer Programmiersprache an sich klar
zu kommen also du weißt wie du fragen musst du weißt wann du vorsichtig werden
musst was das Ding schnell übertreibt und mit welchen Formulierungen es du zu
sehr ins Halle zu Nieren reindrückst.
Man muss halt versuchen, diesen Diskurs so formal wie möglich zu halten und so mit den richtigen,
Emotionalen Ausdrücken auch in die richtige Richtung zu lenken.
Ja und ich muss sagen.
Den richtigen Vibe.
Also ich fremde nach wie vor mit dem Sonnet 3-7. Ich finde das schwierig.
So, ich habe halt jetzt echt lange mit dem 3-5er gearbeitet und habe mich da
gut eingegroovt gehabt.
Und das 3-7er reagiert da schon, finde ich, sehr anders.
Und das 3-7-Thinking nochmal anstrengender. Das ist dann nochmal so die,
wir packen nochmal zusätzliches Reasoning obendrauf und jetzt ist noch ganz
frisch die 3.7 Max Variante,
die sie bewerben mit whatever it takes, also da kann man auch mal vier Minuten
auf eine Antwort warten, so lange wird da Ressourcen drauf geworfen,
bis sie intern der Meinung sind, dass es gut ist.
Und mit diesen jetzt teureren, neueren 3.7er-Modellen, ich habe das Problem,
die tendieren zumindest bei meinem Use-Case, das wieder zu so einem brutalen Over-Engineering.
Die versuchen immer fünf Probleme gleichzeitig zu lösen und ich habe schon echt
mit dem Metaprompt, die man ja bei Cursor auch einstellen kann,
habe ich schon wirklich sehr harsche Sachen eingestellt.
Das ging, ich weiß nicht, ob du auch mal in den Cursor-Foren ein bisschen unterwegs bist oder?
Cursor-Rules.
Das ist auch, genau, die Cursor-Rules, da werden auch so Tipps gegeben und relativ
schnell kam so einer der aktuellen Weibgötter, hat so seine Geschichten dort
mal gepostet, so, wenn du XY machst, werde ich sofort entlassen.
Das ist zum Beispiel gerade so eine.
Cursor-Rule, die dann gut anhand schlachte ich dieses Kuscheltier.
Hilft aber allen nichts. Das setze ich da einfach drüber weg.
Mein einfaches Beispiel. Ich habe also irgendwie einen Webkram da gebaut.
So, funktioniert nicht, also schlägt Sony 3.7 Debugging vor.
Macht Sinn. So, sprich, in die Konsole werden irgendwelche Logs rausgeschrieben.
So, dann wurde irgendwann der Fehler gefunden, wurde auch gefixt, wunderbar.
Ich hatte aber halt jetzt auf der Browser-Konsole, bei jedem einzelnen Klick
hast du dann halt deine 30, 40 Debugging-Outputs noch irgendwie drin stehen.
So, jetzt habe ich also Sonnet 3.7 nichts anderes gesagt, als auf einer 400-Zeilen-Datei,
geh die bitte durch und entferne sämtliche Logs auf der Konsole.
Alles andere lass so, wie es ist.
Glaub mal nicht, dass es das hinbekommen hätte.
Ja, das habe ich in vier, fünf verschiedenen Iterationen versucht.
Er hat ständig Dinge umgebaut, Refactoring gemacht und es war eine glasklare Anweisung.
Ja, und ich wurde dann in den weiteren Iterationen immer klarer in der Angabe.
So, rühre keine Zeile Code an, wo nicht genau dieses... Er hat das nicht hinbekommen.
Das heißt also, dieses 3.7 hat so eine Eigenständigkeit, die sicherlich was
genialisches schon hat, so, aber das ist mir bisher so häufig über die Füße gekippelt.
Dass ich lieber die 3.5.
Annehme.
Fragen.
Vielleicht jetzt für die Leute, die noch nicht mit Cursor gearbeitet haben und
sich das noch gar nicht so richtig vorstellen können, vielleicht nochmal so
ganz kurz, wie das eigentlich real abläuft. Das ist eigentlich sehr einfach.
Cursor ist im Wesentlichen erstmal ein Programmiereditor.
Man öffnet also seine Texterteilen und hat da den Programmcode drin,
wie das sonst eben auch ist.
Schreibt den und startet dann im Terminal irgendwie kompulier mal und lass mal laufen.
Und zusätzlich kann man aber so rechts noch so einen Tab aufmachen,
wo man so einen Chatverlauf halt startet, der sich auf diesen Code bezieht.
Und jetzt, wie man das eben auch von ChatGPT und so weiter eben kennt,
ist das eben so ein Verlauf aus immer wieder Nachfragen und jetzt machen wir
das und jetzt machen wir das.
Hast du jetzt hier bei deinen negativen Erfahrungen, reden wir da von einer Kaskade von Prompts,
die aufeinander aufbauen und du bleibst immer in dem selben Chatverlauf oder
hast du diese Erfahrung auch genauso,
wenn du immer wieder einen neuen Chat aufmachst, weil du hast natürlich hier
immer auch wieder wie bei jeder LLM die komplette History mit drin und da kann
einem schnell mal was entgleisen.
Das kann sein. Ich glaube, ich habe kein neues Chatfenster gemacht.
Also was ich nicht mache, das ist ja auch eine der Grunderkenntnisse,
wenn irgendwas richtig schlecht läuft als Antwort, nicht versuchen,
das noch wieder mit einem neuen Prompt gegenzusteuern, sondern in der History
zurückrollen und präzisere Ursprungsanfrage stellen.
Oder nochmal komplett neu anfangen.
Aber einen komplett neuen Chat habe ich in der Tat an der Stelle nicht gemacht,
weil ich ja so Arbeitsthese wäre ja immer, Kontext ist gut dabei, aber...
Man kann halt auch zu viel Kontext haben, das ist eigentlich das, was ich sagen würde.
Das würde ich dann gleich nochmal ausprobieren auf dem Code hin.
Habe ich da irgendwo... Ich kann es so, zwar in Teilen habe ich das natürlich
auch erlebt, aber meistens war das dann auf mich selber zurückzuführen,
dass ich einfach dann zu viel wollte.
Also es lohnt sich einfach, die Maßnahmen möglichst zu isolieren und nicht,
weil wenn es schnell so, ah,
das hat ja super funktioniert, jetzt noch das obendrauf und nochmal mit Sahne
und nochmal mit Zuckerguss.
Und da überfordert man dann diese Modelle auch so ein bisschen.
Ja, aber rauslöschen von Logs fand ich jetzt keine echte Überforderung.
Ja, aber es ist halt irgendwann einfach zu viel Kontext und das funktioniert nicht gut.
Und gerade rauslöschen von Logs, ich weiß, das ist so, weil gerade dieses Einbauen
von Logs ist so eine dieser Stärken.
Ich baue mal überall irgendwie die Buglogging ein und dann finden wir diesen
Fehler schon und danach den Scheiß wieder loszuwerden.
Ja, da würde ich zum Beispiel den Tipp geben, dass du sowas sagst wie bau log
ein, aber hier das Log-File hat vorher nochmal so ein Identifier,
der jetzt sozusagen explizit für diese Debugging-Session ist.
Ja, ich will jetzt diesen Fehler finden.
Baue Debug-Logs ein, um diesen Fehler zu isolieren, schmeiße Variablen raus,
vorne steht aber immer x23.
Dann kannst du das danach mit dem Editor einfach nach x23 suchen und machst
delete, delete, dann bist du schneller fertig als jede LLM und die hat ja nicht
nebenbei noch die halben Kommentarrollen, dann funktionieren den Code mit raus.
Wie so ein Neandertaler.
Ja, also das sind so Erfahrungen, die ich gemacht habe.
Einen schönen Tipp, den ich ansonsten noch geben kann, auf den bin ich auch
erst vor zwei Wochen gestoßen, Screenshots hochladen.
Das heißt also immer, wenn man irgendwas mit einer GUI baut,
sprich Nutzerinterface, und irgendwas funktioniert nicht so oder irgendwas sieht
nicht so aus, wie man es gerne hätte oder irgendwelche Abstände stimmen nicht
und irgendwas ist nicht aligned und sowas.
Es ist nach wie vor sehr schwierig dem beizubringen, dass zwei Buttons mal auf
derselben Höhe sind und sowas.
Aber Screenshot machen, man kann auch drin rummalen, das mache ich also auch,
Pfeil drauf, Achtung hier, das meine ich.
Screenshot einfach reinpasten in Cursor, tippen so, schau dir den Screenshot
an, da wo der Pfeil ist, das hätte ich gerne zehn Pixel weiter nach unten.
Funktioniert fantastisch. Also Bildanalyse.
Ja, auch so Computer-Use ist ja so eins dieser Features, die sie vor kurzem
noch vorgestellt haben, wo sie explizit die Modelle darauf trainieren,
dir beim Arbeiten mit dem Computer zuzuschauen und das sozusagen zu unterstützen.
Das wird, glaube ich, später auch nochmal ganz interessant werden.
Ich wollte mal ganz kurz zusammenfassen, was eigentlich mit Cursor seit dem
letzten Mal passiert ist, jetzt konkret.
Also abgesehen davon, dass sie diesen Support für die ganzen neuen Sonnet-Modelle,
DeepSeq und so weiter eingebaut haben, gab es jetzt Cursor 047 und 048?
048 ist aber noch nicht raus. Habe ich bei mir nicht drin. Ich habe gerade eben
noch versucht zu updaten.
Das ist schon seit zwei Tagen. Musst du zur Not einfach direkt auf der Webseite.
Mit dem Update, das funktioniert manchmal nicht so gut.
Gibt es auf jeden Fall und im Wesentlichen sind die Änderungen dahingehend, außer der Modelle,
dass man jetzt so ein Multi-Chat-Interface hat, das heißt du kannst auch mehrere
Sachen parallel laufen lassen.
Du kannst also mehrere Chat-Tabs offen haben.
Und sie haben auch diese Konfusion, die man noch vor zwei Versionen hatte,
dass es irgendwie Chat und Composer und so weiter gibt.
Das haben sie jetzt komplett überarbeitet. Es gibt jetzt sozusagen Chat-Windows
und du kannst mit jeder einzelnen Anfrage immer wählen zwischen Agent oder Chat
oder wie sie es jetzt nennen, Ask.
Also entweder du fragst nur oder du sagst, sei ein Agent. Und mit Agent ist gemeint.
Benutzt deine Tools, benutzt die Kommandozeile, wirft den Compiler selber an,
liest die Logfiles durch, geht in die Dateien, macht Änderungen, schreibt Code.
Das ist sozusagen dieser Agent-Modus. Aber du kannst halt jederzeit sagen,
jetzt will ich nur was rausfinden.
Nicht immer dieses Anbetteln, bitte mach keine Änderung,
sondern du schaltest einfach auf Ask und dann sagst du einfach so,
erklär mal, erklär mal, erklär mal, erklär mal und gehst dann wieder auf Agent-Modus,
wenn du eben explizit machen möchtest.
Und außerdem ist es jetzt ein bisschen einfacher auch zu kontrollieren,
wann er Tools starten soll.
Also dieses Ganze, ich drehe jetzt total durch, lösche alle Dateien und es sieht
doch viel schöner aus, gucken wir hier.
Das versuchen sie gerade selber ein bisschen in den Griff zu bekommen.
Überhaupt finde ich, sind das ganz gute Sachen. Ich habe auch noch einen Tipp,
wie man noch vielleicht ein bisschen geordneter programmieren kann.
Und zwar bin ich da auch drauf gekommen, weil mir das auch selber vorgeschlagen hat. Pläne machen.
Also ich habe zum Beispiel verschiedene Migrationen gehabt,
so Datenbanken-Migrationen, die etwas umfangreicher waren oder auch solche Refactoring-Pläne,
wo ich halt irgendwie hier dieses Modul, das müssen wir irgendwie auseinanderklammbüsern.
Ich will das jetzt hier irgendwie in 30 Module für jeden Untertyp und so weiter
mit einheitlichem Protokoll aufbohren.
Und das war relativ haarsträumend.
Und dann habe ich halt gesagt, mach mir einen Plan.
Nicht schreib den Code, sondern ich erstelle jetzt ein Dokument,
in dem drinsteht, was der Plan ist.
Der wird erstmal reviewt oder dass man eben auch parallel immer dafür sorgt,
dass Dokumentation gleich mitgeschrieben wird also wenn man jetzt so ein neues
Modulsystem aufbaut dass man dann eben auch gleich sagt und jetzt hier schreibt
nochmal in diese Textdatei noch mit rein wie das alles gedacht ist und so weiter
also dass man diese Prinzipien die man in diesem Chat formuliert,
nicht nur zum Zwecke des Editierens,
quasi verwendet sondern danach auch zum Dokumentieren, wie das gedacht war.
Warum ist das hier alles so, wie es ist?
Das und das war die Idee und so haben wir das irgendwie implementiert.
Also nicht nur schreibt sich jeder Funktion, was sie macht, sondern eben immer
so Big Picture, auch eben für so untere Bereiche.
Das funktioniert eigentlich ganz geil.
Ja, das sind so meine Cursor Model Updates.
Ich versuche verzweifelt hier die 48 zu finden. Also im offiziellen Download
ist sie nicht. In meinem Update-Fenster ist sie nicht.
Echt?
Sie haben einen Blog-Beitrag dazu und es gibt sogar schon eine 48.2.
Ja, genau. Es gibt auch schon eine 48.2. Die läuft bei mir hier auch.
Tja, nur für die Besten der Besten, Sir.
Ja.
Okay. Ich habe nach einem Update, was er gemacht hat, jetzt die 45.14.
Bitte? Okay, da ist irgendwas erratisch. Wahrscheinlich wird das Update auch
mit so einem LLM-Prompt gemacht.
Schau doch mal nach, ob es nicht was Besseres gibt.
Ob die ihr Cursor mit Cursor schreiben?
So, jetzt noch was Lustiges.
Da könnte ich unter Umständen auch akustisch, glaube ich, noch beitragen.
Ihr kennt ja schon diesen Spaß mit, man lässt eine LLM mit einer LLM reden.
So ist es.
Auf GitHub gibt es die 48.2, muss man da wieder hin. Na gut, sorry.
Und das ist natürlich ganz lustig, wenn die sich sozusagen mit natürlicher Sprache
untereinander unterhalten, aber
warum sollen sich eigentlich Roboter mit menschlicher Sprache unterhalten,
dachten sich einige und haben Gibberlink erfunden und Gibberlink ist sozusagen eine Ist.
Es nicht Gibberlink?
Ja, Gibber, Gibber, Gibber, Gibber, Gibber, Gibber, Gibber, Gibber,
was auch immer Gib ihm Genau, gib ihm alles.
Und das ist sozusagen so ein frequenzbasierter Kommunikation und dann kannst
du halt so zwei Smartphones oder Laptops irgendwie nebeneinander halten,
die mit Mikrofon und Lautsprecher ausgestattet sind und hier ist so ein Beispiel,
ich spiele das mal abs nicht so lang.
Da finden sie quasi sich selber eine Sprache.
Die ist schon irgendwie, bin mir jetzt gerade nicht ganz sicher,
hier ist es gibt da eine richtige Implementierung. Also auf,
gbrl.ai gibt es sozusagen eine Webseite, wo direkt über der Link gesprochen,
wird. Das klingt dann so.
Wie ein Modem.
Ja, aber wie ein sehr schlechtes Modem.
Genau.
Da ist noch sehr viel Raum für Verbesserung.
Auf jeden Fall, hier ist der richtige Dialog.
Man kann jetzt mitlesen, was sie gerade angeblich von sich lösen.
Yes, perfekt für 150.
Es ist aber nicht sehr viel schneller als die normale Sprache,
ehrlich gesagt. Und sie ist schneller als er.
Na ja, sie ist ja auch ein Mac und er ist ein iPhone.
Aber lustige Idee.
Okay, ich meine...
Aber schöne Idee, ne? Warum sollen die nicht ihre eigene Sprache haben?
Ja, aber lustig wäre es ja, wenn die sich eine eigene Sprache erfinden würden.
Weil das ist jetzt wieder eine Annahme von Menschen, was jetzt eine effiziente,
frequenzbasierte Sprachform wäre.
Und ganz ehrlich, ist es nicht. Ich habe das studiert, nein,
Modems klingen so, wie sie klingen, weil das ist das Optimum,
was du aus einer Telefonleitung rausholen kannst.
Genau. Zumindest die alten Modems.
Naja gut. irgendwann war Schluss, weil...
Wieso Schluss? Es gibt ja auch heute Modems auf anderen Medien.
Nein, aber Modems, die tatsächlich über eine Voice-Verbindung...
Telefon.
Telefon, genau.
Aber Modem heißt ja an sich erstmal...
Ja, ja, schon. Aber wenn er sagt,
klingt wie ein Modem, dann meint er ein Telefon-Modem-Voice-Verbindung.
Ja, weil es auch nur so zum Spaß, ne? Ähm...
Äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, ein sehr, äh, kennt ihr Lori Wyatt?
Die Dame kann man sowieso immer empfehlen.
Kenne ich, glaube ich, nicht.
Lori Wyatt ist eine sehr talentierte Programmiererin, die sehr informative kurze
YouTube-Videos auch produziert, unter anderem.
Und die hat es irgendwie richtig drauf.
Und die hat auch coole Ideen. Und sie hat, ähm, ich hatte doch in der letzten
Sendung die MCP erklärt, diese Model, Kontext, Protokoll, Server und Client-Systeme,
die Anthropic vorgestellt hat.
Das ist ein Protokoll, das setzt sich jetzt langsam ziemlich durch, habe ich den Eindruck,
weil man plagt sozusagen damit vor irgendein beliebiges System ein Interface
und definiert im Wesentlichen Funktionen und beschreibt sie einfach mit Text.
Das ist so mal so kurz gesagt, dass was ist.
Und oh Gott, wo habe ich denn jetzt hier den Link dazu eigentlich. Hier unten, ist das der?
Ne, das ist nicht der. Da muss man mal kurz schauen.
Was sie gemacht hat, ist, sie hat ein Open Source Debugging System,
das nennt sich Gidra, genommen.
Und Gidra schreibt sich G-H-I-D-R-A.
Und das ist so ein typisches Code-Analyse-Tool.
Das heißt, du kannst da irgendwelchen Binary-Code reinschmeißen und dann disassembliert
der also das quasi für die jeweilige Prozessor-Architektur, für die das gedacht ist,
also zum Beispiel Intel-Code oder so für Windows oder für ARM-Code für irgendein Smartphone.
Und was sie jetzt gemacht hat ist das ist jetzt mehr oder weniger so ein Beispiel
eigentlich dass sie einen MCP-Server dafür geschrieben hat und,
wieso finde ich jetzt dieses Video nicht hier.
Verdammte Axt, ich suche es gleich raus auf jeden Fall,
Hat sie das davor gemacht. Normalerweise, wenn du was disassemblierst,
hast du ja da keine Symbolinformationen mehr drin.
Das heißt, du nimmst zwar den Code und der Computer kann sehen,
das sind die und die Instruktionen und du kannst das dann auch in so C-artigen
Code zurück übersetzen, weil C in Assembler ist ja meistens irgendwie eins zu
eins mehr oder weniger abbildbar.
Das heißt, du kannst in so einer C-Sprache quasi lesen, was da assemblermäßig abgeht.
Aber alle Identifier sind halt irgendwie irgendwelche komischen Gabel-Strings.
Weil du präferenzierst halt irgendeine Variable, die irgendwo im Speicher ist.
Und die heißt dann halt LBXYA9478.
In solchen Tools kannst du die dann normalerweise alle umbenennen.
Genau, du hast dann so die Möglichkeit, die anzuklicken und zu sagen,
okay, das macht das und dann benennst du die um und dann wird dir langsam so
Schritt für Schritt klarer, was das Tool eigentlich macht.
Und was sie jetzt gemacht hat, ist sie hat so einen MCP-Server für ein Large
Language Model gemacht und hat gesagt, hier sind diese ganzen Funktionen von
Gidra, also mit irgendwie instruieren mal das Ding jetzt so disassemblieren
oder benennen mal was um.
Also all diese Funktionalitäten, die da drin sind, hat sie quasi über diesen
MCP, über dieses Protokoll an den LLM,
exponiert, ist dann mit Cloud rangegangen, also mit der Desktop-App und diesen
MCP-Server gemacht und dann irgendeinen MyWare-Code genommen, der halt so als Binary,
da lag, der dann eben disassembliert wurde und dann gehst du einfach nur noch
in den Cloud rein, in die LLM und sagst,
analysier jetzt mal dieses Programm und benenn alle Variablen nach ihrer Funktion um.
Zack, Return. Und sowas kann halt diese Modelle echt richtig gut.
Also Sonnet, haben wir ja nur viel darüber gesprochen, kann gut Code erzeugen,
aber es kann halt auch echt gut refaktorieren.
Das heißt, es liest Code, findet raus, was es macht und ist ohnehin schon sehr
gut, wie ich finde, immer bei der Benennung von Variablen und Funktionen.
Also das finde ich fast mit am erstaunlichsten, wie geil lesbar der Code ist.
Ja und in dem Fall war das sozusagen so Zack, Return, bumm und auf einmal war
dieses vollkommen unleserliche Zeug auf einmal so benannt.
Weil sozusagen die LLM festgestellt hat, was genau der Code macht mit irgendetwas
und hat dann entsprechende Variablen entsprechend benannt, wie das eben benutzt wird in dem Moment.
Und das ist eine sehr überschaubare Geschichte.
Ich suche jetzt nochmal dieses Video raus. Ah ja, hier ist er auch, genau.
Da ist sie noch. Die gute, das kommt hier auf jeden Fall in die Shownotes und
das zeigt sehr schön, was halt diese MCP.
Server können und ich habe jetzt auch schon gesehen, MCP Server für Wikidata,
das dürfte dich interessieren, für Wikimedia-Projekte generell gibt es wohl
irgendwie auch schon so einen Ansatz.
Also das poppt jetzt einfach überall gerade auf, dass sozusagen jedes Datensilo
und jeder Funktionsblock, der in irgendeiner Form Interpretation seiner Daten erlaubt,
quasi mit einem MCP an so ein LLM herangedockt werden kann.
Und dann kannst du halt mit der Power of the Prompt dann sozusagen nicht nur
Text erzeugen oder Code erzeugen, sondern du kannst halt irgendeine Maschine
auf einmal damit fernsteuern.
Das ist schon ziemlich irre, was da passiert.
Ja, könnt ihr euch einfach mal anschauen. Ich habe da jetzt nicht sehr viel
mehr zu zu sagen, außer dass das eben, ja, dass das geht.
Ja, da muss ich mich, glaube ich, echt mal ein paar Nächte eingraben.
Mit diesen MCPs, das sieht schon alles sehr, sehr vielversprechend aus.
Und es vor allem dann auch, lässt sich auch wiederum mit einer LLM ganz gut
programmieren, sowas wahrscheinlich.
Tim, jetzt musst du ganz stark sein. Es gibt einen Ableton Live-MCP-Server.
Ultraschall-MCP-1 Airbnb Ja, das wollte ich jetzt auch gerade fragen,
Ja, ich meine, das ist natürlich interessant, ne? Was könnte man denn damit
machen, zum Audio-Ding? Was ist denn bei Ableton Live?
Geht's dann um MIDI, oder?
Unklar, ob das irgendwie eine Kollaborationssache ist, ich klicke einfach mal drauf.
Du kannst mit Ableton inzwischen ganze eigene Software also Software-Instrumente
zusammen klicken, weil sie ja mehr oder weniger so ein,
Signalverarbeitungstool eingekauft und integriert haben.
Zwischen LMS und Ableton Live über OSC-Format, das haben wir ja auch.
Also ich meine, ihr habt ja die Unterschallarten.
Das ist glaube ich Fernsteuerung der GUI, das ist glaube ich eher der Use Case.
Drück mal den Play-Button.
Schneide mir mal einen Podcast, hast, indem du erst die Stille rausschneidest
und jada jada. Jetzt guck mich nicht so an.
Ja, ich überlege gerade noch, ob es eine sinnvolle Anwendung gibt oder ob das
jetzt nur so ein ja, kann man mal machen.
Because we can.
Bau uns ein Vader-Filter.
Ne, aber es ist natürlich trotzdem ein gutes Beispiel. Der Use-Case ist noch
nicht so ganz klar, aber ein gutes Beispiel für, du hast eine komplexe Maschine,
die halt ihre Art von Daten vorhält.
In dem Fall halt Audio in Recks oder MIDI und Operationen daraufhin definiert.
Beziehungsweise in Loops.
Was auch immer ist, das Abspielen ist eine Funktion, aber auch Schneiden ist
eine Funktion, Analysieren ist eine Funktion und du kannst halt diese Funktion
über ein MCP dem LLM kommunizieren und sagen,
wenn du mich hierüber ansprichst mit diesen Parametern, dann beeinflusst du
diese Operation und hier ist eine Textbeschreibung, was das tut.
Und was das LLM einfach nur macht, nur in Anführungsstrichen,
ist eben diese Funktion einzulesen, sich sozusagen zu merken, okay,
welche Beschreibung gehört jetzt hier zu welcher Funktion, wie muss ich das
aufrufen und dann kannst du das eben in seine LLM-Operationen mit einbauen.
Und wir hatten ja glaube ich am Anfang das Beispiel mit Postgres,
das heißt der kann dann eben auf die Datenbank gehen, kann sich Tabellen anschauen,
kann sich irgendwie die Felder, die Relationen, die Joins, die Indexes und so
weiter anschauen und daraus seine Schlüsse ziehen.
Rejoice, es gibt einen Reaper MPC Server, Gott sei es gedankt.
MCP Server, da bin ich ja mal gespannt, was der jetzt macht. Aha, okay.
This is a simple MPC-Server that connects a Reaper-Project to an MCP-Client
like Cloud Desktop and enables you to ask questions about the project. Okay.
Was für Fragen könnte man an den Podcast stellen?
Hm.
Fragen Sie doch einfach Ihren Podcast direkt.
Ask away. Na okay, gut. Das gucke ich mir mal an und werde nächste Sendung berichten.
Was stellt er denn hier für Fragen?
Why does the mix on my Reaper Project sound muddy?
Ach.
Looking at the pupal issues. Multiple lead tracks with heavy reverb.
Zu viel Bass und so. Okay, interessant.
Zu viel Bass gibt es nicht.
Na, das schauen wir uns doch mal an.
Ja, okay. Ich meine, das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich mehr auf Audio-Mixing und
sowas bezogen und ich glaube, uns würden da eher andere Sachen interessieren.
Aber was wir auf jeden Fall mal brauchen ist, und ich frage mich,
ob ein MCP-Server hier die richtige Methode wäre,
auf der Webseite eine Freakshow einfach ein Bot, mit dem man irgendwie...
Die Transkripte nimmt und befragt. Also diese Hörerfrage Nummer 1 mit,
ihr habt doch mal in irgendeiner Folge über oder so ähnlich geredet,
welche war denn das nochmal und wo und wann und wie.
Genau diese Antwort, die würde ich ja gerne liefern und das wäre halt cool,
wenn man das so spezifisch genau auf diesen Daten machen kann.
Mir ist selber noch nicht ganz klar, mit welcher Architektur das eigentlich
am besten funktionieren würde und
ob die MCP-Server hier an dieser Stelle vielleicht schon die Antwort sind.
So wie ich es verstehe, wäre das ein Weg. Wir gucken uns das mal an.
Aber die MCP-Server sind ja eher dafür, eine existierende Funktionalität zu machen.
Die Transkripte haben ja in dem Sinne keine Funktionalität.
Die sind ja selber nur Text.
Also ich glaube, da sind wir noch nicht so ganz da...
Also du kannst natürlich einen Suchindex drüber setzen, aber dann bist du halt
wieder weiter weg von so einer Heuristik im Sinne von, ich suche etwas ähnliches
wie, hilft dir dann eine Solar oder sowas an der Stelle dann auch nicht so richtig weiter.
Naja, wir haben ja mit unserem FabBot sowas gemacht, wo wir ja unsere Datenbank
quasi dann eben so einen Vektorraum hochgeladen haben, mit dem eine LMM gut umgehen kann.
Aber das ist jetzt hier für die Freakshow, glaube ich, ein bisschen aufwendig.
Aber da hast du dann genau so einen Assoziationsraum, den du halt befragen kannst,
der dafür dann auch nicht so exakt ist.
Also entweder du hast halt so den Sinn und Grundsemantik gut verstanden oder
du hast es halt präzise, Beides gleichzeitig ist es schwer, in Deckung zu bringen.
Naja, also wenn ihr da mehr Erfahrungen habt, dann könnt ihr das mal in die
Kommentare schreiben. So.
Wollen wir mal zu was vollkommen anderem kommen. Könnten jetzt entweder Berichte
aus dem Leben oder aus der Apple-Welt.
Die Apple-Welt ist das Leben. Nein, natürlich ich nicht.
Ja.
Vielleicht Apple-Welt, oder? Leben zum Schluss.
Erstmal Apple-Welt, das machen wir mal ganz schnell. Also es gibt ja neue Macs.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es für uns jetzt ein großes Thema sein kann,
weil wir ja auch Das ist alles nur Speedbump.
Neuer Prozessor, gib ihm fertig.
Genau, also MacBook Air mit M4, MacStudio mit M4 Max und diesem komischen M3 Ultra für Leute,
die auf viele GPU-Cores stehen und irgendwie mit einem Stapel von fünf MacStudios
schon ihr eigenes Diebsieg zu Hause laufen lassen wollen,
was wohl schon ganz ordentlich geht.
Ich glaube, das waren fünf MacMinis, aber ja.
Ich habe zwei Mac Studios im Vollausbau mit 512 Gigabyte RAM.
Klar, die brauchst du dann auch.
Die dann aber das komplette Deep Seek, das vollständige mit 670 Billionen Tokens gefahren haben.
Ja, versuch nicht das mit Nvidia Grafikkarten abzubilden. vor allen Dingen nicht
neueste Generation, so viele Karten kannst du in Europa gar nicht kaufen.
Ja, vor allem das Interessante ist es ja, dass die Macs jetzt in diesem Anwendungsbereich,
der definitiv natürlich noch kein Massenanwendungsbereich ist,
aber immerhin ein Anwendungsbereich,
ihren Vorteil mit dem Unified Memory voll ausspielen, weil du natürlich jetzt
diesen Speicher komplett von der GPU mit nutzen lassen kannst,
was halt einfach sonst immer nur durch VRAM begrenzt ist, dann hast du da 16
oder 32 Gigabyte RAM, aber so ein Mac hat dann halt einfach mal 512 Gigabyte RAM,
wenn du bereit bist, 17.000 Euro für so eine Maschine.
Ich meine, es gibt im Prinzip es gibt im Prinzip AMD Prozessoren mit Grafikeinheit,
die sowas ähnliches könnten, aber ich glaube, da kriegst du auch keine Systeme,
die so unglaublich viel Speicher haben.
Die sind da noch ein bisschen hinterher und bei Nvidia ist sowieso Da kannst du auch Apple kaufen.
Wieso? Weil es teuer ist, oder was?
Ja. Alles, wo Nvidia AI draufschreibt, da kannst du auch Apple kaufen.
Ja, kann man eben machen. Das haben wir nur so nebenbei. Dann gab es noch ein neues iPhone.
16e.
16e, was sie auch keiner von uns kauft, aber mit einer Verheißung.
Da ist ein neuer Modem-Chip drin, den Apple selber entwickelt hat.
Der C1.
Der C1. Und warum macht uns das alles ganz feucht?
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Weil dann vielleicht auch mal in die Laptops ein Modem-Chip reinkommen könnte.
Ja.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Ich glaube das fest, dass es spätestens nächstes Jahr wird es soweit sein. Das kann einfach...
Weil?
Weil es einfach seit zehn Jahren überfällig ist.
Ja, aber sie hätten es seit zehn Jahren auch mit zugekauften Baseband-Chips machen können.
Ja, aber die Abgaben dafür wären wohl relativ hoch gewesen, weil Qualcomm da
extrem die Hand aufhält. und das könnte ein Grund sein und der andere.
Was Apple bei dem Preis eines Macs sich natürlich nicht leisten kann.
Bei manchen Macs fragt man sich halt schon, ob das nicht möglich wäre,
aber die iPads sind natürlich im Schnitt schon noch günstiger.
Ob das der einzige Grund ist und ob das überhaupt ein Grund ist,
ist eine pure Mutmaßung. Tatsache ist, sie haben es nicht gemacht.
Auf der anderen Seite wäre es
aber mal echt angemessen, weil ich kotze mit diesem Tethering jedes Mal.
Es ist zwar so, dass es eben meistens ganz okay funktioniert,
aber es funktioniert halt auf gar keinen Fall immer.
Also ich sag mal so, wenn die C1,
Struktur, die jetzt ein eigener Chip zu sein scheint, weiß man nicht,
in den nächsten Armchip von Apple reinwandert,
Dann würde ich dir das glauben, weil dann haben sie es sowieso im Prozessor
drin und spricht eigentlich nichts dagegen, dass sie die paar Transistoren da
auch noch mit in den M5 oder wie er dann heißen wird reintun.
Aber ansonsten keine Ahnung. Ich habe immer das Gefühl gehabt,
dass der Fakt, dass Macs keine...
Keine Datenverbindung hatten über WiFi hinaus, dass es eine politische,
produktentscheiderische Entscheidung war und nie eine technische.
Ja, aber ich bitte dich, ich sage jetzt hiermit, ich wäre sogar bereit,
einen Mac zu kaufen mit Notch, wenn da ein Modem drin ist.
Das ist eine andere Diskussion.
Das ist eine Schockwelle, die durch Cupertino geht, nachdem ich diesen Satz gesagt habe.
Du musst, glaube ich, mit dem Fakt leben, dass nur weil du es haben willst,
dass Apple nicht unbedingt bauen wird.
Also so ein Argument, was ich früher immer gelesen habe, war halt,
dass wenn du dir mal so den Datentraffic von so einem Mac anguckst,
was der so in 24 Stunden produziert, so auf deinem ganz normalen Netzwerk hier,
WLAN, dass es halt um ein zigfaches über dem liegt, was irgendwie halt dein
iPhone oder iPad oder sonst was produziert und da dann wieder rum eine Logik
einzubauen, also im Gigabyte-Bereich pro Tag einfach, zig Gigabyte teilweise,
je nachdem, was du noch so an Syncing-Diensten und sowas alles da so fröhlich am Start hast.
Wenn du den ganzen Kram installierst, ja, kein Thema.
Und das für die User so zu parametrisieren, dass du in so einen Datensparsamen-Modus
dann runterschaltest und nicht alle Updates im Hintergrund sofort irgendwie
gezogen werden, dass da Apple irgendwie immer keinen Bock drauf gehabt hätte.
Ja, aber bei Tethering, also klar, einerseits hast du natürlich recht,
die Datensparsamkeit, die in manchen Apps funktioniert,
zu Gesicht stehen würde, ist nicht da. Andererseits, wenn du tetherst,
dann tetherst du halt und fertig.
Also ich finde das iPhone-Tethering, da habe ich andere Erfahrungen als du,
Tim. Ich finde das super.
Der entscheidende Punkt war, als sie es ermöglicht haben, dass du mit deinem
iPhone tethern kannst, auch wenn es im iPhone selber noch deaktiviert ist.
Dass du also diesen Override machen kannst. Und egal, in was für einem State
mein iPhone gerade ist, es taucht immer auf unter WLAN.
Persönlicher Hotspot, das ist ein Klick, es verbindet sich sofort.
Das ist innerhalb von ungefähr anderthalb Sekunden.
Das funktioniert bei dir immer?
Immer. Das funktioniert wirklich immer.
Das funktioniert bei mir auf gar keinen Fall immer.
Also ich benutze es selten, aber wenn ich es benutze, geht es eigentlich.
Ich habe also heute allein...
Das hat jetzt vier Sekunden gedauert.
Nicht anderthalb, aber... Ich saß im Flugzeug und ich musste die ganze Zeit
jetzt war mein iPad verbunden, dann wollte sich der Mac nicht verbinden,
dann taucht es nicht auf, dann verbindet er sich, dann diskonnectet er gleich
wieder, es ging die ganze Zeit hin und her.
Es ist einfach, sorry, aber das ist von stabil sehr, sehr, sehr,
sehr, sehr, sehr weit entfernt.
Aber du saßt in einem Flugzeug.
Das ist doch vollkommen egal. Es geht ja um die Verbindung zwischen dem Macintosh
und dem Telefon. Das lag direkt daneben.
Ja, aber hatte das Telefon denn Verbindung die ganze Zeit zu seinem Netzprovider?
Vollkommen egal. Er war ja noch nicht mal in der Lage mit dem Telefon die Verbindung zu aufbauen.
Das habe ich aber auch schon erlebt, wenn das Telefon tatsächlich das Netz komplett
verliert, geht auch gerne mal das Tethering aus.
Genau, aber das würde ich ja mal sagen, ist ja eher passend Feature.
Im iPad hatte ich ja Netz über das Telefon.
Mit zwei Geräten gleichzeitig kannst du doch gar nicht tethern.
Natürlich.
Nee.
Also gut, wir halten fest.
Roddy, probier doch mal. Du hast doch hier ein iPad unten. Lass doch mal ausprobieren.
Versuch doch mal gleichzeitig dich mit iPad.
Tim will den C1 im Mac haben. Ich glaube nicht, dass es passieren wird.
Ich will den C3 im Mac haben.
Welchen auch immer. Ich glaube nicht, dass es passieren wird,
weil es halt einfach eine Produktentscheidung ist und keine technische.
Das ist meine Einschätzung. der Sachlage, ich mag falsch liegen.
Und schön für dich, wenn ich falsch liege.
Ja. Ja, das wird kommen.
Okay.
Die Frage ist, ob die Laptops dann noch einen Notch haben oder nicht.
Das ist die eigentliche Frage.
Naja, vielleicht haben sie dann auch eine Dynamic Island oder sowas.
Aber sie werden sicherlich nicht die Kamera rausschmeißen, nur damit da mehr Platz ist.
Müssen sie ja nicht. Wir machen einfach einen Rahmen. Geht ja hier bei meinem
alten MacBook Air geht es ja auch.
Bei allen MacBooks schon immer. Also ich fand das einfach das,
sorry, aber wirklich Ja.
Die Diskussion, die brauchen wir jetzt glaube ich nicht nochmal zu führen.
Wo ist euer ästhetisches Empfinden? Das geht einfach nicht.
So ein Cutout da oben in die Menüzeile reinbauen und dann ist Text,
der dann unter der Kamera ist, den man nicht sieht.
Den habe ich jetzt selten? Den Text unter der Kamera?
Das heißt, es findet statt.
Verkehrsunfall habe ich selten. Das kann man schon mal hinnehmen.
Ich glaube eher, dass der Notch oder die Dynamic Island ins iPad wandert.
Als dass sie den Notch beim Mac wieder wegmachen.
Mark my words. Weil größeres Display.
Es sind relativ viele Leute da
draußen, die es nicht stört, aber größeres Display finden sie alle geiler.
Und mit dünnerem Rand, weil dann...
Ach, die Pixel, ey. Sorry, nee, also...
So, Nachtrag, ihr habt natürlich alle recht, weil ich im Auto mit meinem einen
iPhone die beiden iPads meiner Racker bespiele, von den Daten her.
Und das geht nur wenn ein iPhone mehrere Geräte Ja.
Natürlich macht das mehrere Geräte und das hat ja auch funktioniert,
aber es funktioniert dann halt auch mal nicht.
Es schaltet sich dann einfach ab und dann Error und kann nicht verbinden und
allein dieser Vorgang dauert mir einfach schon zu lange Der Computer ist doch
klug genug, der kann ja selber irgendwie das machen und einen Datensparsamkeitsmodus
kann man da auch einbauen.
Man kann auch ein Kontrollpanel machen und sagen, dieses Programm darf da nicht
drauf schreiben und dann ist es wohl im Karton.
Du hast recht, aber Apple wird das erst machen, wenn sie den Datensparsamkeitsmodus
haben im Mac, im macOS und da es den bisher nicht gibt, na gut, im Juni.
Gibt es den nicht, bist du da sicher? Ich meine, ich hätte doch auch.
Nicht so wie jetzt unter iOS.
Aber unter iOS gibt es ihn.
Ja, unter iOS gibt es ihn.
Whatever. Also ich glaube es nicht.
Datensparen ist sowieso Quatsch. Wir wollen keine Daten sparen.
Ich will Internet haben. Ich will irgendwie nicht sparen. Ich will verbrauchen.
Ja, du bist halt nicht der Typ Schenken-Benutzer.
Die Gigabytes müssen weg. Das liegt einfach nur daran, weil die Amerikaner noch
beklopptere Mobilfunktarife haben als Deutschland.
Das könnte man jetzt anprangern, auf der anderen Seite ist halt Amerika, was soll's.
Das kann man anprangern, ja, das sollte man vielleicht auch mal anprangern.
Naja gut, aber das ist natürlich jetzt auch billig, sich auf die USA einzuhauen.
Die können ja nur wirklich nichts dafür.
Momentan ist das sehr, sehr billig, der Umtauschkurs ist nicht gut.
So, kurzer Nachtrag, oder was heißt Nachtrag? Kurzer Hinweis,
weil ich auch darauf angesprochen wurde, weil ich ja so ein Money Money Freund
bin und bei Money Money ist was passiert.
Das äußerte sich erstmal darin, dass sie ein neues Logo irgendwie auf der Webseite
hatten und das auch irgendwie im Programm anzeigen.
Komischerweise nicht als Programm-Icon, eigentlich nicht so ganz verstanden,
aber egal. und dann wurde bekannt, dass irgendwie Money Money neue Mitgesellschafter gefunden hat.
Money Money ist ja die beste Homebanking-App aller Zeiten und man hat sich schon
immer gewundert, wie das eine Person schaffen kann, diesen Aufwand zu leisten.
Ja, also der Michael, der das macht, der macht das ja seit ewigen Zeiten alleine
und der treibt da einen Aufwand, der ist irre.
Ja, bei jedem Update die Liste von bei der Bank habe ich das geändert und bei
der Bank habe ich das gefixt und bei der Bank ist das jetzt dazugekommen.
Ich war da immer beeindruckt, ja.
Genau und nebenbei, was man auch so nicht so direkt sieht, ist er ja quasi auch
vollwertiges Mitglied dieser ganzen PSD-Geschichte.
Also diese ganze EU-Gesetzgebung für Banking-Interoperationen,
wenn man daran, also das ist sozusagen das, was ihn in die Lage versetzt,
alle Konten zu befragen, auch die, die kein API an Kunden anbieten.
Wenn du da diese Subscription eingehst von ein paar Euro im Jahr,
dann kriegst du ja quasi automatisch Zugriff auf dieses ganze PSD2-Modul und
damit kannst du Kontostände definitiv aller Konten, weil das müssen die anbieten,
aber nur als Business to Business. ist.
Und um da mitspielen zu können, musst du quasi dich lizenzieren lassen und musst
jährlich irgendwie horrende Summen an Geld zahlen, nur um diesen Status zu haben.
Plus, du musst irgendwie einen Irrsinn an APIs und Interfaces und so weiter
implementieren, serverseitig, um in diesem Spiel mitzumachen.
Um diese ganze Infrastruktur zu bauen und diesen ganzen rechtlichen Hickhack
und die Gelder zu machen, das steckt sozusagen alles in dieser kleinen,
optionalen Subscription-Feed, die in Money Money mit drin ist.
Und das macht dieser Mail alles alleine. Und jetzt ist ihm das irgendwie zu
viel geworden. Jetzt hat er sich ein paar Gesellschaft damit reingeholt.
Und das soll sozusagen die Weiterentwicklung sichern.
Ich erwähne das jetzt, weil viele so im Netz gleich wieder so,
Leute sind eingestiegen, jetzt wird das Produkt kaputt und so weiter.
Die Angst ist nicht unberechtigt, finde ich.
Wenn man sich die Firma dahinter anguckt.
Ne, auch wenn man sich anguckt, was üblicherweise passiert, wenn jemand und so weiter.
Ja gut, aber die Alternative wäre gewesen, dass er es gleich einstellen muss.
Ich sage ja nicht, dass er der allgemeine Fall ist.
Ich sage nur, die Befürchtung, wenn man nicht genau hinguckt,
ist schon, kann man halt auch schon schnell haben, dass, oh,
jetzt geht es dem Bach runter.
Ja, man kann aber auch sagen so, ah, super, jetzt gibt es irgendwie Unterstützung
und ich glaube, auf dem Level läuft das.
Ja, ich bin da so im Camp, schauen wir mal, dann sehen wir schon.
Genau. So, dann wurde noch darauf hingewiesen, dass Max ja wieder mit allem recht hatte.
Ja, ich glaube es wurde mehr so als Frage zitiert, als Frage gestellt.
Naja, also Apple hat quasi selbst bestätigt, dass Max Reiter.
Also Apple hat bestätigt, dass sie den Vollausbau von Apple Intelligence so nicht hinkriegen.
Nicht mehr dieses Jahr zumindest.
Genau. Ich habe damit recht behalten, dass sie den ganzen Krempel wie diese
ganzen Grafiken und so, das werden sie halt dann einfach machen.
Und der Rest steht so ein bisschen in den Sternen.
Die Sterne sind jetzt weit weg. Also ein Jahr.
Elon Time, wie auch immer.
Ja, ist so ein bisschen schade, dass sie da was versprochen haben,
was sie dann tatsächlich nicht halten können.
Und dass sie mit dem Versprechen aber tatsächlich auch als Werbebotschaft dann Hardware verkaufen.
Ja, also Apple hat sich da ganz schön in die Scheiße geritten,
muss man sagen, weil sie ja auch schon dicke, fette Werbetrailer geschaltet haben,
wo sie ja diese ganze Ankündigung mit ja hier Zugriff auf deine persönlichen
Daten on your device und dann kontextsensitive Antworten mit Siri und so und
davon ist ja nichts zu sehen.
Jetzt kriegen sie auch schon die üblichen Class-Action-Suits.
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch ganz angemessen, weil dieses Sachen anprangern.
Eigentlich, also worum es ja geht, ist ja das, was sie als Apple Intelligence vorgestellt haben.
Jetzt ist es ja schon so, dass sie da bestimmte Dinge auch haben,
nämlich dieser etwas useless Image Generator und Emoji bauen und so.
Ich benutze das nicht, aber.
Mail, Kategorisierung, die funktioniert bei mir ganz gut. Die habe ich noch
gemerkt drauf. Die habe ich gleich abgeschaltet.
Das will ich überhaupt gar nicht sehen, sowas.
Und halt irgendwie Text umschreibe, Viech.
Und Summarizer von so Nachrichten in Notifications.
Alles ganz nett, aber auch irgendwie keine große Schlagzeile wert.
Für mich läuft das alles noch so ein bisschen nebenbei. Womit aber eigentlich
alle gerechnet haben, dass sie das ja nun bringen, ist, dass sie eben mal Siri
auf so ein bisschen auf LLM-Standard bringen und dass das Ding halt mal irgendwas versteht.
Dann gab es jetzt wieder so ein paar Aufreger, dass Siri derzeit noch nicht
mal in der Lage ist, zu sagen, was der aktuelle Monat ist und so weiter.
Ich benutze ja Siri eigentlich ich nie, ich habe das nie benutzt,
weil ich das einfach schon immer ein bisschen absurd fand, mich mit meinem Computer
so zu unterhalten, zumindest so.
Ich benutze Siri sehr viel, um Timer für die Uhr zu stellen.
Ja, das ist aber alles, was alle immer sagen, dass sie damit Timer stellen.
Und Licht an- und ausmachen über HomeKit.
Ja.
Das hat bei mir schon nicht besonders zuverlässig funktioniert.
Das wurde irgendwann besser vor einem Vierteljahr.
Das wird bestimmt auch mal wieder schlechter.
Ja, das stimmt.
Also nichts ist halt machbar. Und ich meine,
ich denke schon, dass sie irgendeine Technologie am Start hatten,
von der sie gedacht haben,
oder zumindest manche gedacht haben, dass sie die binnen eines Jahres im Rahmen
dieses Release Cycles einschalten können und dann passt das schon.
Die existiert unter Garantie.
Aber ich fand das sehr schön bei ATP hat der Siracusa das ganz gut auseinander
genommen, wie ich fand, dass er meinte,
Es kann halt gut sein, dass es sich hierbei einfach mal um ein Problem handelt,
was es so bisher nicht gab.
Weil üblicherweise, wenn sie irgendwas angekündigt haben, was verspätet war
und es sich dabei um Software handelte, kam dieses Feature dann doch.
Weil sie dann einfach ganz viele Leute rangesetzt haben und die Patcher ausgepackt
haben und irgendwann kodest du dich halt dann wund aber dann ist es dann halt
auch da und dann hat es noch ein paar Bugs,
und dann läuft der Hase genau dann fängst du zwei.
Haare Bugs genau.
Aber das ist irgendwie ein definiertes Ziel und es muss nur zu Ende gebracht
werden und so bei diesem ganzen,
das haben wir ja in den letzten zwei Stunden auch schon sehr schön beschrieben,
wie schwierig es ist, denen so das richtige Verhalten beizubringen,
sie davon abzuhalten, irgendeinen Unsinn zu machen und einmal zu Hitler zu werden und so weiter.
Das steckt halt einfach inhärent in dieser Technologie mit drin und keiner kann
halt sagen, warum das Ding jetzt gerade mal das tut oder das.
Das ist einfach eine per se nicht vorhersehbare Technik und ich glaube,
Apple scheitert vielleicht sogar an ihren eigenen,
Mindestanforderungen, was so
Decency und Korrektheit und irgendwie Apple-like und so weiter betrifft.
Dass sie einfach zwar eine Serie haben, mit der du dich schon unterhalten kannst,
aber dass sie halt irgendwie zu schnell auf Abwege kommen. Frech wird.
Naja, den ersten Chatbot, den Microsoft ins Netz gestellt hat,
der wurde weiß ich nicht mehr.
Der wurde doch innerhalb von einem Tag zum White Supremacist.
Also das ist ja irgendwie, als Apple willst so das nun wirklich gar nicht.
Genau. Und ich glaube, das kann gut sein, dass das eben an so etwas hängt.
Aber trotzdem muss man sagen, dieser Move, das Apple Intelligence zu nennen,
Da habe ich mir ehrlich gesagt gedacht, wenn sie das machen,
dann werden sie sich schon sicher sein bei manchen Sachen, dass das gut funktioniert.
Und ich bin mir mittlerweile nicht mehr so sicher, ob man sich da so sicher sein kann.
Du meinst, der Move des Apple Intelligence zu nennen war auch nur so ein mittlerer?
Also Apple Intelligence ist ja nur so ein Umbrella-Begriff gewesen.
Ja, ja, klar.
Also das war ja eben nicht so das eine Feature, sondern es war ein ganzes Set von Features.
Für so ein Wunderstrauß von Einzelfeatures.
Aber damit haben sie ihren Namen in die Waagschale geworfen.
Da haben sie gesagt, Intelligenz und Apple, das geht irgendwie zusammen.
Und derzeit sieht es eher so aus mit ja, nee.
Und was ich ja damals schon vor einem Jahr gesagt hatte, was doch erstmal ein
total sinnvoller erster Schritt gewesen wäre, wäre zu sagen,
so die alte Siri, die bleibt so wie sie ist.
Man betrachtet sie als MCP, um mal gleich in der Technologie zu bleiben,
die wir eben hatten, und schnallt halt einfach nur ein LLM davor,
was die viel besser steuern können, als wir, die wir nicht verstehen,
was die richtigen Codewörter sind, um eine klassische Siri zu bedienen.
So, da bin ich nach wie vor der Meinung, da hätte man mit überschaubarem Aufwand
die Apple-Welt schon richtig viel besser machen können.
So, das wollten sie aber nicht, sondern sie wollten dann ja sofort so Full Monty
und wann landet meine Mutter und wann muss ich losfahren, damit ich zeitlich
beim Flughafen bin, so diese Geschichten.
Das kann die klassische Siri jetzt auch einfach mal überhaupt gar nicht.
Ja, das kann aber auch irgendeine andere Maschine wahrscheinlich nicht.
Eben, das kann derzeit glaube ich auch überhaupt gar keine LLM.
Und das ist exakt das, was jetzt auch Tim gerade eben gesagt hat,
du kannst so eine LLM halt nicht debuggen.
So, geht nicht. So, du kannst am Prompt rumtunen, du kannst eine zweite LLM
oder eine dritte oder vierte drüber setzen, die versucht das zu kontrollieren
und einzuhegen und die Ergebnisse zu interpretieren.
Wir mit sicher sowas probieren sie auch gerade, um da irgendwie rauszukommen.
Aber du kannst sie nicht debuggen und es hilft nichts, wenn du jetzt 50 Informatiker
draufsetzt und noch 60 Informatikerinnen.
Damit kriegst du nicht bessere Prompts hin, als die, die du wahrscheinlich sowieso schon vorher hast.
Dafür ist diese Technologie einfach nicht gerechnet. Und das,
man muss es sagen, hat Max von einem Jahr exakt so gesagt.
Und ich habe ihm da auch schon recht gegeben, nebenbei bemerkt.
So, dafür ist eine LLM für diese Art von komplexen Sachen, es wird in 80% der Fälle funktionieren.
80 ist aber nicht genug.
Und 80 ist dafür aber nicht genug und schon gar nicht für Apple genug.
Und wenn du bei 20% dann zum falschen Flughafen geleitet wirst und deine Oma
steht da und kippt um, weil sie einen Herzanfall hat, dann hast du Tote auf der Straße.
Ja, oder die LLM-halluzinierten Flughafen hin, den es gar nicht gibt und dann
stehst du in der Pampa an der Tanke und wirst überfallen.
Genau, es gibt dann Tote es gibt dann Tote durch Siri und dann ist die,
Meldung eben nicht mehr, oh wir haben mit der Apple Watch 50 Leute vor dem Herzinfarkt
gerettet sondern so, Siri hat Menschen umgebracht, so irgendwann würde es passieren
so und dass da Apple keinen Bock drauf hat, kann ich schon verstehen aber technologisch
hätte man das vor einem Jahr sehen können, so und es haben Leute gesehen,
nachweislich, hört euch die Sendung an,
Tja, und wie kommen sie jetzt da raus? Also ich glaube auch gar nicht.
Mit der derzeit bekannten Technologie ist es, glaube ich, nicht zu lösen.
Ja, es ist vor allem die Frage, haben sie eigentlich irgendwas zu bieten,
was man wirklich braucht?
Also so Text-Summarizing, Notifikationen zusammenfassen, habe ich jetzt noch
nicht so viel Erfahrung mit.
Das ist ja jetzt erst seit dem 18.4 irgendwie drin.
Ich würde ja lieber die anderen Sachen sehen, aber das will ja die EU nicht.
Hier so iPhone-Synchronisierung und sowas.
Zumindest behauptet Apple, dass die EU das nicht will. So richtig begründet haben sie es nicht.
Also in Vietnam, als ich die Beta laufen hatte, hatte ich das Feature auf einmal.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das daran lag, dass ich in Vietnam war oder dass es die Beta war.
Aber da konnte ich mit dieser iPhone-Synchronisierung rumsch...
Keine Ahnung. Apple behauptet in Europa... Also sie sagen ja nur in Europa geht
das nicht. Gibt es das nicht. Bieten wir es nicht an. Warum auch immer.
Sie begründen es ja nicht größer.
Naja gut, Sie sagen es nicht explizit, aber Sie haben ja durch die Blume schon gesagt, warum.
Ja, warum?
Durch die neue DMA-Gesetzgebung in Europa, die halt Apple mit seinen Plattformen
in die Kategorie, ihr müsst alles, was ihr machen,
was ihr mit euren eigenen Sachen macht, müsst ihr jetzt mit allen anderen teilen und zwar von Tag 1.
Und damit bitte nicht schon wieder anfangen, das hatten wir schon so oft.
Ja, aber das ist der Grund.
Das heißt, sie müssten es eigentlich auch Windows erlauben und sie müssten es
eigentlich auch für Android machen.
Na, sie müssten halt von vornherein für jedes ihrer eigenen Integration,
für ihre Vertical Integration und macOS ist nun mal ein Vertical Integration
oder das Apple-Ecosystem lebt von Vertical Integration,
werden sie quasi per Gesetz zu einer Horizontal Integration gezwungen.
Alles, weil sie ihre eigenen Produkte gut unterstützen, wo ich einfach mit der
Logik nicht hinterherkomme, wo jetzt da eigentlich das Problem ist.
Und jetzt sagen sie halt so, naja, bevor wir jetzt anfangen,
APIs auch noch zu bauen und zu pflegen, damit andere Wettbewerber in unser eigenes
Betriebssystem reingehen können, sperren wir den Scheiß einfach in Europa.
Finde ich sogar ein Stück weit nachvollziehbar, auch wenn es sehr ärgerlich ist.
Egal, ich wollte über was anderes nochmal reden und zwar über meine jüngste,
Anschaffung eines Apple-Geräts.
Anschaffung.
Ja, eine Anschaffung. Ich habe das nämlich gekauft.
Er hat es getan. Tim, du hast es getan.
Du hast es übernommen.
Ich habe es getan. Und zwar habe ich das Headset von Dom gekauft.
Ich habe gedacht, was letzte Preis?
Wir reden von einer Apple Vision Pro.
Wir reden von einer Apple Vision Pro, die wir hier alle mal rumgereicht hatten.
Und ich war dann so kurz vor meiner Reise, kurz vor Reiseantritt im Januar, und dachte mir so,
programmieren, Cursor, irgendwie große Bildschirme, geil, aber ich unterwegs
und da gibt es ja keine großen Bildschirme.
Da war ich dann schon so ein bisschen am grübeln und ja, dann habe ich das Ding
einfach mal mitgenommen und geguckt, ob es denn was taugt und was es denn taugt
und ob ich denn dafür eine Anwendung habe.
Beziehungsweise ich hatte den Eindruck, ich hätte jetzt vielleicht eine Anwendung durch,
Du wirst mir ja zustimmen, große Bildschirme und programmieren.
Das geht ganz gut zusammen.
Ich benutze das erst, wenn auch der Bildschirm auf der Vision Pro eine Notch hat.
Gibt es bestimmt schon eine App dafür, oder?
Keine Ahnung. Nein, das ist natürlich
Quatsch. Ja, nein, aber eine gewisse Mindestgröße willst du schonen.
Es ist ein bisschen lustig, weil wenn man das gewohnt ist, auf einem großen
Bildschirm zu programmieren und ist dann auf einem kleinen unterwegs,
fühlt man sich immer so ein bisschen wie so der U-Boot-Kapitän,
der durchs Periskop schaut.
Also es ist so dieses Gefühl, kann ich mal an Deck gehen und richtig gucken?
Ja, genau.
Und deswegen war ich schon so ein bisschen am Überlegen.
Und dann habe ich, das hatte ich ja auch schon berichtet,
kurz bevor ich losgefahren bin, habe ich mir dann auch nochmal so einen Add-on
Kopfbügel dazu gemacht,
damit man also nicht so wie Apple das normalerweise verkauft,
das Ding befestigt, sondern quasi an der Stirn nochmal so einen zusätzlichen
Bogen hat, auf dem man mehr Last abwerfen kann.
Das funktioniert auch ganz okay so.
Ist alles immer noch nicht perfekt und steht natürlich vollkommen außer Frage,
dass jetzt man sich diese Hardware in sehr viel leichter wünscht.
Also das Gewicht ist schon spürbar, aber man kriegt es mitigiert.
Ich hatte dann so ein bisschen Passformprobleme und das lag,
wie sich herausgestellt hat, an diesem Light Shield.
Also dieses Ding, das misst man ja mit einer iPhone-Kamera, mit dem 3D-Sensor,
mit dem LIDA-Scanner quasi vorher ein, wenn man sich das Ding bestellt.
Ja, oder man geht in den Apple Store und da machen sie es für einen.
Ja, aber da machen sie es auch mit der Apple.
Ja, ja, da machen sie es.
Und dann kriegst du halt die Größe vorgeschlagen und ich habe heute gecheckt,
was mir das Telefon vorschlägt. Also das kannst du ja einfach durch einen Bestellvorgang
auch auf der Webseite initiieren.
Und es war halt eine andere Größe als die, die dran ist. Also wer das nicht
kennt, die eigentliche Brille ist ja...
Einfach nur so ein Stück,
Aluminiumglas mit Elektronik drin, was man sich so vor die Augen hält,
wo die ganze Optik drin ist.
Und mit Linsen und einem Gedöns.
Genau, und dann kommen noch die Linsen noch mit dazu.
Achso, dann gibt es noch die Einlegelinsen, die kommen ja auch noch.
Dann gibt es noch diese Einlegelinsen dazu und ich habe mir halt diese Einlegelinsen,
die habe ich mir halt gekauft,
für Lesebrille 2 Plus, also sozusagen das Maximum.
Und habe die eingesetzt, weil ich wollte ja, ich hatte ja immer so ein bisschen
gerätselt, ob denn das mir so scharf genug ist.
Das war so einer meiner, beim Testen immer so eine Sache, wo ich mir nicht so
richtig sicher war, ob ich das jetzt noch schärfer hinkriegen müsste oder ob
es eigentlich schon scharf genug ist und so weiter.
Viele Rätsel stellten sich da von mir auf und das andere war natürlich diese reine Passform.
Das heißt, dieses Light Shield, also das Ding, was man so magnetisch an die
eigentliche Brille ranklippt und die dann sozusagen dafür sorgt, dass um den Kopf herum,
also um die Augenpartie herum, man kein Licht von außen reinbekommt.
Und die dann zusätzlich nochmal so ein auswechselbares, auch magnetisch herangeschnapptes
Kuscheladapterchen auch noch dran hat.
Also nochmal sozusagen ein extra Polster, was man noch auf die Kante macht,
da wo man eben dann wirklich das Ding an die Haut ansetzt.
Und wenn du das halt in einer anderen Größe kaufen willst, dann musst du bei
Apple welchen Betrag bezahlen?
Für dieses Stück Plastik willst du es nochmal in die Hand nehmen?
Ich glaube 120 war das noch.
Nimm es mal in die Hand. Es handelt sich dabei um Plastik mit ein bisschen Bespannungs-HomePod-Stoff
und so ein bisschen Plastik und an der Nase so ein kleines Stöffchen.
Es erinnert sehr an so Auto-Dashboard bei edleren Marken, die total gut aussehen,
bis man näher hinguckt und merkt, okay, die haben halt irgendeinen Stoff auf
ein Stück Plastik draufgeklebt.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist es so edel.
Ich kenne das, aber hast du es einfach mal ganz ohne probiert?
Das ist ja das, was ich in der vorletzten Sendung habe.
Nee, aber ich meine, also die entsprechende Apple-Tags wird da schon notwendig gewesen sein.
200 Euro.
Selbstschuld.
100 Euro.
Ich sag doch Apple-Tags. Das ist doch für ein Gerät, das 4000 Euro kostet, ein Schnapper.
Das ist der frechste Preis, den sie je auf irgendein Produkt draufgesetzt haben.
Und ich war entsetzt und entrüstet und ich habe es natürlich gekauft.
Weil...
Ich wollte all in gehen. Ich wollte es jetzt einfach mal wissen und mir war
das andere Ding einfach zu eng und ich habe einfach Augen zu und durch und habe
gesagt, das mache ich jetzt einfach für euch alle.
Das ist schön von dir.
Ja, plus diese Lasereinsätze, die halt irgendwie viel wertiger sind,
aber die Brilleneinsätze. Nicht so teuer wie das Stück Plastik.
Naja, also Strafgebühr auf Strafgebühr auf Strafgebühr. Aber ich wollte halt
auch zweieinhalb Monate unterwegs sein und ich brauchte einen großen Bildschirm
und ich wollte es jetzt irgendwie wissen.
So, und jetzt habe ich das Ding hier schon gebraucht bekommen.
Ja, und dann habe ich es ausprobiert.
Und ich war ja sehr skeptisch, was diese Brille betrifft. Aber ich muss sagen,
ich bin ein bisschen angetan davon.
Und das Gewicht, gibt es da jetzt noch so ein Helium-Adapter-Kit,
das einem die Brille hochzieht?
Also ich habe wirklich an manchen Tagen das Ding sechs, sieben Stunden lang getragen.
Aber dann mit Tastatur und Trackpad gekoppelt.
Genau, also als großer Bildschirm für das Laptop.
Das MacBook Air M1 vollkommen ausgereicht, habe diesen Mac-Sharing,
wie heißt es, Virtual Desktop-Modus gemacht, den kannst du dir in so drei verschiedenen,
Bildschirm Aspekt-Ratios zusammenklicken.
Also du hast halt nur einen Bildschirm und entweder hast du ihn in so einem
normalen Monitor-Ratio oder Whitescreen oder so Ultra-Whitescreen.
Welches hast du da genommen?
Ich habe den mittleren genommen. Es ist auch so, man muss sehen, du kannst,
du hast ja, du wählst damit eigentlich ja nur den Aspektratio,
aber wie viel Pixel du da jetzt wirklich drin hast, also wie klein oder wie
groß das ist, das kannst du ja ganz normal dann, weil das ja wie ein Monitor ist,
einfach über das Display-Setting auch nochmal auswählen.
So, und was waren so meine generellen Bedenken? Meine Bedenken waren,
es ist so ein bisschen unscharf alles.
Und es war für mich immer schwer einzuschätzen, inwiefern jetzt diese Lesebrillenproblematik,
also quasi die Degradation meiner Augen selber da schon eine Rolle spielen und
womit ich das am besten austesten kann.
Dann habe ich mich halt für diese Leseeinsätze entschieden das hat schon auch geholfen,
und das andere ist ja dieses Foveated Rendering das heißt du schaust irgendwo
hin und dann wird es erst in dem Moment scharf wo du hinschaust und das ist
ja so ein merklicher Vorgang und der ist natürlich wenn man das das erste Mal
testet ist der irgendwie doof,
nur ja es ist immer so schön man gewöhnt sich dran es ist nicht so schlimm,
Weil man schaut nicht die ganze Zeit, wie beim Austesten, die ganze Zeit von
da nach da nach da nach da, sondern du schaust halt auf deinen Bildschirm,
schaust auf deinen Code, der ist scharf, la la la, schaust woanders hin.
Und klar, da ist so dieser Delay mit drin, aber es ist so, okay, ist so.
Aber es ist nicht, es bringt mich jetzt nicht um, es stört nicht,
es ist nicht so, dass es dauerhaft unscharf wäre, es ist halt nur für diesen
ganz kurzen Moment unscharf.
Mir ist das ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so richtig aufgefallen,
aber es liegt vielleicht daran, dass man, wenn man wirklich immer eine Brille trägt,
dass man gewohnt ist, den Kopf mehr zu drehen, um da, wo man hinzugucken,
dann halt auch die Brille nicht im Weg ist.
Ja.
Also ich glaube, wenn du sonst keine Brille trägst, bist du eher gewohnt,
den Kopf ruhig zu halten und dann mal mit den Augen so.
Deswegen, also mir ist das Forviated Rendering nur selten wirklich aufgefallen. Das ist so.
Genau, also das waren so erstmal die Rahmenbedingungen und dann war für mich
halt wirklich die Frage, okay, bringt mir das jetzt irgendwas?
Ändert das irgendwas im Vergleich zu, ich habe das Ding nicht auf und ich schaue
schon auf meinen Bildschirmen?
Und das Offensichtliche ist natürlich, großer Bildschirm, viel Platz,
riesige Textfenster, hier läuft der Chat, da ist noch eine Doku offen,
hier hast du noch einen Webbrowser und dann kann ich auch noch da drüber und
links und rechts drumherum, kann ja auch noch meine ganzen Vision Pro Sachen
machen, kann da irgendwie ein Video laufen lassen und es geht irgendwie alles gleichzeitig.
Das war so das Einzige, wo ich das Gefühl hatte,
das gesamte Rendering vom Mac, seit es Mac OS X hieß,
ist ja eigentlich mit Hardware-Grafik-Unterstützung und das sind Layer,
die du beliebig verschieben kannst und der Inhalt von allen Fenstern ist immer komplett vorhanden.
Warum boxt man das, was auf dem Mac passiert, in so ein Viereck rein und ist
nicht in der Lage, die Mac-Fans da auch überall hinzuschieben, wo man sie haben will?
Für mich war das komplett unlogisch.
Mhm.
Gut, kommt vielleicht noch mit irgendwelchen Updates, aber das ist so das,
wo ich halt so gerne, ja, ist schön, dass du jetzt so eine riesige Wand hast,
wo Dinge drin passieren,
aber eigentlich will ich ja nicht die Wand, sondern ich wäre ja in der Lage
sein, den Chat da drüben und das hier hin und das hier hin und mich in der Mitte
dann darauf zu konzentrieren.
Naja, im Prinzip kannst du ja deine Fenster überall hinlegen,
aber nur halt innerhalb eines beschränkten Bereichs.
Der ist auch bei der Vision Pro beschränkt, nur dass er eben auf dein komplettes
Sichtfeld beschränkt ist, also auf deine ganze Wohnung.
Naja, du hast so 5K oder so hast du und dann ist Schluss.
Nö, du kannst es ja auch irgendwo hinhängen, wo du es gerade nicht siehst.
Ja, aber du kannst nur den Modi vor quasi hinlegen. Aber du hast ja den gesamten
Mac-Inhalt immer in einem Fenster drin.
Jaja, klar.
Und das ist ja, was ich meine.
Ja, ich weiß. Genau und man bricht sich manchmal auch so ein bisschen den Kopf,
weil man dann doch immer so hin und her schalten muss.
Ja, dann fängst du an irgendwie mit den Fingern, versuchst du irgendwelche Fenster
auf deinem Mac nach vorne zu bringen,
was natürlich nicht geht so und es wird besser dadurch, dass du zumindest über
die Tastatur und über das Trackpad auf einmal alle Apps, also auch die Apple
Vision Pro Apps, hatte ich ja schon mal berichtet hier,
Universal Control und so weiter steuern kannst.
Das macht manchmal die Sache noch ein bisschen einfacher.
Aber ich würde mal sagen, die Kernerkenntnis war, großer Bildschirm,
geil, dass man das auf Reisen dabei haben kann, ist einfach der Brüller.
Also das war einfach irre. Und was ich dann aber auch noch gemerkt habe ist,
dass mir insbesondere mit diesen zuschaltbaren Environments,
aber auch schon generell durch dieses,
wenn auch so ein bisschen einschränkendes, dieser Lichtschutz und dieser eingeschränkte,
dieser Tunnelblick, den man dann sozusagen hat.
Und irgendwie ist man sofort woanders.
Also ich hatte bestimmte Konzentrationsprobleme, die ich sonst hatte, auf einmal nicht mehr.
Ich war total abgetaucht in diesem Teil,
gerade mit dem Environment, dann hast du vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen Musik laufen,
das ist aber jetzt nicht so wichtig, das ging auch ohne und einfach auf einmal
war ich auf eine Art und Weise fokussiert auf meine Arbeit, die sonst so für
mich nicht so ohne weiteres herstellbar war.
Das war jetzt eine sehr persönliche Sache, aber es hat mir definitiv geholfen
dabei und ich habe mich manchmal stundenlang da rein vertieft und dann irgendwann
gemerkt, so was ist wie drei Uhr nachts irgendwie, was erlaube.
Ich verstehe, was du meinst, weil ich habe ja auch ein bisschen rumgespielt
und das ist schon so, man ist drin oder man ist nicht drin, so wie früher das
Internet, man ist drin oder man ist nicht drin.
Genau, ich bin drin oder was.
Und ich konnte es dann auch gar nicht irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, weglegen. Trotzdem...
Die Augen, man vermutete ja auch so ein bisschen so Eye Strain,
dass so die Augen ein bisschen überfordert sind. Das eigentlich nicht.
Es ist eher das Tragen. Also es ist wirklich das physikalische Gewicht.
Relativiert sich so ein bisschen, wenn man jetzt die zweite Killer-App ist halt,
ganz einfach Filme gucken.
Also halt wirklich zum Filme gucken ist es einfach super.
Vor allem, wenn man sich dann einfach aufs Bett legt, schön irgendwie auf Kissen.
Dann guckst du einfach nach oben, dann hast du auch schon mal viel von dieser Last gar nicht.
Ja, also die Produktivität beim Programmieren.
Podcast schneiden geht auch sehr gut.
Ich saß so auf dem Balkon irgendwie bei 30 Grad, hab das Ding auf und hatte
einen riesen Bildschirm mit meinem Audio und konnte Probleme machen.
Und da muss ich auch sagen, ich bin unfassbar beeindruckt von der niedrigen
Latenz, die du hast, obwohl das alles über WiFi geht.
Du hast so einen riesigen Bildschirm mit 10.000 Pixeln und du hast zu keinem
Zeitpunkt das Gefühl, dass das irgendwie nicht direkte Manipulation wäre.
Dass deine Maus laggt oder dass ein Klick nicht da ist oder irgendwas ist es.
Das haben sie wirklich unheimlich gut hinbekommen. Ehrlich gesagt,
mir ist das ein Rätsel, wie gut sie das hinbekommen haben.
Sie haben wegen dem ganz großen Bildschirm ja auch erst nach dem Update drin gehabt.
Trotzdem, wenn man sich anguckt, was für ein Latenzgeruckel das ist,
immer, wenn es auf einen Apple TV projiziert wird, wo du gefühlt so eine halbe
Sekunde Latenz auf alles irgendwie drin hast.
Scheußlich. Wo da jetzt eigentlich der große Unterschied ist,
die Auflösung ist nicht kleiner bei einem 4K.
Apple TV ist ja auch schon einiges an Pixeln, was da geschoben wird, aber trotzdem.
Es hängt bei mir ja sogar irgendwie im LAN dran.
Ja, mein Apple TV hat nicht den Prozessor, den du dafür brauchst.
Ja.
Ja, also was auch immer sie getan haben, es ist ihnen gelungen.
Das hatte ich auch schon mal gesagt,
bei der Apple Vision Pro gibt es noch viele Dinge, die man verbessern kann,
in der Hardware und auch in der Software, aber es ist ihnen zumindest gelungen,
ein paar von den wirklich wichtigen Sachen, die gut sein müssen, sind auch wirklich gut.
Das Headtracking ist einfach ultra
gut. Es ist einfach, die Fenster stehen wirklich wie festgenagelt da.
Und was auch ganz gut funktioniert, aber was ich an seine Grenzen gebracht habe,
ist dieser Travel-Modus.
Weil ich habe natürlich jetzt auf meinem Rückflug auch nochmal das Ding massiv
eingesetzt. Ich habe vor allem jede Scham verloren.
Ich habe in den letzten Wochen das Teil in Cafés getragen. Ich habe das im Flugzeug sofort aufgesetzt.
Gibt es eigentlich auch wo ein Blog so, Tim Waring ist. Ein bisschen pro in Thailand.
Ein Tumblr.
Wir haben ihn verfolgt.
Ja, weil irgendwie mir war das dann alles egal und ehrlich gesagt,
ich wollte auch so ein bisschen mal gucken, wie so die Reaktion ist.
Ich wollte einfach mal so wissen, okay, wie ist denn das hier mit meiner sozialen
Integration? Hat das noch irgendwelche Chancen?
Wenn ich das Ding aufhabe, lief auch sonst nicht so gut. Von daher war es dann auch egal.
Und ich habe das einfach mal ausprobiert und habe es einfach mal drauf ankommen
lassen. Aber im Flugzeug war es wirklich interessant.
Ich hatte,
eigentlich erstmal keine Probleme. Das hat also wirklich ganz gut funktioniert.
Du kannst also sagen, okay, ich bin jetzt hier im Flugzeug. Er merkt das auch
mittlerweile automatisch.
Also der merkt schon, wenn du im Flugzeug sitzt.
Hat das Ding ein GPS eingebaut?
Nee. Nee.
Wozu?
Um zum Beispiel zu merken, dass er im Flugzeug ist.
Er merkt es im Flugzeug, weil das Flugzeug sich halt nach vorne bewegt.
Du halt das Ding aufsetzt und der Beschleunigungssensor das Aber dann doch halt.
Ja.
Ja, Beschleunigungssensor hat er natürlich, dass das Ding beschleunigt ist.
Das ist das Ding, was das Ding gut kann.
Er merkt jede Bewegung im Raum.
Und der merkt dann auch sofort, wenn du im Flugzeug bist und sagst,
was geht hier ab? Willst du Reisemodus einschalten?
Ja, klapp, tap, Reisemodus, bumm, so.
Weiß dich dann nochmal drauf hin, dass du dann aber auch wirklich an deinem
Ort bleibst und nicht rumläufst, weil dann kann er, weil er das ja sozusagen alles ausschaltet.
Ist aber auch kein Problem, weil du sitzt dann halt in deinem Flugsitz und blickst
halt irgendwie auf den Dings und ich mach halt wieder meinen Riesenschirm auf
und hab halt irgendwie Kino.
So. Ich hatte jetzt, kann aber auch damit zu tun haben, dass ich jetzt hier
die Developer-Betas drauf hatte, hatte ich Probleme nochmal mit Bluetooth,
ich hatte dann irgendwie Disconnects mit meinen AirPods, das war jetzt irgendwie
auf den letzten Metern auf einmal ein Problem, aber ich glaube, das hat was,
da ist irgendwas in dem Release kaputt gegangen.
Aber das hat auch alles ganz hervorragend funktioniert und hat auch die Reisezeit
dann doch erheblich verkürzt.
Und da war ich dann halt auch komplett weg, ich hab einfach gar nichts mehr
davon gemerkt, dass ich im Flugzeug sitze. Ich sitze da halt einfach und gucke einen Film.
Das ist wirklich total irre.
Ja.
Also Produktivität okay, irgendwie körperliche Belastung erträglich.
Grafische Brillanz, Schärfe okay für mich.
Ich glaube, wenn man eine richtige Brille hat und da die ausmessen lässt,
und sich dann genau die Einsätze dafür machen lässt, dann ist das auch perfekt.
Das ist zumindest das, was ich von anderen Leuten gehört habe, bei denen das so ist.
Ich hatte ja die Einsätze im Apple-Store, die richtigen. Da haben sie ja die Brille ausgemessen.
Und das war schon ein ganz anderes Erlebnis als jetzt mit der geliehenen Brille,
wo keine Einsätze drin sind und man die Brille drunter tragen muss.
Ja.
Ich habe jetzt neulich einen schönen Beitrag gelesen, was Apple eigentlich alles
für App-Ideen so auf der Straße liegen lässt, wo man denkt, okay,
das wäre doch total cool, warum machen sie das nicht?
Und so der Hauptspin war, die
eingebauten Apple-Apps, warum die eigentlich nicht 3D sind. Stichwort Uhr.
Warum haben die nicht 50 Kultuhren modelliert,
wo du die halt einfach mal an die Wand hängen kannst oder auf den Tisch stellen
kannst so warum muss eine Uhr in der Vision Pro auch in irgendeinem zweidimensionalen
Milchgleis Fenster irgendwo in der Gegend hängen.
Es gibt glaube ich gar keine Uhr von Apple im OS. Es gibt nur Party.
Umso schlimmer.
Aber das gibt es dann auch schon wieder in allen Varianten Widget Smith und
hast nicht gesehen Also Uhren gibt es jetzt wirklich keinen Mangel.
Aber das ist nicht so wichtig. Oder dieses, das zweite Beispiel,
was sie hatten, das fand ich auch cool, die Find My Karte.
Also wo man irgendwie gucken kann, wo ist mein iPhone und wo sind meine Kopfhörer und sowas.
Ist nicht native.
Warum siehst du die nicht vor dir als kleine, süße 3D-Kulisse mit Apple Maps?
Und dann hast du da den Pin, wo dann das Ding ist und dann kannst du dann dich
vorlehnen und sowas. Das wäre doch saukool.
Ich glaube, die Antwort ist so ähnlich wie mit dem Taschenrechner und dem iPad.
Wir sind damals nicht dazugekommen und dann ist es priomäßig immer wieder hinten
runtergefallen bis ich glaube ich zum iOS 18 oder so dann endlich den Taschenrechner
aufs iPad gebracht habe.
Aber es fällt halt schon auf, dass sie wirklich keine einzige App haben,
die eigentlich mal 3D ist. Außer halt irgendwie einen 3D-Film gucken.
So alles andere ist halt flach auf irgendeinem Screen.
So und das ist eigentlich underwhelming für das, was man sich da vorspricht.
Also so eine Map, das wäre schon ganz cool.
Weißt du noch, als Apple den Macintosh 2 vorgestellt hat? Das weißt du doch nicht, oder?
Du weißt, wovon ich rede? Es gab den Macintosh in seiner ursprünglichen Bauform.
Und dann gab es den Macintosh 2, der halt so.
Nicht mehr den Monitor eingebaut hat.
Sondern der Monitor auf so einem rechteckigen Dings oben drauf stand.
Und was war das Besondere an dem Macintosh 2? Er hatte einen 68.020 Prozessor
und er hatte einen Farbbildschirm.
Und wenn du diesen Computer dann eingeschaltet hast.
War alles schwarz-weiß.
War alles schwarz-weiß, bis auf den Apfel. Bis auf den Apfel.
Aus dem Apfelmenü.
Das war sozusagen die Farbe, die sie genutzt haben.
Als sie Farbe hatten, haben sie den Apfel farbig gemacht und alles andere war
erstmal genauso wie sonst auch.
Ich finde das okay, dass sie einen mit diesem ganzen 3D-Kram nicht überwältigen.
Es ist immer eine Nuance. Du guckst ein Icon an und in dem Moment wird es plastischer.
Aber es springt dir auch nicht so ins Gesicht. Bei diesen ganzen Immersive-Videos,
die sie jetzt gerade rausbringen, diese ganzen Updates zu diesen ganzen Demos
und Konzertaufschulen, sogar Metallica, furchtbar,
da machen sie immer noch den Fehler, dass sie dann permanent so Close-Ups haben.
Da hast du auf einmal irgendwelche schwitzenden Fans so direkt vor deiner Nase.
Suchst du irgendwie so den, wo ist der Schalter, wo ich den irgendwie nach hinten
schieben kann? Ich will nicht so nah bei denen stehen.
Teilweise kann das auch total aufdringlich sein.
Und deswegen finde ich das ganz gut, wenn sie dieses übertriebene 3D-Getue erstmal
den Third-Partys überlassen.
Die machen das auch und da ist das auch nervig.
Also das ist gar nicht so das, wo ich mich sehne.
Es wäre generell erst mal wichtiger, dass sie mehr Native Apps haben,
auch von dem OS, also Kalender und so weiter.
Das muss halt alles irgendwie in Vision OS sein, aber ich glaube,
das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich mit der 3.0, wenn wir sehen, da kommen dann wahrscheinlich ein paar davon.
Die Apps sind doch im Prinzip alle ihr iOS Pendant, die da laufen.
Nö, nicht alle. Ja, aber Kalender.
Kalender ist die iPad-Besie.
Die iPad-App, genau. Und ich hatte das Gefühl, dass Mail war auch mehr oder
weniger das, was die iPad-App macht.
Also relativ viele von den eingebauten Apps waren im Prinzip die iPad-Apps mit Nuancen. Mail.
Ist native Kalender halt nicht aber ich.
Glaube Kalender.
Wird bei der nächsten.
Version so viel wie halt da native heißt weil ich meine es ist letzten Endes
ist es auch nur ein leicht verändertes iOS und die Frameworks die du verwendest
um das Zeug zu bauen das ist alles SwiftUI in der Usage.
Macht das natürlich einen Unterschied weil iPad Apps sind halt immer im iPad Size.
Nein nicht notwendigerweise.
Doch. Wenn es eine iPad-App ist, dann ist sie entweder vertikal oder landscape.
Nee, die kann auch eine andere Größe haben.
Wenn sie multitaskingfähig ist, dann kannst du die Größe verändern.
Bei welcher soll das so sein?
Du musst dieses komische Control Center anschalten. Dann hast du mehrere Windows
vor und hinter und so weiter.
Und dann kannst du auch die Größen auf dem iPad...
Ja, aber wenn du die iPad-Apps auf der Apple Vision Pro installierst als iPad-Apps,
dann sind sie entweder nur Landscape oder Portrait, das kannst du umschalten,
das war's. Mehr ist es nicht.
Es kann sein, dass du multitaskingfähige Apps, die in der Lage sind zu vergrößern,
dass du die auch vergrößern kannst.
Hauptproblem ist, dass die meisten gar nicht freigegeben sind für den Vision Store.
Also du hast schon wieder so eine komische Auswahl, so wie du viele iPhone-Apps
auf einmal nicht auf den Mac laden kannst wegen Bodennebel, weil irgendein Flag
nicht angeklickt ist, ist es halt teilweise auf der Vision Pro auch so,
dass die Apps nicht da sind, obwohl du die gerne haben möchtest.
Aber das ist, also aus der eigenen Erfahrung heraus kann ich dir sagen, ähm...
Apps auch für Mac zu veröffentlichen, ist halt so ein Problem,
weil du gerne, wenn dein Business dir Stranger Third Party Frameworks vorschreibt,
du gerne mal welche bekommst, die nicht auf dem Mac laufen.
Das kann gut sein, aber die iPad-Dinger laufen alle.
Oder aber, wenn du eine Mac-App machst, dann musst du die natürlich auch testen und pflegen.
Also du kannst nicht einfach sagen, ja, ich klicke hier den Haken und ob die
Scheiße läuft oder nicht, interessiert mich nicht. Also kannst du natürlich schon.
Du machst das viele. Ja, das Gefühl wird man nicht los.
Ja, aber es ist immer noch besser, als wenn es gar nicht da ist, ganz ehrlich.
Also das ist zwar schade, wenn es nicht läuft, aber wenn es halt nur deshalb
nicht läuft, weil so eine Checkbox nicht geklickt ist, dann ist es halt irgendwie bekloppt.
Also es ist so, dass die iPad-Apps, wenn du den Mac-Checkbox klickst,
auch meistens ganz brauchbar laufen.
Da sind dann so ein paar Kleinigkeiten dabei, wo du dann merkst,
das About-Fenster, da steht halt nicht viel drin.
Keyboard-Shortcuts, ja meistens. Das ist aber was, was du eigentlich bei einer
guten iPad-App eh haben willst, weil kann ja jemand eine Tastatur dran haben.
Klar, willst du haben, aber haben sie halt auch meistens nicht.
Haben sie mal auch mehr.
Egal, also auf jeden Fall, eine iPad-App läuft auf der Vision Pro in der Regel problemlos.
Und wenn die da nicht verfügbar ist im Store, dann ist das eine rein politische Entscheidung.
Wie zum Beispiel bei Netflix oder bei YouTube.
Und das ist auch tatsächlich eins der Probleme, ich wollte mal so ein bisschen
ein paar Probleme noch benennen die ich gesehen habe also,
dass Netflix da nicht native ist und vor allem YouTube ist ein echtes Problem,
weil du kannst es zwar im Webbrowser benutzen, aber das ist,
es ist möglich, es geht, aber es ist super annoying.
Und das, wo die YouTube App ja schon nicht so geil ist, ne?
Genau, die ist nicht geil und die wäre aber trotzdem eine deutliche Verbesserung,
allein schon damit du halt Offline-Video hast mit YouTube Premium,
das wäre schon mal ein Vorteil und das halt auch bei Netflix,
aber ich glaube sowohl Google als auch Netflix wollen sich da Apple derzeit
noch so ein bisschen auf Distanz halten und ihre,
Verhandlungsposition verbessern, das ist ein rein politisches Ding.
Ja, das ist wirklich doof und generell ist auch so Videopräsentationen dann
in so Webplayern, das ist halt teilweise unbenutzbar,
weil die halt alle so für Mausklick-Sachen sind und die Tab-Targets,
die du brauchst auf einer Vision Pro, die sind nochmal viel größer als auf einem iPad,
und dadurch kommst du an manche Kontrolls einfach gar nicht ran.
Also es gibt einfach Webplayer, die sind nicht benutzbar, es sei denn,
du schaltest halt noch den Mac-Bildschirm dazu und benutzt das Trackpad, dann geht es irgendwie.
Aber wenn du nur rein mit dem Finger und mit Augen versuchst,
das zu steuern, geht es gar nicht.
Und teilweise hat das auch ein bisschen was mit dem User-Interface zu tun.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt so ein YouTube-Video mache und dann habe ich es
rechts unten, habe ich das Icon, um so Fullscreen zu machen.
Jetzt ist das Fullscreen, es geht.
Full Fenster.
Ja, der schaltet im Fullscreen-Modus und dann erscheint tatsächlich dieser Videoplayer
Fullscreen in dem Sinne,
dass du nur noch wirklich dieses Video siehst in einem entsprechend großen Fenster
auf der Apple Vision Pro.
Wenn du die anschaust, hast du darunter halt diesen Punkt und diesen Strichbalken,
um das Ding anzufassen oder zu schließen.
Aber du hast halt auch so Sachen wie das Resize-Element, wenn du auf die Ecke guckst.
Und wenn jetzt in diesem Webplayer dann noch ein Element rechts unten ist,
also wenn du in der Ecke selbst, die jetzt auch wirklich die Ecke des Fensters ist,
da noch was zum Anklicken hast, dann ist es so, dass die Vision Pro, wenn ich da hinschaue,
im Zweifelsfall diesen Resize-Button an der Ecke priorisiert,
weil wenn du da hinguckst, willst du ja wahrscheinlich resizen und es ist quasi
ein User-Interface-Fehler auf der Vision Pro, sein User-Interface so zu machen,
dass da in der Ecke direkt auch noch was ist, was klein ist.
Ja, vor allen Dingen die Ecke ist ja nochmal abgerundet und dann rundet es wahrscheinlich
auch noch die Hälfte von dem User Interface Element aus dem Player ab.
Ja, das ist nicht so das Problem. Es ist wirklich, dass die Selektion ja irgendwann weggeht.
Und vor allem andere Sachen gehen auf einmal auch nicht mehr.
Zum Beispiel sind wir alle gewohnt, dass man auf einer iPhone App oder auf dem
iPad kannst du irgendwie oben an den Rand tippen und dann scrollt der Inhalt wieder nach oben.
Das geht nicht auf der Vision Pro. Weil es gibt keinen oberen Rand.
Das ist dann da zu Ende. Du kannst dann nirgendwo, du kannst nicht an den Rand,
ich habe das einfach bei verschiedenen Sachen ausprobiert und es geht nicht.
Du kannst also wirklich nur scrollen, indem du da halt irgendwie mit der Hand
irgendwie wirre Bewegungen machst.
Aber dir gehen einfach bestimmte Dinge verloren und das ist ein echt interessantes,
Thema jetzt so für User Interface Design und es wird ja eh gemunkelt,
dass sie jetzt so ein bisschen versuchen, mehr Vision Pro kompatibel das User
Interface umzubauen auf dem iPhone und auf dem iPad. Das werden wir nochmal sehen.
Also das ist definitiv etwas, wo sich noch was verbessern muss und dann gibt
es noch etwas, das nenne ich das Popcorn Problem.
Also stell dir mal vor, du liegst jetzt auf dem Bett oder du liegst auf dem
Sofa, hast die Brille auf und schaust einen Film.
Und dann isst du Popcorn.
Was machst du also die ganze Zeit?
Mit Daumen und Zeigefinger ein Popcorn greifen.
Und immer wenn du dein Popcorn nimmst, dann denkt der, dass du irgendwas antetzt
und dann geht der die ganze Zeit irgendwie die Fenster verloren,
gerade wenn du so YouTube im Fenster hast oder so.
Also Essen von irgendwelchen Snacks, während du einen Film guckst,
ist auf der Vision Pro ein totales Desaster, weil du einfach die ganze Zeit
denkst, du willst irgendwas anklicken und dann verscrollst du dich.
Und dann scrollst du auf einmal in die Timeline 30 Minuten nach vorne und wirst bekloppt dabei.
Das Popcorn-Problem ist echt ein großes Problem.
Da gibt es ja so Leute, die propagieren, auch wenn man am Rechner arbeitet oder
so und man will snacken, dass man das am besten mit Stäbchen macht.
Da kann man auch tief in Chipstüten reingreifen und die Hände bleiben sauber.
Vielleicht musst du mal probieren, ob du mit Stäbchen um das Popcorn-Problem rumkommst?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, aber Snacks
mit Stäbchen. Es ist halt eher die ganze Hand-Interaktion und auch andere.
Es muss noch nicht mal Popcorn sein. Also generell, wenn man so mit seiner Hand
irgendwie Dinge tut im Schoß,
Könnte das zu Problemen führen?
Nein. Ja.
Musst du dann immer die Hände unter die Decke nehmen, damit ich da irgendwie Ruhe habe.
Ja, schön die Hände unter der Decke. Vielleicht braucht man auch so ein Zubehörteil
wie den Popcorn-Behälter, der so überdacht ist, dass die Kameras die zupacken.
Du musst es ja zum Mund führen. Das ist ja das Problem. Also das geht nur so begrenzt.
Hat was mit Strohhalmen zu tun oder intravenöser Injektion.
Der Popcorn-Strohhalm. Sie brauchen entweder bessere Ignorierungsmomente,
dass es wirklich so einen Videomodus gibt, wo dann irgendwie so etwas nochmal
anders abgefangen wird.
Das wird definitiv ein Problem sein, was sie auch schon mal erkannt haben,
da bin ich mir relativ sicher.
Dann gibt es noch das Problem, wenn du ein Video abspielst, die Vision Pro besteht
dann darauf, dass nur ein Video gleichzeitig abgespielt wird.
Du kannst nicht zwei Videos laufen lassen. Geht nicht.
Wenn der eine läuft, dann hört der andere automatisch auf.
Also wenn er irgendwas laufen lassen will, ohne Ton und parallel vielleicht
noch was mit Ton und das andere ist aber nur so was auch immer, Webcam oder so, dann...
Ja okay, das sehe ich noch eher ein, als das Popcorn-Problem.
Ja, aber es gibt gute Gründe mehrere Videos laufen zu lassen so,
ja, ich will irgendwie vielleicht ein Fußballspiel im Hintergrund laufen lassen
und im Vordergrund gucke ich mir halt irgendwie einen kurzen Clip an,
da will ich nicht, dass dann das Fußballspiel auf einmal nicht weiterläuft oder
so, das ist das ist einfach blöd, also es ist einfach wieder so eine Anwendung, die die geht nicht Ja.
Die Amis haben keinen Fußball Ja.
Die haben auch Sport die.
Haben auch Sport.
Ja genau Tap to Top also es fehlt YouTube, Netflix,
Und, äh, genau.
Achso, ja, was auch noch ein total nerviges Ding ist, so, wollte ich so Signal
auch noch mit drauf haben.
So, alle Messenger installieren, was kann schon schief gehen.
Ahnst du schon, was das Problem ist?
Ja, Signal,
wenn es nicht im Vordergrund ist, macht es aus Sicherheitsgründen den Screen,
einfarbig.
Das könnte auch noch ein Problem sein, aber so weit bin ich gar nicht erst gekommen.
Probleme beginnen schon heuer.
Ah, Signal, da muss man irgendwelche QR-Codes scannen und so, ne?
Genau. Halten Sie diesen QR-Code, den ich Ihnen jetzt gerade anzeige, vor Ihrem Telefon.
Geht aber nicht Vision Pro was habe ich alles probiert ich habe versucht Screenshots
zu machen ich habe versucht irgendwie den QR-Code also den Bildschirm auf dem
Apple TV oder auf dem iPad anzeigen zu lassen,
dann da hin zu gucken und während ich quasi irgendwo auf den QR-Code gucke in der Brille,
das Bild dann auf dem iPad angucken zu lassen und parallel mit dem iPhone den
QR-Code auf dem iPhone iPad zu scannen Ich bin wahnsinnig geworden,
aber ich habe es nicht hinbekommen.
Ich habe zwar gelesen von manchen Leuten, die es irgendwie hinbekommen haben,
aber diese ganze Authentication mit QR-Code bricht komplett zusammen mit der Vision Pro.
Nicht möglich, darüber ein Security-Konzept zu implementieren.
Man muss sich was Neues einfallen lassen.
Diese QR-Codes sind tot, wenn es um diese Brille geht.
Wie war das? Das neu angemeldete Programm zeigt ein QR-Code an.
Und du musst aber mit einem bereits verbundenen Gerät den dann scannen.
Das wird natürlich schwierig.
Gab es nicht einen Modus, dass man den Screen der Vision Pro woanders mirrorn kann?
Ja, habe ich ja gerade gesagt. Das habe ich auch versucht. auf ein iPad.
Aber das war halt nie so schade.
Also erstmal hängt das auch immer davon ab, wo ich hingucke.
Ich muss dann halt auch noch auf diesen QR-Code gucken, während ich nebenbei,
also mit einer zweiten Person wäre es vielleicht etwas einfacher geworden,
hätte es vielleicht funktioniert, so ist es mir nicht genug.
Dann das Telefon so vor dem iPad halten, damit ich da den QR-Code sehe,
der da aber nur an der Stelle rumzuppelt, wo ich gerade hingucke,
während ich was anderes mache.
Ich bin wahnsinnig gewonnen, ich habe alles mögliche ausprobiert ich habe Screenshots probiert,
ich habe versucht das Ding irgendwie zu screenshotten und dann irgendwie über
Fotolibrary zu synken und dann auf dem Rechner und so weiter,
aber es war dann nie scharf genug und so also das ist auf jeden Fall nicht schön
und es gab für mich keine Möglichkeit die Single App zum Laufen zu bekommen,
also ich habe es einfach nicht, also es ist irgendwelchen Leuten ist es gelungen,
aber mir ist es nicht gelungen.
Und das ist halt echt ein Problem. Naja.
Hast du denen mal geschrieben deswegen? Wahrscheinlich nicht, ne?
Wen jetzt Single?
Ja.
Nee.
Ich habe den irgendwann mal geschrieben, weil ich Probleme hatte. Irgendwie.
Ja. Naja.
Riesen QR-Code auf dem iPad und
das Phone hat den einfach nicht gescannt gekriegt. Überhaupt gar nicht.
Ja. Also das ist auf jeden Fall, da muss man eine andere Lösung finden.
Das muss irgendwie eine andere Lösung geben.
Ja, das bin ich auch fast durch. Eine Sache noch. Ich habe dann mal so einen
Performance-Meter gefunden, was mir die CPU-Auslastung anzeigt.
Und?
Und es war erstaunlich, dass irgendwie alle Efficiency-Cores,
zumindest wenn die Anzeige richtig war, permanent in Action waren.
Also das Ding war eigentlich die ganze Zeit voll ausgelastet und drei Viertel
der Performance-Cores wiederum waren, hier habe ich geschrieben, selten beschäftigt.
Deckt sich das jetzt gerade mit meiner Erinnerung?
Also auf jeden Fall war viel los auf diesen Efficiency-Cores.
Überhaupt wird das Ding ja auch ganz gut warm und lüftet ja so nach oben weg,
was eigentlich kein Problem ist, außer dass es halt Strom verbraucht.
Naja, aber dafür hast du die Efficiency-Cores ja, dass du die auslasten kannst,
ohne dass es signifikant Strom verbraucht.
Und nur wenn du wirklich richtig ordentlich Last brauchst, dann benutzt du halt
die Performance-Cores.
Ja, aber die waren auch immer voll in Volllast. Also die Efficiency-Course,
die waren auch richtig beschäftigt.
Also das Teil, man merkt richtig, da ist viel zu tun.
Er muss ja ständig Gyros auslesen, Accelerometer auslesen, irgendwie Ort im
Raum ausrechnen, wo kommen die Bilder hin und so weiter.
Klar, da wird so ein bisschen die Grafikkarte auch mitspielen und Forviated
Rendering läuft wahrscheinlich auch vor allen Dingen über die Grafikkarte.
Aber ich kann mir das gut vorstellen, dass da ständig was los ist,
weil du hältst den Kopf ja auch nie still.
Auf jeden Fall, da ist noch viel Luft nach oben für Performance-Verbesserungen, denke ich mal.
Also da dürfte die nächste Generation nächstes Jahr vielleicht was bringen.
Beziehungsweise wahrscheinlich eher ist es dann die nächste Generation Silicon,
die da den Durchbruch bringt.
Ja, das meine ich ja auch. Also in der nächsten Generation wird definitiv kein M2 drin sein.
Gut, damit fertig. Vielleicht ein letzter Satz, weil für mich war das ja so
ein bisschen eine Re-Evulation des Go-To-Effekts.
Da hatten wir, als wir ja ganz vor einem Jahr über die Brille gesprochen haben,
war das so einer meiner Grundfragen.
Ich hatte also jetzt wirklich das Setup. Da lag ein Telefon,
da lag die Brille, da lag ein Laptop, da lag ein iPad.
Ich hatte sozusagen alles am Start, außer Apple TV.
Und dann ist immer die Frage, okay, jetzt will ich irgendwas tun.
Was ist mein Go-To-Device? Welches Device gewinnt? welches Device verliert.
Und mit der Brille und dem Laptop und dem iPad und dem Telefon habe ich gemerkt,
dass ich das Telefon und das iPad sehr viel weniger verwendet habe.
Und es hat sich eigentlich im Wesentlichen mit Brille und Laptop sehr viel abgespielt.
Das iPad hat auf jeden Fall so als Film-Outlet verloren gegenüber der Brille,
weil da die Brille einfach den geileren Gesamteindruck macht.
Ja gut, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Und vor allem in meiner spezifischen Situation, was ich auch als sehr angenehm
empfunden habe, wenn ich mit meinem Laptop und meinem Telefon arbeiten will, oder im iPad auch,
brauche ich halt immer eine Lesebrille. Muss man diese Lesebrille aufsetzen
und das geht mal besser, mal schlechter und okay, die hat man dann auf,
ist auch irgendwie okay.
Aber irgendwie dachte ich mir manchmal so, setz mir einfach Division Pro auf.
Da ist meine Lesebrille irgendwie drin und wenn ich da drin bin, ist alles da.
Also da ist die Brille sozusagen boundless. Da ist dann auf einmal alles wieder
gleich scharf Apple Lesevision.
Ja, also das war so schon nochmal so ein extra Effekt, dass das irgendwie angenehm ist.
Und dann war ich da irgendwie auch gern und dann habe ich mir da meine Filme angeschaut.
Notizen machen war nicht so gut. So mit Notes arbeiten und so weiter schreiben ist schwierig.
Da will man dann schon irgendwie eine Tastatur dabei haben.
Not for everything, Aber gerade dieser Macintosh-Modus ist saugeil.
Also das hätte ich ehrlich gesagt, das habe ich auch am Anfang nicht gedacht.
Ich weiß noch, als wir darüber geredet haben, als über das Ding gemunkelt wurde
und ich bezweifelt habe, dass es dafür gute Anwendungen gibt,
kam irgendwie aus dem Chat der Hinweis, ja, hier als Bildschirm.
Und ich dachte mir so, als Bildschirm habt ihr sie noch alle.
Aber da haben sie mich wirklich eines Besseren belehrt, muss ich sagen.
Tatsächlich ist das die Killer-App für das Teil.
Wenn man eine Anwendung hat, die von einem großen Bildschirm profitiert und
man ist auf Reisen viel und man will mit wenig Gerät unterwegs sein,
dann ist das auf jeden Fall eine Investition, die sich schnell lohnen kann.
Ja, soviel zu dem Thema von mir.
Jetzt müssen wir uns ja drüber unterhalten, was Ralf so macht.
Machst du auch Dinge?
Ralf ist richtig wild. Ja, also der lebt ein Leben jenseits der Norm.
Da machen wir uns überhaupt keine Vorstellung.
Während ihr euch alle in der weiten Welt rumtreibt.
Wir hängen nur mit am Strand in Vietnam in der Elbe mit einem Po auf der Nase rum.
Warst du, bin ich mit meinen Kindern mit meinen Kindern,
Zu Ikea gefahren.
Du Rebellen.
Schwedisches Müllhaus. Alter.
Jetzt müssen wir einen kleinen Disclaimer vorschieben.
Wir hatten ja schon irgendwie Podcasts und wie sie strukturiert sind und es gibt ja Kapitelmarken.
Jetzt kommt wirklich so eine Sektion, alter weißer Mann schüttelt die Faust gen Himmel.
Also wenn euch das nervt, dann fühlt euch ermuntert einfach ein Kapitel nach vorne zu.
Wolken, nehmt euch in Acht.
Nach vorne zu skippen. Also, vielleicht noch ein Versuch der Einordnung.
Ich war jetzt seit langer Zeit nicht mehr bei Ikea.
Ich glaube seit sechs Jahren oder sowas ungefähr.
Bin aber eigentlich recht Ikea-freundlich immer gewesen, so Zeit meines Lebens.
Also damals irgendwie mit 18, dann erste Wohnung und dann fährt man da schon
mal hin und ich mag halt grundsätzlich,
skandinavischen Design Stil und auch dieses Konzept so, sich den Kram selber
zusammen zu bauen, fand ich immer ganz lustig. Das habe ich auch alles ganz gerne gemacht.
Habe ich also keine Schmerzen mit und relevante Teile meiner aktuellen Wohnung
sind auch immer noch von Ikea so.
Weil immer, wenn ich in ein traditionelles Möbelhaus gehe, denke ich einfach
nur, was wollt ihr hier von mir? Es ist alles hässlich, geht weg.
Das mag Besseres geben da draußen, für dann wahrscheinlich aber auch sehr viel mehr Geld und Der.
Fairness halber muss man sagen, dass es auch bei Ikea Dinge gibt,
wo ich mir denke, was wollt ihr von mir, geht weg, es ist hässlich.
Klar, aber es gibt auch einfach mal so Klassiker, so einen Poengstuhl,
dieser Sessel, dieser freie Schwingwessel, ist einfach ein totaler Designklassiker,
finde ich, kann man wirklich nichts gegen sagen.
So, jetzt habe ich ja Kinder und als ich das letzte Mal bei Ikea war,
da war also mein größerer glaube ich ungefähr zwei Jahre.
Und da dachte ich so, jetzt gehst du mit denen endlich mal ins Smallland.
Wisst ihr, was das Smallland ist?
Das ist der Kinderbespaßungsabteilung. Kinderparkplatz bei Ikea.
Der Kinderpark, genau. Also wenn man bei Ikea reinkommt, unten im Erdgeschoss,
überall gleich aufgebaut, ist also dort quasi so eine kleine Tobe, also gar nicht so klein.
Also man weiß nicht, ob sie klein oder groß ist, man sieht das ja alles nicht
so richtig. Da gibt es also einfach einen quasi Kita-Bereich,
in dem man halt seine Kinder betreut abgeben kann und hat dann als Eltern Ruhe
und kann eine Stunde irgendwie da durchziehen.
Das fand ich immer total cool und faszinierend, schon als ich keine Kinder hatte.
Ich wollte aber auch immer mal wissen, wie ist es denn da eigentlich in diesem Smallland?
Was passiert denn da nun eigentlich?
Man hört da immer irgendwie so was von, aber darfst du halt Erwachsene auch da nicht rein?
Ich meine, dass Kinder da abgeholt werden wollen.
Genau, das wird in den Durchsagen immer durchgegeben. So, und du darfst aber
Kinder erst ab, ich glaube, drei oder vier Jahre im Smallland abgeben.
Und Anton war damals also einfach noch zu jung.
Das heißt, den mussten wir also dann wieder durch die normale Ausstellung durchschleppen.
Ich jetzt also vor zwei Wochen mit meinen Jungs mal wieder nach Ikea.
Und jetzt waren die beide im perfekten Smallland-Alter. Da dachte ich mir,
jetzt, jetzt ist der Moment gekommen. Du hast zwei Kinder.
Die freuen sich da schon drauf wie Boller. Denen hast du schon sonst was erzählt.
Jetzt geht es in Smallland.
Oh Gott, das kann ja nur schief.
Schon der Name verfängt.
Was heißt das überhaupt?
Und dann das kleine Leute-Land quasi. Small ist einfach klein.
Small ist klein, ja.
Moment, das wird erstmal nachgeschlagen.
Ja, mach das aber.
Smorland ist eine historische Provinz in Südschweden.
Schau da ein. Also ein Wortspiel.
Die Provinz ist typisch skandinavisch mit großen Nadelwäldern,
vielen Seen und ausgedehnten Mooren.
All das gibt es dort nicht. So viel ist schon mal sicher.
Småland wurde aus einer Reihe sogenannter kleiner Länder, schwedisch Små,
Land. Kleine Länder. Kleines Land. Okay. Daraus wurde es gemacht.
Daraus wurde es gemacht. Also das kleine Land macht ja alles semantisch irgendwie Sinn.
So, also das war jetzt also der Plan. Jetzt gibst du dir deine Racker ab und
die werden dann hinter dir endlich mal berichten können, was denn da eigentlich
wirklich abgeht im Smallland.
So, wir da jetzt also hin, Feuer und Flamme.
Und ich denke gesagt, so eine Stunde lang geht ihr in Smallland und dann gehen
wir zusammen essen und dann ist Papa auch schon fertig und wir können ja nach Hause.
Jetzt kommst du da hin und das erste, was dich begrüßt, sind zwei große TFT-Terminals.
So ein Meter hoch mindestens, also so auf Oberkörpergröße, so ähnlich wie diese
ganzen Selbstbestell-Terminals, die man jetzt auch irgendwie bei McDonalds und
sonst wo überall sieht. Ich weiß nicht, ich hab da so ungefähr vor Augen.
So eine 2001 Stähle.
Wo halt einfach ein Touchscreen drin ist.
So und da war also irgendeine GUI drauf, die ich erstmal ignoriert hab und stattdessen
lauf ich also an den Counter, der also der Eingangsbereich ist Richtung normale
Menschen, wo sich drei...
Damen, langweilten, die da halt irgendwie am Counter vom Smallland sahen.
Weil es keine Kinder gab, oder was?
Naja, mit denen durfte ich aber nicht sprechen. So, die sagten so,
nee, Anmeldung da vorne über die Stähle, bei uns können sie hier keinen...
Muss seine Kinder da der Screen einchecken, oder was?
So, ich also zurück zu der Stähle. Das erste, was da auffällt,
eine von den beiden ist kaputt, die war defekt.
So, vor der zweiten stand ein verzweifelter Familienvater, der also jetzt versuchte,
sein Kind dort einzuchecken in Smallland.
Und dann habe ich mir das da mal etwas genauer angeguckt, was denn da so IT-technisch passierte.
Das war schon wild.
Also es war grundsätzlich erstmal schon so Ikea- Ikonografie,
also sehr, sehr viel Whitespace, weißer Hintergrund.
Ihr habt so die Ikea-Seite vielleicht irgendwie so ein bisschen vor Augen,
wenn du so Sachen bestellst. Eigentlich fast alles nur schwarz-weiß, wie damals quasi der.
Auch die Produkte Suchterminals sind so.
Der Macintosh 2, genau, alles so ein bisschen in dem Stil. Aber alle irre kleine
Schrift für diesen riesen Monitor, wo man sich schon fragt, warum hat er nicht
mal den Zoom-Level hochgeschaltet, weil ihr wollt doch nur irgendwie einen Namen eintippen hier.
Da müsst ihr doch nicht auf 10-Punkt-Schrift gehen, wenn ihr schon so viel Platz habt.
Und dann halt ein On-Screen-Tip-Display, wo man dann irgendwie da den Namen reintippen muss und so.
Also der Vater war irgendwie einigermaßen verzweifelt. Hat das dann aber irgendwann
geschafft, seinen Junior dort also in diese Datenbank dort einzutragen,
um die jetzt also im Smolland abgeben zu können. Dann drückt er auf Abschicken,
Dann bekommt er die fröhliche Mitteilung. Vielen Dank. Ihre Wartezeit beträgt 75 Minuten.
Was?
Und ich so, was?
Vater vor mir zusammengebrochen, der hat sich nicht mehr bewegt.
Ich also zurück zum Counter. habe.
Und gefragt, hätte gerade jemand an dem Display gestanden und da hätte jetzt
irgendwie Wartezeit 75 Minuten, was hätte ich mir denn darunter vorzustellen?
Naja, das ist die Zeit, die sie jetzt halt warten müssen, bis sie ihr Kind hier abgeben können.
Und ich gucke dann so an ihr vorbei in dieses Smallland rein,
was nicht übermäßig groß ist.
Ja, da war irgendwie ein Bällebad drin und so eine kleine Kletterecke und eine
Ecke mit irgendwie Tischen und Mahlzeug und sowas. Das war alles leer.
Und dann gucktest du weiter um die Ecke und dann hast du gesehen,
okay, irgendwo so unter der Decke hing so ein Screen, wo offensichtlich irgendwie
ein Film lief oder sowas.
Und da saßen dann vielleicht so zwölf Kinder davor.
Also kein Kind hat in diesem Smallland auch irgendwas anderes gemacht außer Fernsehklossen.
Kein pädagogisches Programm, kein nichts. Und die Aufsichtspersonen haben sich
vorne gelangweilt. Und ich dann so.
Okay, 75 Minuten Wartezeit, weil das hier gerade überfüllt ist,
zeigt er also auf diese 140 leeren Quadratmeter Bar aller Kinder und sie dann so, ja genau.
Weil einfach ihre offizielle Zahl von erlaubten Kindern ist 15 und das ist am Ende.
Ist halt irgendwie, weil sie wahrscheinlich aufgrund welcher Policy auch immer
dort einen Verteilungsschlüssel haben, ja, Wartezeit 75 Minuten.
Gut, das müsst ihr doch irgendwie kommunizieren, Leute, ja, also man hätte halt,
was man hätte machen müssen ist, zu Hause buchen, du kannst das quasi remote
buchen, deinen Slot im Smallland.
Ein Slot kommt.
Und dann fährst du nach Ikea, wenn dein Slot irgendwie aufgerufen wird.
Aber geht nicht.
Wahrscheinlich wäre das gegangen, aber auf die Idee kommst du ja nicht.
Vor allem, ich hab morgens mir noch die Smallland-Seite angeschaut.
Da wirst du da eben nicht drauf hingewiesen. Wenn die da also hätten so,
Achtung, wir haben Wartezeiten heute, Samstag und so weiter,
rechnen sie damit, hier können sie clever sein, sowas kann ich ja alles kommunizieren,
wenn ich dann schon solche bescheuerten Spielregeln habe, ja.
Aber Familien vor Ort, die sich darauf freuen, jetzt sind sie mal eine Stunde
ihr Kind los, was so das Heilsversprechen ist, dann zu sagen,
ja, 75 Minuten Wartezeit, obwohl nur 15 Kiddies drin rum, das geht nicht,
das kannst du nicht machen.
So, meine Kinder am Boden zerstört. Ihr könnt das euch vorstellen.
Ja, klar, logisch.
Niemand wollte jetzt 75 Minuten auf das Smolland warten. Gut,
wir dann also erstmal als Ersatz dann halt oben Köttbullar essen,
schmeckten scheiße, die waren früher auch besser.
Ich glaube, Chefbullar übrigens, 25 Minuten gewartet, bis wir da auch an dem
Essen dran waren, Also ja, es war ein Samstag, aber es war nicht übermäßig voll.
Aber die ganze Detailorganisation, auch von dem Catering-Bereich,
habe ich irgendwie alles viel besser und viel...
Welche Ikea waren das?
Das ist der in so Richtung Marzahn raus.
Lichtenberg.
Lichtenberg, okay. In dem waren wir aber immer. So, also das...
Ich bin da selten, aber...
So, und...
Gut, dann Ikea selber, die Sachen, die ich haben wollte, hatten sie alle nicht.
Meine Stimmung sank ins Bodenlose. Man kann sich das vorstellen.
So, aber der Ausgang.
Auch wieder diese Selbstverbucher-Terminals überall,
wo man sich auch mal denkt, okay, in welchen Szenarien funktioniert das eigentlich
gut und wo funktioniert das irgendwie weniger gut und dann hast du da irgendwie
riesige Pakete und musst dann selber gucken, jetzt fahre ich deine Wagen nach
vorne, damit ich mit dem Scanner drankomme und dann fahre ich wieder nach hinten um die andere.
Gut, kann man alles drüber diskutieren, aber dann kostet am Ende auch noch der Hotdog 2 Euro.
Die haben die Hotdog-Preise erhöht.
Skandal!
Ja, pass auf.
Im Smallhand.
Hear me out. Für diejenigen, die dort nicht so Firmen drin sind,
der Ikea Hotdog ist auch etwas ganz Besonderes.
Das ist auch eine Philosophie, die da mit verbunden ist. Nämlich,
nachdem du durch dieses stressige Möbelhaus gearbeitet hast,
viel zu viele hunderte, tausende Euros ausgegeben hast.
Du wolltest nur die eine Sache kaufen und trotzdem ist dein ganzer Wagen am
Ende voll, weil sie halt auch ein bisschen cooles Zeug da rumstehen haben.
So, und dann bist du gerade durch die Kasse durch und dann läufst du auf die Hotdog-Theke zu.
Und dort steht in großen Lettern Hotdog, ein Euro zum selber belegen.
So, das ist immer der psychologische Effekt gewesen, so, oh,
das war alles ganz schön anstrengend und ich habe viel zu viel Geld hier gelassen,
aber wenigstens kriege ich jetzt einen Hotdog für einen Euro, ja.
Und diesen Vertrag hat Ikea einseitig aufgekündigt und hat jetzt den Preis auf zwei.
Und du glaubst nicht, was das in einem Menschen anstellt, der auf sowas irgendwie
sensibel reagiert. Du merkst, okay, hier weht ein anderer Wind.
Mir ist völlig klar, dass ihr da Verlust mitmacht, wenn ihr das für einen Euro
macht. Da brauchen wir nicht drüber diskutieren.
Aber die Debatte gab es vor ein paar Jahren schon mal, wo es wohl bei Ikea,
ich habe das noch nachgelesen, wo man diskutiert, den ganz abzuschaffen,
weil man dann mit so viel Verlust macht.
Und der damalige Chef hat sich dann durchgesetzt und gesagt,
Leute, ihr müsst auch mal das glückliche Gesicht der Kinder auf der Rückbank
auf der Rückfahrt mit einpreisen in eure Kalkulation.
Diesen Effekt könnt ihr nicht einberechnen, sinnvoll.
Ja, exakt so ist es. So, und jetzt kostet dieser scheiß Hot-Tuck halt zwei Euro,
ist damit viel dichter dran an dem, was er vielleicht gefühlt irgendwie wert wäre oder sowas.
Aber dieser, ich möchte sagen, Gesellschaftsvertrag, den Ikea hier hatte,
der ist einfach mal aufgekündigt. Plus dieses im Detail kaputt optimierte.
So, wir wollten dann, also Hot Dogs hatte auch irgendwie keiner Lust zu und
zwei Euro, das hätte ich jetzt aus Prinzip niemals dafür gezahlt,
aber ein Eis sollten die Kinder halt irgendwie kriegen.
So, jetzt glaub mal nicht, dass du also an dieser Theke jetzt ein Eis kaufen konntest,
sondern du musstest dich also an die Theke anstellen, wo dann auch wieder so
eine lange Schlange erstmal dich zu den ganzen Leuten, die einen Hotdog an der
Theke ausgegeben haben bekommen, musstest du dich mit denen zusammen anstellen,
um ein Coin zu bekommen für dein Eis.
Diesen Coin musstest du dann zu einem weiteren Automaten tragen,
wo du dich in die nächste Schlange angestellt hast Das hat.
Ja schon fast aus dem Flughafen Security-Kontrolle aber echt.
Dann standst du also dann in
der nächsten Schlange vor diesem scheiß Eisautomaten um dann festzustellen,
wenn du dann dran bist und da vorne dran stehst, dass du dich nicht an dem richtigen
Eisautomaten angestellt hast,
weil aus dem kommt nämlich nur Vanille und kein scheiß Schoko.
Da musst du also nochmal um die Säule rum den Schoko-Eisautomaten finden.
Und also egal in welche Detail man es da guckt, ich hatte selten das Gefühl,
dass irgendwas gerade so runtergerockt wird, wie dieses Ikea-Prinzip,
was irgendwie gefühlt die letzten 40 Jahre ziemlich stabil überlebt hat.
Das geht gerade echt vor den Rund.
Der Tod der industriellen Automatisierung und Verkackung von Web-Terminals.
Dieser Ingmar Kamprad, das I&K aus Ikea, der ist doch schon seit einer Weile tot, oder?
Wie lange, weiß ich nicht, aber können wir ja mal rausfinden.
Wofür ist das relevant?
Naja, der hat den Laden gegründet und der hatte wahrscheinlich immer den Daumen
da drauf, wie die Ikea-Experience ja so ist.
Der hat übrigens mal Uhren verkauft und weil er der Meinung war,
dass französische Uhren tolle Uhren sind, hatte das eh ein Accent Tegue.
Als er unter dem Namen Ikea die Uhren verkauft hat. Sehr, sehr witzig.
Das ist das, was man erfährt, wenn man in Schweden in Almhult,
das A von Ikea, in das Ikea-Museum geht.
Das frech viel Geld kostet dafür, dass es eine große Werbeveranstaltung für dieses Museum ist.
Es ist bei Legio auch so, aber da lohnt es sich wenigstens. Was ich übrigens
noch vergessen habe, was sie auch kaputt rationalisiert haben,
ist das Café am Ende des Gartencenters.
Das ist auch ein Ikea-Standard-Pattern. Das kenne ich nicht.
Du hast ja oben im ersten OG hast du ja immer deine Ausstellung,
wo du durch die ganzen aufgebauten Sachen durchgehst.
Dann gehst du runter, wo du dann die Lagerhallen hast und irgendwie die Küchengeschichten,
und Aufbewahrung und so weiter.
Und Licht und sowas. Und am Ende davon, genau Licht und nach dem Licht,
kommt die Garten- und Grünzeugabteilung, wo du Plastikblumen und echte Blumen und sowas kriegst.
Da haben sie auch ganz lustiges Zeug immer irgendwie, da findet man schon was.
Und dann geht es ins eigentliche Lagerhalle.
Und da geht es in die eigentliche Lagerhalle und dazwischen ist immer ein Café.
Das ist also auch dort, bevor du dann… Das kenne ich nicht.
Das Café.
Ein kleines Café, aber da gibt es lecker Zimtschnecken und einen guten Kaffee und sowas.
Und da kann man sich nochmal kurz hinsetzen. Das ist nämlich auch die Gartenmöbelabteilung.
Da hat man immer eine Endgespänlichkeit erreicht, um so schnell wie möglich
aus dem Plan rauszukommen.
Genau, also da ist man nämlich auch schon immer sehr genervt.
Und darum war auch dieses Café dort auch schon immer ganz gut strategisch positioniert.
Weil da kann man sich nochmal aufmunitionieren, um es dann bis zum Hotdog zu schaffen.
In Ruhleben gab es dieses Café nie.
Diese Cafés sind jetzt auch personalfrei geschaltet.
Das heißt, da gibt es jetzt also auch nur noch einen Kaffeeautomaten,
wo du dir wieder glaubst, nicht, dass du an diesem Kaffeeautomaten alles bekommst,
was du brauchst und du brauchst erst deinen Coin.
Dann musst du dir mit dem Coin einen Becher ziehen, dann musst du mit dem Becher
zu dem Automaten laufen.
Und ich sage, so und jetzt ratet mal, was dieser Coinautomat nicht annimmt.
Geld?
Ja, elektronisches.
Alles andere außer Münzen?
Alles andere außer Münzen, exakt. Das heißt, es war schon der nächste Moment,
wo ich dort mit nörgeligen Kindern, Papa, wir wollen ein Wasser haben.
Die wollten einfach nur ein Wasser trinken, ein Kranwasser.
Ich würde mich ja mal mit dem Filialleiter zusammensetzen.
Das dann aber auch irgendwie 2,50 Euro für ein Drittel Liter kostet oder so.
Das hätte ich ja an der Stelle auch bezahlt. Hätte ich es denn bezahlen können?
Ich habe kein Bargeld mehr dabei, wenn ich irgendwo durch die Gegend laufe. Ich mache das nicht.
Ein Elend.
27. Januar 2018. Das ist ja gestorben, seitdem geht es bergab.
Also ich habe in Wroclaw, in Breslau, wie auch immer man die Stadt nennen will,
am Bahnhof, mein Wasser aus dem Automaten mit Apple Pay gezogen.
Da hat das funktioniert.
Vom Spirit her musst du da einfach einen kostenlosen Wasserautomaten hinstellen,
so wie du das in diversen Decathlon hat das beispielsweise.
Da ziehst du dann aus einem kleinen Pub-Zylinder Kubus dann halt irgendwie dein Leitungswasser raus.
Das muss nicht sprudeln, du brauchst einfach nur was zum Trinken für Kinder.
Und Erwachsene.
So, ich hätte jetzt aufs Klo gehen können und dort irgendwie gucken,
ob ich dem was abgefüllt hätte.
Ja, aber an der Stelle ist ja auch kein Klo.
An der Stelle war in der Tat auch kein Klo. Nun ja.
Es tut mir sehr leid für dich und deine Kinder.
Also meine Kinder sind jetzt traumatisiert. Wir werden nie wieder irgendwas bei Ikea kaufen.
Das kann ich auch verstehen. Ja, da ist was dran.
Also ich meine, ich habe ja den Vorteil, Nachteil, weiß ich nicht,
dass ich keine Hotdogs mag.
Insofern war das jetzt für mich die Hotdog-Experience und dass der teurer geworden
ist, ist für mich eine neue Information.
Aber gut. Naja.
So.
Wollen wir zu unserem krönenden Abschlussthema kommen?
Ich bitte darum.
Ja, um hier auch nochmal, wie sagt man so schön, Ending on a good note?
Ne, wie war das? Irgendwie sowas.
Ja, also ich bin ja erklärter nicht Fernsehbinger.
Also Fernsehen sowieso schon nicht mehr, aber ich bin auch nicht jetzt in diesem,
Serienwahnsinn, in dem sich manche Leute so befinden und halte mich da eigentlich
generell etwas zurück und bin unbelesen, was viele Sachen betrifft.
Gibt allerdings immer wieder Ausnahmen und dann kann ich mich auch richtig reinlegen.
Ich hatte großen Spaß zum Beispiel mit Stranger Things, dieser Netflix-Serie
und nicht nur, weil da Kate Bush am Schluss wieder so eine Auferstehung gefeiert hat.
Alter, also die vierte Staffel ist schon Hammer, oder?
Ja, die hat es auf jeden Fall rausgerissen.
Wie ist da die Backstory quasi für die erste Staffel dann konstruieren.
Also das ist echt Masterclass in wie man gute späte Seasons baut.
Ja, ich denke Stranger Things war ein sehr gutes Beispiel. Von daher,
ich kann jetzt auch nicht,
belesen über alle Fernsehserien sprechen und deswegen ist es immer so ein bisschen
schwierig mit den Superlativen, weil wenn man nicht alles kennt,
wie soll man da den Vergleich haben?
Superlative werden sehr überschätzt.
Das stimmt.
Superlative sind das Schlimmste.
Trotzdem möchte ich dass,
eine Fernsehserie von einer Fernsehserie berichten die ich gesehen habe in ihrer
Gänze und in einer Detailtiefe wie ich das bisher noch nie getan habe,
Und es handelt sich dabei wenig
überraschend um Severance, was es halt auf und nur auf Apple TV gibt.
Und das schließt ja viele Leute schon mal aus, weil ja viele der Meinung sind,
sie müssten irgendwie nur bei Netflix gucken, was ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so
richtig verstehe. Okay, Stranger Things.
Gibt auch noch ein paar andere nette Sachen, aber das meiste was da ist, ist auch nur Grütze.
Naja, egal, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall.
Apple TV Plus.
Apple TV Plus, korrekt, so heißt das.
Ich bin schuldig wir haben echt alles im Abo bei uns.
Ja gut, dann hast du ja Zugriff auf Apple TV und du hast mir auch berichtet,
du hast die ersten drei Folgen Severance schon gesehen.
Ich bin jetzt hier betont spoilerfrei.
Dafür bedanke ich mich schon mal.
Ja, also das ist natürlich vollkommen klar. Aber eine Prämisse kann man klar
benennen, nämlich worum es in dieser Serie generell geht.
Das wird sozusagen von Anfang an klargestellt und das kriegt man in jedem Trailer
und in jeder Ankündigung, in jeder Erwähnung eh fünfmal um die Ohren gehauen.
Es gibt da halt eine Firma,
Die Leuten eine Beschäftigung bietet und wenn sie diese Beschäftigung wahrnehmen möchten,
dann erhalten sie einen Chip in den Kopf eingepflanzt, der dafür sorgt,
dass wenn sie diese Firma betreten, spätestens den Fahrstuhl,
um dann in ihre Räume zu fahren,
dann schaltet ihre Identität auf eine andere Zweitidentität um.
Und in dieser Zweitidentität erlebt dann dieselbe Person sozusagen die ganze
Arbeitswelt des Tages und nach acht Stunden, wenn die Schicht beendet ist,
tritt sie wieder aus der Firma heraus und dann wird wieder auf die normale Identität umgeschaltet.
Das heißt, du stellst deine Arbeitskraft zur Verfügung, aber du nimmst deine
Arbeit nicht mit nach Hause, weil du gar nichts davon weißt.
Genauso wenig weiß dann aber auch diese Person, die dann dort arbeitet,
irgendwas über dein Leben.
Das heißt, es gibt sozusagen da eine Trennung, eine künstlich herbeigeführte
Split Personality, deswegen heißt die Sendung Severance, Trennung,
weil du halt abgetrennt wirst sozusagen an dieser Stelle.
Wobei grundsätzlich die Leute schon wissen, dass diese Trennung stattfindet.
Es wird ihnen nicht verheimlicht.
Genau, also du weißt, Achtung, Abgleich ist quasi wieder Cut,
aber man hat halt keinen Zugriff auf die anderen.
Und daraus leitet sich unter anderem der Begriff des Innis und des Autis ab.
Das heißt, dieselbe Person ist Inni und Auti quasi zugleich,
aber nicht immer zum selben Zeitpunkt.
Der Auti lebt halt sein normales Leben weiter und der Inni lebt halt nur das Leben bei dieser Firma.
Lumon, ja, soweit so die Prämisse.
Du hast ja noch gar nichts davon gesehen, deswegen darfst du die Fragen fragen.
Die erste Frage ist, hast du auf der Apple-Webseite unter Mac mal geguckt,
was es da so zu kaufen gibt?
Ja, seit ein paar Tagen gibt es.
Da gibt es ganz links den Tab Lumon,
Terminal Pro und dann haben sie hier diese Grafik von diesem Terminal und bewerben
natürlich die Serie, man kann das Gerät nicht kaufen, aber ich fand das so,
hä, was wollt ihr denn von mir?
Und das ist ein schönes Beispiel für ein äußerst gelungenes Marketing,
was sie jetzt für diese zweite Staffel, die ja jetzt vor einigen Wochen erschienen
ist, nochmal richtig auf elf gedreht haben. Das ist ein Beispiel.
Du kannst auch im Apple Bookstore kannst du ein Buch finden,
was sich irgendwie findet und auch einen Brief.
Da gibt es nämlich zum Beispiel den Lexington Letter als E-Book und es gibt
auch ein Buch und auch als Hörbuch, was in dieser Serie eine Rolle spielt.
Das kannst du dir durchlesen.
Wie heißt es noch gleich? das Buch heißt oh Gott ich bin nicht vorbereitet,
ich schaue mal kurz hier The You You Are also sozusagen ein Buch,
was es eigentlich gar nicht gibt,
also was aus dieser Serie ist ja eine spirituelle Biografie wie es da so schön
heißt von einem angeblichen Rick and Hale, das ist halt einfach ein Schauspieler aus dieser,
Serie, das ist ja auch nur 39 Seiten lang, also das kann man sich so durchlesen,
das ist so, ja, erkenne dich selbst und bla bla bla, das ist alles ein bisschen
so esoterischer Quatschkram, aber das ist alles.
Pfiffige Hintergrundstory rund um diese Serie herum,
Und überhaupt ist in dieser Serie meiner Auffassung nach nahezu alles richtig gemacht worden.
Es handelt sich dabei um so eine Art Retro-Science-Fiction.
Man sieht ja auch schon diesen Terminal Pro an, das hat also einfach ganz harte
70er Jahre Vibes und ja, diese Terminals tauchen dort in dieser Serie auf und
spielen dort eine zentrale Rolle.
Die Tastatur ist sehr 70er, aber auch dieses, man hat da ein Bildschirm,
wo das Gehäuse nicht mal so groß ist wie der Bildschirm, der da eingebaut ist.
Und rechts ist noch Platz, wo bei einem Fernseher der damaligen Zeit vielleicht
noch der Lautsprecher wäre oder irgendwelche anderen. Es ist schön gemacht.
Ja, auch der CRT noch so mit maximaler Krümmung und so weiter.
Also überhaupt in den 80er Jahren, da hat es ja dann schon sehr viel flachere
CRTs, so Nitrinitronen und so weiter. Die haben ja durch verschiedene Tricks.
Ja, langsam so ein bisschen, ja.
Ja, aber hier hast du noch so diese Extremverzerrung. Es gibt ja auch dieses
schöne Terminalprogramm, wie heißt es noch gleich, auf dem Mac,
was so alte Terminals simuliert.
Cathode hieß das.
Cathode.
Das gibt es aber schon eine Weile nicht mehr.
Oh, gibt es nicht mehr?
Nee, nee.
Echt?
Aber es gibt einen,
Open-Source-Klon davon, den ich jetzt wahrscheinlich auf die...
Bist du dir sicher, dass es das nicht mehr gibt? Das war doch fantastico.
Weil der Entwickler das nicht weiterentwickelt hat.
Ach, das ist ja doof.
Aber wie gesagt, es gab da noch... Ich habe da gerne mit rumgespielt,
weil es irgendwie so... Ich meine, es war so ein bisschen schwierig.
Genau, cool Retro-Term.
Ist das Programm was ich meine,
Das ist so ein Open-Source-Ding, was im Wesentlichen ähnliche Features hat. CRT, cool, Retro-Term.
Indie-Show-Nose, bitte.
Ja, ich muss jetzt mal gucken. About cool, Retro-Term.
Okay, so, Secret Geometry. Oh, Domain-Name ist nicht mehr da. Oh Gott, das ist ja böse.
Ja, ja.
Ja, na gut, aber Severance. So, wie rede ich jetzt über eine Serie,
über die ich nichts verraten möchte?
Also erstmal totale Empfehlung ich garantiere euch,
keine Enttäuschung insbesondere nicht bei den Finales der beiden Staffeln,
die bisher erschienen sind diese Sendung ist so irre und ich würde jetzt mal so weit gehen Ralf,
darin darfst du mich auch gerne messen Aber Severance ist wirklich so das Twin
Peaks der aktuellen Zeit.
Das ist einfach ein Storytelling, das reißt nochmal ganz neue Wunden auf und
dieses Spiel der ganzen psychologischen, humanistischen Fragestellungen,
die mit dieser Severance-Prozedur,
mit wer bin ich, was bin ich, wann bin ich, was, was darf ich sein.
Ja, es wird das Leben dieser Innis und dieser Autis halt irgendwie separat verhandelt
und dabei entstehen halt einfach zahlreiche.
Kollateralschäden, Mysterien werden die ganze Zeit aufgedeckt,
man fragt sich, worum geht es denn hier eigentlich überhaupt und immer wenn
man denkt so, okay, jetzt komme ich hier so langsam auf die Spur,
kommt die nächste Folge raus, die nochmal so ein komplett neues Ding aufmacht,
aber nichts ist so völlig,
überzogen und völlig überdreht oder so, dass man sagen würde,
ja okay, jetzt wolltet aber hier irgendwie mal einen dicken machen und irgendwie
ablenken oder keine Ahnung oder jetzt ist es mit euch irgendwie durchgegangen,
sondern man merkt einfach bei jedem Detail,
wie gut abgeschmeckt und abgestimmt das auf alles andere ist.
Alles spielt mit allem mit.
Es ist eine perfekte Ansammlung. Erstmal ist es cinematografisch hervorragend gemacht.
Der Sound, die Farben spielen alle eine Rolle, codieren Dinge und lassen einen Dinge dekodieren.
Allein schon das Theme, das...
Anfangsmelodie, das Main Theme dieser Serie ist großartig und spielt mit diesem
Inni und Outi Ding, in dem es mit Moll und Dur-Akkorden die irgendwie als,
asymmetrisch sagen, als disharmonische Kombinationen zusammengeworfen werden
und einfach ein irres Klangbild abgeben.
Es ist einfach ich bin einfach begeistert von Severance.
Falls es noch nicht rübergekommen ist. Ich kann euch das zutiefst ans Herz legen.
Ich habe dann auch noch etwas gemacht, was ich auch noch nie gemacht habe.
Ich habe mir nämlich in der zweiten, also erstmal habe ich die erste Staffel
habe ich mir einfach angeschaut und fand es dann irre.
Ich fand es schon fast scary und ich kann mir echt gut in die Hosen machen bei solchen Serien.
Also so bestimmte Sachen, vor allem wenn es dann immer mit dem Blut und dem
Wasser übertreiben sie es ja dann oft immer alle, aber auch ansonsten,
es gibt schon so Momente, wo man sich denkt, kann ich mir das überhaupt angucken?
Erste Folge habe ich dann so angeschaut und war beeindruckt von der Auflösung dieser ersten Staffel.
Dann kam halt die zweite, das hat jetzt drei Jahre gedauert,
das war jetzt halt alles nochmal mit den ganzen Produktionsverzögerungen nach Corona und so weiter.
Die haben das ja 2020 angefangen zu drehen und das ging natürlich dann nicht
schnell und deswegen dauerte das alles ewig.
Und jetzt ist natürlich die zweite Staffel mit viel Fanfare eröffnet worden,
weil vorher wusste ja keiner, was ist.
Okay, Ben Stiller kennen irgendwie alle, der macht jetzt irgendwie so eine Serie,
was kann der denn eigentlich?
Stellt sich raus, absolut Masterclass, was er da abgeliefert hat.
Und die zweite Staffel ist natürlich jetzt schon mit den ganzen Leuten,
die sich bei der ersten angezündet haben, natürlich schon ganz gut umrangt gewesen.
Dann haben sie ja diese Aktion gemacht, das habt ihr vielleicht mitbekommen,
wo sie diese Bürosituation, die dort immer wieder zu sehen ist in dieser Serie,
in diesem Bahnhof in New York, in diesem Grand Central,
mitten in diese Haupthalle reingebaut haben, wo in so einem Glaskasten alle
Leute drüber rumstanden, eine Riesenaufregung gesorgt hat.
Zurecht. Ja, Supercast, einfach nach,
Science-Fiction mag, wer mysteriösen Kram mag und wer vor allem es feiern kann,
wenn mal irgendwas mal so richtig, richtig gut ist und zwar auf allen Achsen,
wo die Story stimmt und von der Typografie bis zur Farbgebung alles auf eine
Art und Weise durchdacht ist, dass es einem fast den Kopf platzen lässt,
dann ist Severance eure Serie, die ihr unbedingt gucken müsst. Wahnsinn.
Tja,
Also Claudia und ich haben halt die ersten drei Folgen geguckt und wir sind
beide da nicht so richtig reingekommen.
Von daher ist halt die Frage so ändert das dann nochmal irgendwie den Sog,
den Appeal, das was da irgendwie so passiert?
Die ganze erste Staffel ist eigentlich nur der Prolog für das Spiel,
was dann in der zweiten Staffel erst so richtig in Fahrt kommt.
Also du weißt eigentlich erst am Ende der ersten Staffel, wo du bist.
Und ich sag euch, schaut euch das an, ihr werdet es sonst zutiefst bereuen.
Das ist Weltkulturerbe, was da abgeliefert wird.
Na gut, also wir erinnern uns hier The Expanse, wo ich ja die Losung rausgegeben
habe, wenn man die ersten drei Folgen überlebt hat, dann ist es danach episch.
Ja, also wir Wir haben das auf der Watchliste, wir werden das nochmal ausprobieren.
Also was mich da ein bisschen, glaube ich, nicht so gecatcht hat,
ist, ich bin schon jemand, der halt gerne Charaktere mag.
Ja, ja.
Und da macht es einem so dieser Cast, der da aufgefahren wird,
mindestens halt in den ersten drei Folgen, einfach mal nicht so leicht.
Also da ist so wenig Identifikationsprojektionsfläche so.
Die leben halt alle irgendwie in einer sehr seltsamen Art.
Das sind auch so Sachen, warum ich so Filme wie dein Lieblingsfilm Brasil nicht
besonders mag, weil die auch in so einer schrägen,
komischen Welthabitus-Sache gefangen sind, zu der ich wenig relaten kann.
Ich befürchte, dass.
Gerade das Charakter-Development hier ist irre du wirst einfach überrascht werden
das ist einfach das baut sich gezielt über viele Episoden auf und lange Zeit denkst du dir,
Leute was worauf wollt ihr hinaus was bitte was ist los und irgendwann dann
öffnen sich einfach die Tore und denkst dir so, was zur Hölle.
Gerade Character Development, also was hier teilweise die uninteressanten Charakters
sind in diesem Büro, diese Inis,
diese Leute ohne Vergangenheit, die sozusagen in dieser Bürowelt im Nichts leben.
Das ist halt gerade das Spiel zumal, wenn man später dann auch mehr von ihren Autis erfährt,
das hast du nach drei Folgen ja noch gar nicht gesehen da wird es dann halt
interessant weil du nämlich dieselben Personen hast, die aber auf einmal zwei
verschiedene Personen sind die voneinander aber gar nichts wissen,
Aber vielleicht im Verlauf die Gelegenheit dazu bekommen auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise.
Und was ist überhaupt mit diesem Unternehmen und worum geht es denn auch?
Und vor allem, es gibt einfach Folgen, da guckst du dir an und denkst dir so,
bitte habt ihr sie noch alle?
Das ist ja irre. Das ist einfach crazy.
Das ist einfach geil. Ich lege meine Hand ins Feuer für Severance.
Ich poste mal kurz noch einen Link,
wo jemand so einen Lumen Terminal in 3D-Druck gebaut hat mit Display.
Es ist so ein Kult, diese Folge und die Memetik der Sätze, die in dieser Folge ist.
Es gibt einfach so viele Sätze, die werden wir noch in 30 Jahren,
wenn wir die noch rezitieren, weil die einfach so cool sind.
Weil es einfach durch diese Serie einen Kultstatus erreichen wird.
Ich verrate einfach gar nichts. Ich sage euch einfach nur, jede Zeit,
die ihr da rein investiert, wird es sich lohnen.
Aber du würdest schon sagen, dass in den ersten drei Folgen dann keine dieser
Kult-Sätze auftaucht, oder?
Also manche merkt man erst sozusagen durch Repetitionen, dass sie so diesen Kultstatus erlangen.
Das baut sich halt alles sehr langsam und gediegen auf.
Ja und im Nachgang ist es dann halt sehr interessant eben, weil so Aspekte es gibt viele,
ich habe ein paar verlinkt für Leute, die sagen wir mal,
also wer sich gar nicht spoilern lassen will, sollte sich sozusagen das nicht
vorher angucken, zumindest nicht nach der ersten Staffel so,
aber es gibt sehr schöne Analysen über die Musik, es gibt sehr schöne Analysen über die Grafik
Gestaltung, über die Farbgestaltung über die Typografie bei Severance, die,
alle auf vielen Ebenen total outstanding ist.
Ja genau, und dann halt diese ganzen Begleitwerke, wie dieser Lexington Letter
und dieses Buch und so weiter, das gehört hier alles sozusagen dazu.
Und dann gibt es auch noch einen achtstündigen, genau für einen Arbeitstag,
einen achtstündigen Soundtrack.
Music Tour Refined Tour.
Diese Gruppe ist ja, das kann man auch sagen, ist ja sozusagen dieses,
Data Refinement, das ist ja das, was sie dort betreiben, ist auch eine sehr
interessante Tätigkeit, ja,
Data Refinement, was auch immer das ist, ja, aber sie sind in dieser Abteilung,
Data Refinement und hier gibt es dann einen schönen Soundtrack,
acht Stunden lang Severance Music to Refine, die kannst du dann laufen lassen
und dann kannst du dann nebenbei deine Daten refinen.
Ja, also ich werde das ausprobieren. Ich werde berichten.
Ich sage nur, ich habe auch ein großes Herz mittlerweile im vorgerückten Alter
für Serien, die einem in der ersten Folge der ersten Season schon voll ins Gesicht springen.
Nein, nein, nein.
Das habe ich auch gerne. Also wer da mal ein Beispiel haben möchte,
die erste Folge der ersten Season von Fargo, der Serie.
Also es gab ja Fargo, den Kultfilm von den Cone-Brüdern.
Und wenn ihr glaubt, der Film war gut, dann guckt euch mal die erste Folge der ersten Season an.
Und dann wisst ihr, wie man meiner Meinung nach eine Serie starten sollte.
Ja, John Totoro, der hier eine dieser Rollen spielt, ist ja auch einer der Stammgäste
bei Fargo, bei den Kohn-Brüdern.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er auch bei Fargo mitgespielt hat. Weiß ich nicht. Auf jeden Fall bei,
Big Lebowski und weiß nicht ganz genau, mindestens einen Film,
vielleicht sogar noch mehrere.
Ich glaube, er gehört so ein bisschen zu den Stamm- Schauspielern bei den Kohn-Brüdern.
Und ja. Habe ich irgendwas vergessen? Ich habe alle Links zu den Büchern drin.
Da gibt es dann die ganze Lore, wie ich gelernt habe, das Wort.
Richtig, richtig. Immer gut.
Da ist jetzt viel Lore zu holen. Ach Ralf, das wird so schön werden.
Ich freue mich jetzt schon für dich.
Vor allem in deine Zweifel rein. Ich kann es sehr gut verstehen.
Ich weiß auch, wie ich mich nach drei Episoden gefühlt habe.
Aber ich weiß halt auch, dass hier eine Menge geht. Und die Schauspieler sind wirklich fantastisch.
Also das ist einfach eine gute Wahl.
Nicht so gecastet mit, dass man jetzt hier irgendwelche Superstars haben will,
sondern einfach Leute genommen, die einfach unheimlich gut in diese Rollen reinpassen,
die sie dort ausfüllen und,
Da hat Apple auf jeden Fall einen Knaller gelandet. Und es ist ja jetzt schon
viel populärer als ihre bisher erfolgreichste Serie. Dieses Ted Lasso,
das war ja schon sehr komisch.
Und Severance ist aber jetzt die unangefochtene Nummer 1.
Aber nicht, was Zuschauer ansieht. Da ist das Verhältnis bestimmt 20 zu 1. Also Ted Lasso ist ja...
Nein, nein, Severance ist die meistgesehene Serie jetzt bei Apple TV.
Das ist doch grober Unfug. Wenn du jetzt gerade guckst, vielleicht aber insgesamt
nie, nicht ansatzweise, kommt das an Ted Lasso ran.
Das ist das, was sie selber sagen. Doch, doch, doch.
Severance ist eine Bewegung. Wir werden von Severance noch viel hören.
Und das ist, wie ich schon sagte, das ist unser Twin Peaks der aktuellen Zeit.
Okay, über Geschmack lässt sich streiten, aber nicht mehr die Freakshow.
Wir haben jetzt schon ein ganz gut Programm hier gemacht, dafür,
dass wir meine Sendung haben ausfallen lassen.
Haben wir ganz gut aufgeholt. Wollen wir noch irgendwas besprechen oder seid
ihr am Ende eurer Kräfte?
Ich bin, glaube ich, am Ende.
Ja, ich bin auch so ein bisschen am Ende.
Ein bisschen am Ende.
Ja, ein bisschen mehr als nur ein bisschen.
Aber Was soll ich denn da sagen?
Weiß ich nicht. Sag, was du sagen möchtest.
Ich dachte, er ist nichts zu, aber ich habe wenig Schlaf gesehen und war vor
30 Stunden noch in Vietnam.
Ich konnte nicht landen, weil es Nebel war in Berlin. So fing das hier irgendwie
an. Kaum kam ich zurück. Schon war Nebel.
Kommst du zurück, was ist? Gestreikt wird. Brücke kaputt. S-Bahn fährt nicht richtig.
Ja.
Gleich wieder fressen in der S-Bahn und so. Da dachte ich mir auch,
was mache ich hier eigentlich?
Das war schon, also der Tag, an dem sie dann die Brücke tatsächlich gesperrt
haben, war schon sehr interessant, weil ich, da war ich im Office und unser
Office ist 200 Meter Luftlinie von dieser Brücke weg.
Sprich, die gesamte Blechlawine hat sich um das Office herum gelaviniert und
ich bin echt auf Biegen und Brechen nicht nach Hause gekommen.
Ich habe zwei Stunden gebraucht.
Stimmt, du bist ja voll betroffen. Krass. Tja, ich sag ja, Zweirad ist die Zukunft.
Und es war so lustig, ich hatte bei uns im Firmen-Zlack so ein Bild davon gepostet,
wie mir die TomTom-App rund ums Office halt alle Straßen rot gemacht hat und
dann so nach der Art, setzt mal eure Erwartungshaltungen,
ob ihr jetzt gut nach Hause kommt oder nicht.
Mal, würde ich mal dran arbeiten.
Und dann halt ganz viele, oh mein Gott, Emojis unter dem Beitrag.
Und ein Kollege macht so ein Thread auf und klemmt einfach so den Link zu,
ach übrigens, wir verkaufen ja jetzt auch E-Bikes.
Das war schon, das war schon sehr geil. So einfach den Link auf die E-Bike-Verkaufsseite, das war schon.
Also hiermit beliebteste Apple-Serie, nach dem was Apple hier rausgibt,
ist es vom 17. Januar bis 17.
Februar gemessen. Also da würde ich jetzt wieder zweimal hingucken,
so was sie da eigentlich mit welcher Ted Lasso-Staffel vergleichen und die Gesamtzuschauerzahl und so.
Das scheint mir ehrlich gesagt wieder so ein Apple-Marketing Statistik-Dingsi
zu sein mit Charts, wo keine Zahlen dran stehen und so, wir kennen das.
Severance ist das Größte, was sie rausgebracht haben. Das ist einfach, das wird...
Ja, das ist doch keine Familienunterhaltung. Du gewinnst nie mit so einer dystopischen
Science-Fiction-Geschichte gegen Familienfeelgood.
It's the shit. Believe me.
Naja gut, aber ich meine Apple TV Plus ist natürlich auch auf einem anderen
Niveau als so ein Disney Plus.
Das ist schon für Leute, die ein bisschen so spezielles Zeug suchen.
Wenn du Familienunterhaltung willst, bist du Disney Plus besser aufgehoben.
Apple gibt nämlich gar keine Zahlen raus, wie viele Leute irgendwas gucken. Absolute Zahlen.
Warum wohl?
Nun gut.
Officially Apple TV's most watched show in history.
Genau und genau den Beitrag hatte ich auch und dann guckst du rein und dann
ist die in history 17. Januar bis 17. Februar.
That's not my understanding of history.
That's not your piece of history.
Und alle Artikel berufen sich auf exakt dieses eine Interview von einem Executive
irgendwas, der diese eine Aussage gemacht hat. ohne absolute Zahlen zu irgendwas.
Naja, ist ja auch am Ende nicht so wichtig.
Das ist ein Paywall-Artikel, der hier verlinkt wird. Den kann ich jetzt gar
nicht bewerten. Oder? Ach nee, warte mal, man muss nur was wegklicken.
Lass uns den Sack zumachen. Das wird doch nichts mehr.
Ja, ich...
Drew the highest number of unique viewers in Apple TV history from January,
17th February 17th 2025. Das heißt, in diesem In einem Monat haben mehr Leute
Severance geguckt als irgendeine andere Serie, vermutlich in irgendeinem Vergleichsmonat.
So, wenn du dann aber guckst, Ted Lesso, Laufzeit, vier Seasons,
seit irgendwie sechs Jahren unterwegs.
Ich habe da Zweifel, aber ist ja egal.
Das heißt ja nicht, dass es nicht trotzdem eine tolle Serie sein muss.
Na, hier beziehen sie sich noch
auf 589 Millionen Minuten Viewed in the US over all existing episodes.
Können wir diese Diskussion lassen, bitte?
Naja, ich will ja mich hier nicht hinstellen und irgendwas behaupten,
was so nie gesagt wurde, auch wenn ich das so verstanden habe.
Aber das können wir ja nochmal nachforschen.
Wenn sie das noch nicht ist, dann ist sie das auf jeden Fall danach.
Gut. Das war's. Freakshow 290. Haben wir das überhaupt schon erwähnt? Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, du sagtest 91.
Nee, ich glaube, du sagtest gar keine Nummer.
Doch, du hast eine Nummer gesagt.
Nee, ich glaube auch keine Nummer gesagt. Das ist aber die 290.
Und das heißt auch, dass wir bald eine 300 haben. Was machen wir denn damit?
Ausfallen lassen.
301, 200.
Nein, auf keinen Fall. Das habe ich mal bei Chaos Radio gemacht.
Das war eine ganz schlechte Idee.
300. This is Sparta, sage ich nur.
Ja, wann wäre denn das? Das wäre so 10, das wäre so gegen Ende des Jahres, wäre das so.
Ja, dann machen wir die Sparta-Weihnachtsfolge oder so.
Jetzt schreit ihr nachher im Kongress.
Saal 1. Seid ihr bereit?
Einmal Rampensau, immer Rampensau. An mir soll es nicht scheitern.
Na gut, machen wir jetzt endlich hier Deckel drauf. Ihr merkt schon,
die anderen, die können gar nicht mehr.
Und dann muss man es ja auch nicht weiter vertiefen, oder?
Gut, ihr guckt alle schön Severance, lernt Programmieren mit Cursor.
Ihr habt es ja alle in der Frickshow gelernt, wie sich das gehört.
Genau, das ist das cool Retro-Term.
Ikea boykottieren es jetzt.
Also, tschüss Leute.
Tschüss.